pas de problème cher gérard leur paraît
léger et nous allons pouvoir commencer
cette séance
les dames et messieurs chers collègues
parlementaires
chers invités chères
concitoyens concitoyennes pour celles et
ceux qui ne suivent en ligne
nous voici sur le point de commencer
cette audition publique sur les effets
indésirables de la vaccination coville
19 je vous prie d'excuser le premier
vice président de l'opecst sts gérard
longuet qui a été retenu
et je voudrais pour commencer poser
quelques éléments de contexte
les personnes clés dans cette audition
pour le fils sont les trois rapporteurs
ici présents gérard le seul en virtuel
qui vient d'arriver ce n'est le poète et
florence lassarade que je présenterai
dans quelques instants pour rappel
l'opex a été saisi le 9 février 2022 par
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
pour un rapport sur les effets
secondaires les effets indésirables des
vaccins contre le coc vite 19 cette
saisine de la commission des affaires
sociales faisait suite à une pétition
citoyenne
déposées sur le site du sénat avec des
dizaines de milliers de signatures qui a
donc entraîné une réaction de la part de
la conférence des présidents du sénat
qui a donc confié à la commission des
affaires sociales le soin de préparer
d'instruire le dossier par voie de
rapports et la commission des affaires
sociales a confié à l'opecst sts qui est
à la fois assemblée nationale et sénat
le soin de réaliser l'instruction de ce
dossier à travers des auditions
audition privé auditions publiques comme
il est d'usagé et de préparer un rapport
le contexte était singulièrement
compliquée par les échéances électorales
avec une fin de mandature
l'instruction de dossiers qui sera
forcément à cheval entre la mandature
sortante et la mandature qui arrivent
pour les députés la nécessité de
représenter adéquatement toutes les
sensibilités politiques au sein des
rapporteurs nous a conduits après
discussions avec les différents groupes
parlementaires à ce que le les trois
rapporteurs disponibles pour cette
instruction prépare un rapport d'étape
préliminaires d'ici la fin de l'actuelle
mandature sans doute en juin et à ce que
l'instruction soit complétée par un
panel de rapporteur éventuellement
élargie
après les élections législatives
cela évidemment est une solution
plus complexe que ce qui a pu se faire
dans d'autres auditions mais le
particularité du calendrier le fait que
la saisine tomber juste avant les
élections législatives et le fait que le
fils est bicaméral et que nous tenons à
ce que députés et sénateurs instruisent
les dossiers conjointement ne nous
laissait pas d'autre choix
le 28 mars les auditions ont commencé
avec autour de la table trois des quatre
rapporteurs sur la stratégie vaccinale
c'est une mission de l'opex qui avait
commencé en 2020 et 3 des rapporteurs
était disponible et prêt à étendre leur
saisine pour traiter ce dossier il
s'agit du député gérard le seul groupe
socialiste qui sera présent avec nous en
visioconférence de la sénatrice florence
lassarade groupe lr qui est ici à nos
côtés est juste à ma droite de la
sénatrice sonia de la provôté de l'union
centriste ils vont en début de table
ronde vous faire un point sur les
auditions tels qu'ils ont pu les
réaliser des dizaines d'heures
d'entretiens qui ont été réalisés dans
un format privé et qu'ils auront permis
d'appréhender les tenants et
aboutissants les difficultés et
d'approfondir déjà les dossiers
presque tous les intervenants
aujourd'hui dans cette table ronde
publique ont déjà été entendus en
audition privé
le format public permet d'élargir le
débat est également donne la possibilité
aux citoyens qui le souhaitent de poser
des questions via une plateforme dédiée
pas directement c'est moi qui me
chargerai de
répertorier sélectionner certaines des
questions qui sont posées il y en a
beaucoup en particulier des questions
qui sont les plus
favorisés les plus aimés et puis slick
et si vous voulez et nous pourrons ainsi
participé à donner une ouverture
citoyenne à cette audition publique
encore plus que ça n'aurait été le cas
pour l'édition fermé
j'insiste sur deux points ça fait partie
à la fois des habitudes de l'opecst sts
et de la feuille de route qui nous est
donné par la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat que les débats se
fassent bien dans contradictoires et que
nous prenions le temps d'écouter les
parties prenantes et en particulier
celles qui ont été citées par la
pétition citoyenne qui a déclenché cette
saisine et la deuxième le mât deuxième
remarque là la lettre de mission nous
enjoignent et à
mettre en place les conditions d'un
débat serein et approfondi fondée sur la
science est donnée objectifs
conformément à nos traditions
débat approfondi je l'espère débat
serein l'expérience a déjà montré que
non la tension qui a présidé à la tenue
de ces échanges privés comme publics et
juste inédite dans tout cas dans toute
l'histoire de l'office que j'ai connus
inédite dans les cinq dernières années
je reçois à peu près 1000 mails par jour
quotidiennement sur ce sujet et la façon
dont la les
interpellations sont venus de façon très
forte sur beaucoup de positions parfois
pour dire que nous ne devrions pas même
écouter tel ou tel intervenant au
contraire pour dire que nous bâillonnant
tel ou tel intervenants ont contribué à
instaurer au cours de cette instruction
un climat assez tendu
dont les rapporteurs ont tâché de faire
abstraction
je garantis ici le fait que les
rapporteurs sont arrivés ici dans ce
contexte sans a priori avec le souci de
prendre en charge tous les aspects de
cette audition de cette instruction le
plus complètement possible
et avec un esprit ouvert et je
souhaiterais que il en soit possible que
ces sont ses ambitions que nous
puissions respecter au cours des
échanges et des débats que nous allons
avoir aujourd'hui
je vous propose de passer en début de
table ronde et je vais donner la parole
aux rapporteurs pour nous faire un
compte-rendu
forcément extrêmement succinct au vu de
la grande quantité d'audition un
compte-rendu préliminaire de ce qu'ils
ont retenu deux si on trouvait le plus
saillant au cours de leur audition
moi qui vais démarrer depuis maintenant
presque 18 mois nous travaillons
largement sur le sujet la vaccination
contre le coc ville a fait partie de nos
instruments de lutte contre la pandémie
à l'heure actuelle près de 80% de la
population française a reçu une primo
vaccination complète et plus de 5 9%
reçu une dose de rappel cependant
plusieurs sujets d'inquiétude ont émergé
dans la population avec en trame de fond
la question de la sécurité de ces
vaccins la rapidité avec laquelle ont
été mis au point les vaccins
actuellement disponibles la technique
sur laquelle reposent certains d'entre
eux et l'évolution de leurs indications
suite à des effets indésirables avéré
également au fait que la
la durée d'efficacité du vaccin était
limité dans le temps des doutes ont
également bien sûr été émis quant à l'
efficacité nous on avait entendu ainsi
avec mes deux co-rapporteurs ici
présents nous nous sommes emparés du
sujet en réalisons en réalisant un très
large cycle d'auditions qui nous a
permis d'entendre plus de 50
intervenants partie prenante de cette
question à des titres variés nous avons
eu à coeur d'entendre tant les acteurs
institutionnels la pharmacovigilance
et de la campagne de vaccination que des
problèmes que des professionnels de
santé des chercheurs et des voix
critiques quant à la campagne de
vaccination casema de scientifiques ou
de représentants de personnes victimes
d'effets indésirables nous avons
identifié trois axes d'étude pour
assurer notre mission de contrôle et
répondre à la demande qui nous a été
formulée nous sommes intéressés d'abord
au système d'évaluation et de
surveillance des vaccins afin de nous
assurer de leur efficacité leur bon
fonctionnement au cours de la crise
sanitaire et de l'adaptation d'un
fonctionnement au caractère inédit de
cette campagne vaccinale
ensuite aux principaux signaux d'effets
indésirables à leur prévalence à leur
gravité ainsi qu'à la manière dont ils
avaient été identifiés pris en compte
par les autorités sanitaires dans les
recommandations vaccinales
enfin à l'organisation de la campagne de
vaccination et à la place des effets
indésirables dans la communication qui
l'accompagné le sujet est vaste et nous
concentrerons l'audition de ce jour sur
certains points sur lesquels ils
subsistent des interrogations cette
audition publique capté et diffusé en
direct sur le site du sénat portera
principalement sur la déclaration
l'analyse et la communication autour des
effets indésirables des vaccins contre
lacko vide et s'organisera en deux temps
dans un premier temps nous interrogerons
les acteurs institutionnels en charge de
la pharmacovigilance et de la campagne
vaccinale sur plusieurs sujets qui ont
attiré notre attention au cours de notre
premier cycle d'auditions dans un second
temps un moment d'échangé aura lieu avec
des scientifiques qui auront pu avoir
une voix critique quant à l'analyse la
prise en compte et la communication des
effets indésirables des vaccinations
contre la colline 19 je précise pour les
internautes qui nous suivent à distance
qui leur est possible de poser des
questions par l'intermédiaire de la
plate forme dont le lien figure sur les
pages internet de l'office sur les sites
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
dans la mesure du possible nous
tenterons de relayer un certain nombre
de ces questions dans les débats que
nous aurons avec les intervenants des
différentes tables rondes c'est à mon
collègue gérard le seul s'ils le
souhaitent de prendre le relais
très bien merci beaucoup chers collègues
je vous prie d'excuser mon absence
physique mais je vous parle je puis
l'assemblée nationale voilà donc nous
sommes à un office big and assemblé sont
bien présentes physiquement 6 punir donc
pour la première partie de cette
audition nous rejetons bernard s'est dit
responsable de la task force vaccination
et qui représentera la direction
générale de la santé küttel attigny
directrice générale group agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé accompagnée
rosemary puniet directrice de la
communication et des
civilisations
ces lignes de monnier directrice de la
surveillance et
du format combine finances risque à 7 un
comité de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
je le prie de m'excuser si vous dira pas
tout à fait correctement mais nous
accueillons aussi il ya une pierre
joinville berra président du réseau des
centres régionaux de pharmacovigilance
micallef sophie gautier va dernier grâce
qu'on pète et chant belle champel pardon
et marina adventure membres des crp vert
à porter des différents vaccins et enfin
alain fischer président de commune du
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale et je vous remercie très
chaleureusement toutes et tous de
participer à cette audition alors étant
donné que le temps est contraire je vais
entrer dans le vif du sujet en posant
d'emblée quelques questions dans
quelques séries de questions tout
d'abord concernant des autorisations de
mise le marché au cours de nos
différentes auditions nous avons compris
l'intérêt la légitimité qu'il ya eut
accordé des autorisations de mise sur le
marché
conditionnel au vaccin ceci étant un
point d'échauffement pouvez vous nous
indiquer comment s'est déroulé le
processus de renouvellement de ces mêmes
conditionnelle et de nouvelles données
de sécurité d'efficacité des vaccins
notamment contre les nouveaux variants
honte a été demandée par certains
d'entre vous ont laboratoire
s'agissant des données de sécurité nous
avons retenu que les essais cliniques
n'était pas encore terminée et que les
laboratoires s'était engagé en donner
les résultats finaux dès qu'ils font
il nous a été rapporté qu'une partie des
personnes figurant
sont concernés par cette dérogation la
procédure et quelle incidence cela
aura-t-il sur la validité des essais
cette dérogation était reçu
l'autorisation préalable des agences
sanitaires d'évaluation et se lasse de
votre point de vue peut-il remettre en
cause la possibilité d'obtention d'une
la mm pleine et entière pour les vaccins
concernés voient la première série de
questions et si vous voulez bien nous
reposer une cheville tout à l'heure je
cède la parole
merci par avance de la réponse et puis
vu le temps à parti d'aller à
l'essentiel
si gérard je propose que l'on fasse tous
nos propos introductif parce que vous
avez reçu la liste des questions tous
donc on l'est on les présente parce que
c'est une audition publique de pardon
pardon gérard petit coupé ton micro s'il
te plait
ou tu continues schirrhein rouge prend
le relais c'est comme
le relais très bien d'accord ok j'ai
coupé ton micro cher gérard c'est très
bien merci
l'autre série de la seconde série de
questions concerne la fameuse évaluation
de la balance bénéfice risque dont on
sait qu'elle est finalement au coeur de
tous les sujets
parce qu'elle est elle formule les
recommandations donc par tranche d'âge
par catégorie de
2,2 d'usagé
et en fonction des risques qui ont été
identifiés elle est réalisée par la
haute autorité de santé et
au cours de cette pandémie c'est le
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale qui a accompagné ces décisions
l'autre sujet qui est à l'origine de
tensions c'est l'utilisation de données
dite de vie réelle pour mieux
caractériser les vaccins et formuler ou
ajuster les recrues-stars les
recommandations puisque finalement là et
même conditionnelle repose aussi sur sur
ce sujet là les recommandations
vaccinales notamment en ce qui concerne
leur efficacité contre les formes graves
où la mortalité
est donc on entend des critiques que
qu'on reprend pas à notre compte on se
fait le rapporteur de ce qu'on entend
quand même je précise à chaque fois le
cadre des questions la critique porte à
la fois sur le fait que ces études sont
à niveau de preuve moines que les essais
cliniques randomisés contrôlés mais
aussi sur le fait que ces données sont
obtenus à posteriori mais ce qui est
factuelle par rapport à la situation
dans laquelle les vaccins sont arrivés
et donc c'est un fait nouveau est d'une
ampleur inégalée au niveau international
et qui touche un nombre très important
de citoyens donc on est dans une
situation
qui est à ce titre tout à fait
particulière
et donc vers la question qui revient ce
qui l'est plus reese est prudent de
vacciner les personnes en bonne santé en
l'état actuel des connaissances après
les plusieurs vagues qu'on a subies et
en étant à ce niveau finalement
d'immunité collective entre ceux qui
entrent contracté le virus et ceux qui
ont eu plusieurs doses vaccinales et
donc quel type de réponse à a proposé
aux personnes qui peuvent être inquiète
ce sujet
légitimement ou non suivant les points
de vue le point de vue du jeu sur lequel
on se positionne en tant que
parlementaire nous n'avons pas vocation
à nous exprimer quand à la positivité ou
non de la balance bénéfice risque
d'autant plus qu'en plus est d'autant
plus qu'elle est très évolutive et on
l'a bien vu elle a été extrêmement
évolutif d'abord les virus évoluent la
contagiosité la dangerosité tout ça
évolue
lala le
la façon dont dont nos citoyens se
protègent ou pas et utilisent ou pas les
gestes barrière est un élément dans la
balance bénéfice risque bien évidemment
l'évolution de la connaissance en
matière de conséquences du virus en
matériaux conséquence des vaccinations
respectives
et donc tous ces éléments là font que on
chemine au fur et à mesure de la
diffusion et de la et de virus et dans
ses formes modifiées et et de la
vaccination cela ne nous empêche pas
nous interroger sur l'actualisation donc
de cette fameuse balance bénéfices
risques dont bien évidemment on a besoin
d'avoir peut-être une connaissance plus
fine peut-être plus transparents ou en
tout cas des éléments réguliers à
soumettre à soumettre
aux citoyens c'est un élément en tout
cas de transparents vu que toutes les
politiques repose sur cette balance
bénéfice-risque le processus en fin de
troisième set question concerne le
processus de pharmacovigilance on a
longuement auditionnés la une est saine
et crpv et puis faire on a eu le gip et
puis faire donc également les
professionnels aussi le point de vue des
professionnels pour la déclaration le
point de vue des usagers pour la
déclaration puisque tout cela participe
d'un tout
dans le processus de pharmacovigilance
et le le travail exceptionnel de 2 de
nombreux acteurs nombreux acteurs en
tradant salué ce travail exceptionnel
tant par le volume que par la
transparence et donc ces informations
régulières fournie par le réseau
l'examen des dossiers par des experts
des dossiers individuels l'examen dans
l'ensemble des faits que ces traces eux
reconnus aussi au plan international et
au niveau européen puisque on a quand
même en france des dossiers qui sont
particulièrement étayées sur le plan
médical
et donc c'est ce qui garantit d'ailleurs
la qualité du signal quand il a été
repéré au travers des procédures aux
actuels ce qui peut déboucher donc sur
une halle être comme ça a été le cas
pour les thromboses atypique apparu
il ya un avion qui décolle apparu avec
le vaccin astrazeneca pourtant nous
sommes et que étonné que par exemple les
troubles menstruels dont on parle
beaucoup beaucoup et depuis de nombreux
mois ne soit toujours pas reconnus comme
des effets indésirables s'éteint c'est
un rapport d'étonnement à vérin comment
cela est il possible commente il
commente il est finalement pour que cet
effet soient reconnus
saga sans gravité dans la majorité des
cas manifestement mais encore une fois
comme non reconnu on n'a pas non plus du
coup là la précision sur cette gravité
éventuels qui pourraient se voir chez
certaines femmes ces troubles interpelle
par leur part leur fréquence ils ont
inquiété les femmes c'est certain
puisque de l'est et notamment des jeunes
femmes qui ont été très inquiété par ce
sujet à qui on a affirmé que ce n'était
pas grave et donc la réponse du pas
grave et pas forcément une réponse
médicalement et scientifiquement étayé
sans qu'une explication approfondie ne
soit donnée et donc
ce sujet là peut ré pourrait apparaître
comme étant une dissimulation et
c'est à dire que c'est un élément
d'inquiétude d'étonnement et sur
laquelle évidemment un certain nombre de
nos concitoyennes n'ont pas eu de
réponse sous 2 ou de rassurance factuel
au même titre que d'autres que d'autres
sujets médicaux qui ont été évoqués dans
les effets indésirables donc ce sujet
nous amène logiquement à la dernière
série de questions qui concerne la
communication dont on a dit depuis le
début ont depuis le tout le début de le
premier rapport qui avait eu lieu avant
la halle de débuter la vaccination que
la communication était le noeud de tout
ce sujet à la fois de l'adhésion à la
fois de la transparence à la fois de la
connaissance de toutes les parties
prenantes au fur et à mesure du
déroulement de la vaccination
toute erreur de que de communication
peut se payer cher
il ya d'abord la communication vers le
grand public il faut pour inciter à
accepter la vaccination est bien sûr un
discours de vérité et c'est vrai que là
on tombe sur un écueil c'est à dire que
des effets secondaires indésirables
graves ou non gras qui arrivait sur
lesquels on est transparent peuvent être
aussi contre-productive par rapport à la
sollicitation de vaccination donc où
trouver les équilibres dans la
transparence néanmoins la transparence
est un élément essentiel d'adhésion est
en tout cas à posteriori
le fait d'avoir identifié non
transparence pourrait être complètement
délétère pour l'ensemble de la prise en
charge vaccinale et pas que pour l'aco
vite donc on a beaucoup de sujets de
santé publique il ya cette question-là
[Musique]
la balance bénéfices risques est un
outil intéressant et majeur à
transmettre et il l'a pas toujours été
lisible en tout cas pour le grand public
que chacun n'a pas su dans quelle case
il se situer par rapport aux risques par
rapport au vaccin
il nous a été rapporté par exemple que
les notice imprimée sur feuilles
volantes qui devait être mise à
disposition des personnes se faisant
vacciner dans les centres de vaccination
ne l'ont pas toujours été donc en fait
déjà rien que ces notices là n'ont pas
été transmises avec la liste des effets
indésirables connus du vaccin
et donc ça c'est un sujet comment on
peut expliquer que finalement cette
dimension là n'a pas été complètement en
piste et de la même façon que les autres
considérant de la politique vaccinale
il ya il y à aussi la communication vers
les professionnels de santé alertée des
différences des effets indésirables en
cours d'étude pour guider leur prise en
charge et puis mieux conseiller les
passions savait que les médecins
traitant par exemple été le coeur du
réacteur de l'adhésion vaccinale on
l'avait dit dès le début et on sait ça
s'est avéré derrière réel et par exemple
la question des fameux dgs urgents qui
arrive à un nombre certain où un certain
nombre par jour qui traitent à la fois
techniques de logistique de
disponibilité vaccinale ou d'indications
vaccinale mais aussi d'informations
médicales pure ça c'est compliqué de
faire le tri pour un médecin généraliste
ou un professionnel de santé surtout ces
mails qui arrivait et dont on sait
qu'ils n'ont pas tous la même égale
importance en tout cas vis-à-vis de ces
questions de pharmacovigilance et de
détection d'effets secondaires voilà
donc tous et toutes ces questions
s'adressent à vous tous et
donc
voilà on vous laisse répondre dans
l'ordre que vous choisissez en tout cas
c'est notre président c'est pas
merci chers collègues
comme vous l'avez compris mon rôle ici
dans ce débat n'a pas été de faire le
travail de l'instruction fine des
dossiers tels que le fonds les
rapporteurs mais de vérifier que
l'ensemble
est bien en cours de route que les
auditions se déroulent que toutes les
postures sont suivis et maintenant je
vais m'occuper distribuer la parole donc
à nos intervenants ici dans cette
première table ronde nous demanderons de
répondre autant que possible parmi les
questions qui vous ont été posées par
les rapporteurs sur les autorisations de
mise sur le marché et leur
renouvellement sur l'évaluation et
l'actualisation de la balance
bénéfice-risque sur le procédure de
pharmacovigilance sur la communication
aussi bien grand public que pour les
professionnels
répondez à chaque fois à celle des
questions pour lesquelles vous vous
sentez légitime à vous exprimer et à
répondre et je vais commencer par donner
la parole à monsieur bernard celi
responsable de la task force vaccination
à la direction de la direction générale
de la santé dgs pardon monsieur celi
merci monsieur le président je tiens à
remercier les organisateurs la sénatrice
sonia de la provôté la sénatrice
florence lassarade et le député gérard
le seul de nous avoir convié cet après
midi à cette table ronde peut-être à
titre liminaire je souhaitais rappelé le
rôle de la task force son organisation
et puis donner quelques éléments
chiffrés sur la campagne de vaccination
la task force elle a été créée en
octobre 2020 avec comme objectif de
mettre en oeuvre de manière
opérationnelle la campagne de
vaccination voulue par le gouvernement
très concrètement un de ses objectifs
était d'assurer une forme de
coordination d'une part entre les
différents ministères qui étaient
concernés par la vaccination est
évidemment au premier au premier titre
le ministère des solidarités de la santé
également assuré au sein du ministère la
coordination entre les différentes
directions l'administration centrale la
direction générale de la santé mais
aussi la direction générale l'offre de
soins la direction générale de la
cohésion sociale
elle avait également pour ea l'a
toujours pour objectif au sein de la
sphère santé d'assurer une coordination
entre les différentes structures actives
dans la campagne de vaccination
s'agissant des autorités scientifiques
la haute autorité de santé et le conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
du professeur fisher également les
opérateurs de l'état santé publique
france pour la mise en oeuvre de la
logistique vaccinale est évidemment l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament
sur notamment les aspects da mêmes et de
pharmacovigilance
la task force est organisée en pôles
différents pôles un pôle qui assure la
stratégie vaccinale et qui élaborent
madame la sénatrice vous en parliez
notamment les dg assure jean qui fixe la
doctrine de vaccination on pourra
revenir sur la fréquence est évidemment
dans une période de crise il faut
produire de la doctrine pour informer
les professionnels de santé un pôle
approvisionnement en médicaments en
vaccins en l'occurrence qui interface
avec les laboratoires évidemment mais
également avec les la commission
européenne est donc là on est en amont
de l'approvisionnement en vaccins un
pôle qui en charge de la logistique
travaille beaucoup avec santé publique
france et qui lui assure la partie aval
et donc
l'acheminement des vaccins jusqu'au
centre de vaccination ou aux
professionnels de santé de ville qui
vaccinent on a également un pôle en
charge des systèmes d'information le
fameux système vaccin qu'ovide qui
permet d'enregistrer les vaccinations un
pôle territorial qui s'occupe des
interfaces avec les agences régionales
de santé les directeurs généraux des
agences évidemment mais aussi les
référents vaccination au sein des
agences
également avec les collectivités
territoriales
enfin un pool indicateur qui lui
monitor la campagne donc
s'assure que tous les chiffres qui sont
collectés ont du sens et permet de
communiquer de regarder des tendances de
modéliser également les différents
scénarios d'évolution de la campagne et
puis enfin un pôle communication on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler également qui
avait vocation à justement faire en
sorte qu'on communique de manière
appropriée autour de la campagne de
vaccination donc ça c'est pour
l'organisation globale de la de la task
force aujourd'hui la tasse forcée
environ 25 personnes à des moments plus
intenses delà de la campagne on était
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus nombreux
quelques mots de bilan sur la campagne
crois que c'est important de le
souligner donné quelques chiffres le
premier chiffre c'est peut-être le
nombre total d'injection cumulait
144,3 millions d'injections ont été
réalisés depuis le 27 décembre 2020
parmi ces 144 millions d'injections il
ya 54 4 millions de première injection
et 41,9 millions de rappels ce sont des
chiffres qui sont tout à fait
vertigineux et le directeur général de
la santé jérôme salomon indique souvent
qu'on n'a jamais autant vacciner dans
notre pays que depuis ses 18 derniers
mois au-delà des chiffres je pense qu'il
est important de rappeler que la
vaccination
ça correspond à une protection
importante de la population en
particulier des personnes les plus
fragiles
et les personnes les plus fragiles sont
les personnes âgées ce sont également
les personnes atteintes de comorbidité
et donc la vaccination elle a permis
d'éviter des drames humains elle a
permis d'éviter que des personnes
décèdent que des personnes se retrouvent
en réanimation et elle a permis
également au plus grand nombre d'entre
nous de retrouver progressivement une
vie normale et je crois que c'est
important cet après midi de le souligner
un mot également de comparaison
internationale puisque cette campagne de
vaccination elle a pas été fait au
niveau franco français évidemment tout
le monde le sait un grand nombre de pays
ont lancé des campagnes de vaccination
et cantons ce benchmark comme on dit
avec d'autres pays on constate que la
france a plutôt réussi une campagne de
vaccination très encourageante alors il
ya quelques pays qui en termes de
couverture en primo vaccination on
décide des chiffres plus plus plus élevé
je pense notamment à l'espagne ou à
l'italie a contrario la plupart des pays
européens affichent une campagne plutôt
moins bien réussi je pense notamment au
royaume uni à l'allemagne ou même à la
moyenne européenne qui est inférieure à
celles atteintes en france alors on part
de loin
cette comparaison internationale est
positive et on part de loin puisque en
décembre 2020 près de 60 % de nos
concitoyens avaient une forme de
réticences par amy par rapport à la
vaccination est donc il a fallu
améliorer ce taux d'adhésion au fur et à
mesure et ça c'est fait justement parce
que on a pu démontrer et convaincre de
la qualité de la sécurité des des
vaccins qui était proposé
la campagne de vaccination c'est une
prouesse humaine une prouesse semaine
parce que elle a mobilisé de nombreux
électeurs la vaccination au sein de la
sphère santé elle a conduit à
l'ouverture de centres de vaccination
massif dans lesquelles il ya eu un
véritable engouement pour aller
travailler contribué à cette production
à cette protection des plus des plus
fragiles les professionnels de santé de
ville se sont également largement
mobilisés et je crois qu'il faut
également le souligner et rendre hommage
à tous ces professionnels qui se sont
mobilisés alors il ya eu aussi des
prouesses des prouesses logistique la
mise en place d'un influent au début de
la campagne qui a permis d'apporter les
vaccins dans les ehpad des vaccins qui
se conserve à -80 de graisse était un
véritable défi logistique pour aller
protéger les personnes les plus fragiles
là où elle réside en évitant de l'est de
les déplacer comme ça a pu être le cas
dans d'autres pays on a également
apporté un peu plus tard les vaccins arn
messager je le redis qui se conserve à
-80 ou à -20 ce qui n'est pas classique
dans la chaîne pharmaceutique
il y en a apporté ces vaccins au plus
près des effecteurs donc en particulier
dans les pharmacies d'officine et ses
éléments ont contribué au succès de la
campagne de vaccination française donc
au final il faut souligner qu on a
mobilisé des vaccins sûrs et efficaces
et pour nous c'est le caractère sûr et
efficace il était attestée par des
autorisation délivrée par des
institutions indépendantes le m&a au
niveau européen la haute autorité de
santé au niveau français et des vaccins
donc en amont sécurisée sur efficace de
manière à tester de manière indépendante
et puis en aval un système de
pharmacovigilance
intrinsèquement extrêmement performant
piloté par là par la haine et s'aiment
et qui a été en plus renforcée mais là
je laisserai la parole à l'ats nsn pour
préciser les choses à l'occasion de
cette campagne vaccinale et s'agissant
de ces questions de sûreté d'efficacité
de pharmacovigilance il ya un maître mot
qui a guidé la campagne et on était on
en était des garants au niveau du mss
c'est le mot de transparence donc dès
qu'un signal était identifié il était
évidemment remontée traitées analysées
et rien n'a été caché rien n'a jamais
été cachées et cette transparence pour
nous elle a largement contribué à
l'adhésion de la population pour la
vaccination
ces lits
continuons donc si vous voulez bien avec
le docteur christelle ratinier carbonnel
directrice générale de l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament la
rsm site est déjà bien des fois
le titre complet si agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé vous êtes accompagné de madame
rose marie tu n'y es directrice de
communication madame cécile mourier
directrice de surveillance docteur
tiphaine vaillant membres titulaires du
pharmacovigilance risque assez semaine
committee de l' agence européenne du
médicament ema
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
merci beaucoup de donner la possibilité
en effet l agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament et des produits de santé
de pouvoir s'exprimer dans le cadre de
ces auditions évidemment accompagnés de
l'ensemble des acteurs parties prenantes
de ce sujet à la fois évidemment la
direction générale de la santé le
conseil d'orientation la stratégie
vaccinale mais également évidemment les
centres régionaux de pharmacovigilance
et un maillot et je le dis souvent
évidemment indispensable avec un réseau
territorial qui est assez unique en
europe voire au monde et c'est en effet
un élément qui est majeure peut-être
quelques éléments pour revenir sur les
questions liées à la haye même
conditionnelle ou au renouvellement
notamment et au sujet de l'évaluation
bénéfice risque quelques éléments de
précision et je vais essayer évidemment
d'être la plus concise possible est
possible et la plus claire possible sur
le sujet des mêmes conditionnel puisque
en effet il ya beaucoup de questions est
tout à fait légitime sur ce concept da
et même conditionnelle et est-ce qu'il
est nouveau
non ce n'est pas un procédé qui est un
dispositif qui est nouveau il a à peu
près 20 ans au niveau européen il existe
depuis 2004 et il permet de garantir un
accès rapide aux médicaments ou vaccins
pour les patients lorsque l'on est dans
une situation où il y à un besoin
médical qui n'est pas couvert et lorsque
l'on est face à une situation en effet
sanitaire particulière ce qui est en
effet le cas notamment dans le cadre de
la mise à disposition notamment des
vaccins des vaccins qu'ovide alors
pardon je me permets juste de vous
demander une petite précision donc une
posture qui a presque 20 ans d'autres
exemples où elle a été appliquée tout à
fait j'allais ans dans mes films je vous
en prie je l'expliqué donc oui nous
avons en 2020 nous avons 13 autorisation
démissionne marchés qui sont
conditionnels on en a eu à peu près plus
d'une cinquantaine depuis le début
notamment dans des indications comme en
oncologie où en est faite évidemment
lorsque le rationnel en effet d'une
année même conditionnelle c'est la mise
en évidence évidemment après évaluation
d'un rapport bénéfices/risques est et on
en reparlera qui est évidemment centrale
qui est positif qui est mis en évidence
sur la base de données suffisamment
importante pour définir ce rapport
bénéfice risque positif avec des données
qui sont certes pas totalement complète
mais où il est mis en évidence et
notamment au niveau européen donc avec
la colle gilles collégialité de
l'ensemble des états membres que ce
bénéfice est évidemment plus important
et il serait délétère d'attendre la mise
à disposition de l'ensemble des données
complètes pour le patient et que nous
aurions une perte de chance pour le
patient s'il n'y avait pas la mise à
disposition de ce médicament de manière
anticipée donc le terme conditionnelle
en effet et peut prêter à confusion mais
on est bien sûr une autorisation de mise
sur le marché précoce qui permet de
donner accès en effet au patient ou à la
population dans une situation sanitaire
évidemment précise avec un rapport
bénéfice risque positif et avec la
garantie également que le l'industriel
donc le demandeur le titulaire d'aller
mer sera en capacité de compléter
l'ensemble des données est donc une
année même conditionnelle est assorti
d'un certain nombre d'obligations
spécifiques de ce qu'on le dit en effet
en anglais les spécifique obligations
qui sont évidemment toute transparence
disponible sur le site internet de l'iem
est donc qui définit pour chacun des
vaccins est donc là nous en avons
aujourd'hui cinq qui sont indisponibles
on en a encore d'autres qui sont en
cours d'évaluation mais notamment pour
les cinq vaccins qui sont déjà
disponibles une liste de spécifique
obligations qui définit en effet quel
type de données doivent être mobilisées
en effet soit des rapports finaux en
effet d'études ou alors de nouvelles
études il faut savoir que pour les
vaccins nous sommes dans une situation
quelles que soient les vaccins et pas
uniquement que vim nous sommes dans une
situation en effet qui est particulière
nous avons des données en effet au
travers des essais cliniques et nous
avons des études randomisées qui ont été
réalisés notamment pour l'autorisation
d'émission de marché conditionnelle des
vaccins que qui sont aujourd'hui sur qui
sont aujourd'hui commercialisés avec une
autorisation de mise sur le marché et
vous avez de toute façon un suivi qui
est réalisée de l'ensemble des personnes
qui ont été inclus dans les essais
cliniques donc nous avons au moment de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
vous à un certain recul avec en termes
d'efficacité ou en effet nous avons eu à
disposition et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ya eu des mêmes
conditionnelle nous avons la
démonstration de l'efficacité en effet
des vaccins avec un rapport bénéfice
risque qui a été définie comme positif
avec un certain recul à la fois sur
l'efficacité et la sécurité puis ensuite
vous avez toute la nécessité de suivre
au fil du temps en effet est de pouvoir
appréhender et apprécier la durabilité à
la fois de l'efficacité il de
l'évolution des effets indésirables et
de manière assez classique et notamment
ce sont des règles de pratique clinique
de recherche unique à la fois européenne
mais je dirais même mondiale ce qui est
fait aux états unis où ce qui est fait
au canada où ou en asie est assez assez
similaire les participants en effet aux
essais cliniques sont suivis à peu près
deux ans après la fin de l'essai
clinique dont vous avez des données des
données en effet qu'ils sont acquises au
fur et à mesure et il est nécessaire et
les industriels ont l'obligation de
déposer auprès de l'agencé européenne du
médicament qui je le rappelle est une
agence de coordination des agences
sanitaires nationales l'évaluation est
réalisé par les agences sanitaires
nationales les rapporteurs et les
co-rapporteurs nous sommes notamment co
rapporteur sur le vaccin comir mathy et
donc vous avez en permanence des données
qui arrive de la part en effet également
des industriels et puis aussi des
données qui viennent à la fois de la
surveillance on y reviendra en effet en
termes de données de pharmacovigilance
également de
pharmacoépidémiologie vous avez
mentionné le vice en effet épiphane j'y
reviendrai j'y reviendrai plus tard et
puis de la littérature je matte c'est
juste pour une question complémentaire
vous avez parlé du des deux ans après la
première dose c'est ça sauf que là il ya
une itération des doses et donc
qu'est-ce que ça re décale à chaque fois
parce qu'il ya le fait il ya le vaccin
lui-même il ya la reproduction de
l'injection du vaccin sont deux éléments
un peu différent voilà il ya une base
commune mais il ya ce sont des éléments
différents surtout qu'on a eu des
mélanges vaccinaux en fait alors là je
parle bien des deux ans suivi des
participants à l'essai clinique donc
lorsque l'essai va la laisser d'origine
de la mm en effet initial là et même
conditionnelle et donc on a en effet un
suivi à peu près en moyenne de 2 ans
ensuite comme vous le savez et vous
l'avez indiqué madame un rapporteur il y
à une évolution des indications en effet
des vaccins on l'a vu et je dirais comme
toute autorisation de messieurs marché
quel que soit le médicament c'est en
effet il y à une évolution avec des
extensions d'indication et donc de ce
fait les données en effet et le suivi
alors on n'est pas évidemment pas sur
les mêmes participants puisqu'on a eu
des tranches d'âge différentes etc mais
il ya aussi également ce suivi dont on a
tout un corpus en effet de la part des
industriels en termes de données
fournies par les industriels dans le
cadre de leurs essais cliniques dans le
cas des suivis donc des de ces essais
cliniques on a ce qu'on appelle sur la
partie sécurité les past les post
autorisation safety study on a aussi les
pea es les post autorisation efficace
east dit et donc il y a en effet toutes
ces données de la part des industriels
qui sont soumises au niveau de l' agence
européenne qui sont évalués par les
états membres et donc avec cette
collégialité et avec au fur et à mesure
une évolution de la connaissance en
termes de données qui se traduit dans
les résumés des caractéristiques des
produits dans les notices avec des
évolutions soient sur l'indication soit
sûr évidemment les profils de sécurité
et donc c'est quelque chose qui bouge en
permanence une autorisation de mise sur
le marché quelles qu'elles soient
qu'elle soit conditionnelle ou qu'elle
soit pleine et entière elle bouge en
permanence on a une première à mm et
puis ensuite les choses bougent les
choses évoluent et donc il y à un suivi
permanent une évaluation permanente qui
est qui est réalisé et donc dans le cas
du renouvellement et c'était une
question de monsieur le rapporteur dans
le cadre du renouvellement en effet de
deux là mêmes conditionnel donc puisque
nine conditionnel est valable pour un an
et ensuite elle est révisée donc de
manière de manière annuelle avec un
objectif d'évolution en effet vers une
année même dit pleine et entière une
fois que l'ensemble de ces spécifique
obligations que je mentionnais
précédemment une fois qu'elles seront
toutes terminées il peut y avoir en
effet une évolution vers une année
pleine et entière j'ai indiqué en effet
que c'est un procédé qui existe depuis
quasiment vingt ans quand on regarde en
effet sur les autres produits les a et
même conditionnelle on a à peu près en
moyenne en tout cas pas pas sur les
vaccins mais en tout cas sur les autres
produits en est aux alentours de 3,5
années entre le moment de l'obtention du
naye même conditionnelle et la
transformation je dirais on avait même
pleine et entière ce sont des données
qui sont disponibles évidemment de
manière transparente sur le site
internet de l'ime donc la révision qui a
été fait donc en de fin 2021 donc un an
après l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché vous vous rappelez en effet les
premiers vaccins ont vu leur est même en
décembre 2020 donc l'évaluation qui a
été fait et la synthèse de l'ensemble
des données disponibles à la fois des
industriels bien évidemment et puis tout
ce qui a été acquis comme connaissance
et bien marcel il a rappelé et vous-même
également madame la rapporteure nous
sommes dans une situation
exceptionnelle et extraordinaire au sens
sémantique du terme avec une vaccination
extrêmement importante de la population
au niveau français au niveau européen et
au niveau mondial et donc nous avons
acquis un quantum de données
exponentielle est vraiment extrêmement
important à la fois sur l'efficacité à
la fois sur la sécurité le dispositif
qui a été mis en place mais on y
reviendra après sur la pharmacovigilance
le dispositif qui a été mis en place
notamment donc par là nsm de
surveillance renforcée avec je le dis
toujours deux jambes la
pharmacovigilance et la pharmaco
épidémiologie a permis en effet de
pouvoir actualisé en temps réel on y
reviendra et je laisserais surtout mais
mes collègues des centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance pouvoir compléter a
permis d'actualiser en effet en
permanence ces éléments sur la partie
sécurité mais aussi sur la partie c'est
la partie efficacité et notamment avec
la production vous l'avez vous l'avez
mentionné madame la rapporteur sur la
partie évaluation br / ces fameuses
donner envie réelle
possiblement compte jeudi possiblement
considérait en effet comme comme moi -
positive ou moins puissantes par rapport
à un essai randomisé en effet en double
aveugle qui
aujourd'hui est considérée ou encore
considéré en effet comme le gold gold
standard notamment dans le cadre de la
recherche clinique on le voit bien là en
effet avec les vaccins on a bien cette
combinaison des deux et c'est
indispensable et c'est la force en effet
de l'acquisition des données que nous
avons eu à la fois avec des essais
cliniques qui ont été réalisés donc au
départ en randomisés en effet contre
placebo je reviendrai sur les variants
et les immuno bridging puisque la
situation aujourd'hui rend difficile
voire impossible la mise en place d'un
groupe témoin en effet non vaccinés j'y
reviendrai après et l'hymne bridging
pardon que ce que vous en parlez payer
sur l'imminent billie jean alors du coup
je viens tout de suite sur le sujet des
variants puisque c'est en effet dans ce
dans ce cadre là
les premiers vaccins en effet et
notamment ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
commercialisés donc ont été réalisés
donc sur la base d'essais cliniques en
effet décès d'efficacité qui a permis de
démontrer en effet l'efficacité
notamment sur des critères primaires dur
que sont les maladies sévères mais
également les décès et le professeur
alain fischer pourra largement
évidemment compléter sur ce point les
nouveaux vaccins qui sont encore qui
sont en cours d'évaluation évidemment il
ya une difficulté de pouvoir mettre en
place un groupe témoin eut égard en
effet à la vaccination importante et
donc dans ce cadre là on passe en effet
ce que l'on appelle sur de l'immuno
bridging c'est à dire que on va analyser
on aura toujours du comparatif mais
entre deux vaccins et nous allons
analyser en termes immunologique la
réponse immunitaire donc in vitro en
termes de taux d'anticorps en termes de
profils en effet des anticorps qui vont
permettre de définir que le nouveau
candidat-vaccin un profil analogue s'est
mis aussi bien ou peut-être mieux que
les vaccins en effet qui ont été
autorisées notamment lors de la première
phase et donc ça permet en effet d'avoir
ces éléments c'est des choses qui
existent pas uniquement sur les vaccins
coville les vaccins grippes que vous
avez en effet et qui arrive en effet
donc tous les ans vous avez comme vous
le savez des souches différentes c'est
ce concept qui est mis il n'ya pas
d'essai clinique qui est répétée donc
avec des études d'efficacité en tant que
tel mais c'est bien ce même concept donc
il n'y a rien de nouveau je dirais mais
une utilisation en effet des procédés
existent juste merci beaucoup pour les
clients que je vérifie qu on a bien
compris au début quand on travaille avec
une population naïve au départ on peut
faire aussi bien dessinés vitraux qui
laissait in vivo en comparaison avec un
groupe témoin et c'est quand par la
suite on arrive avec nouveaux vaccins
nouveaux variants et c'était un nouveau
contexte peut pas forcément refaire des
essais in vivo décès sur les patients
mais en revanche on peut faire la
comparaison sur une vie trop et on
extrapole
là la comparaison in vivo de la
comparaison une vitre ou est ce que
c'est un peu ça l'idée ou alors oui pas
complètement si je vous me permettez
monsieur le président puisque on reste
en comparatif entre deux vaccins c'est à
dire la première partie on était sur des
vaccins versus placebo et là on va
comparer entre deux vaccins donc on a
déjà le je dirais le la bottom line en
effet dans le premier cas on et placebo
versus le candidat vaccin dans le
deuxième cas on est on reste un
comparatif vaccins contre vaccin est
donc cette notion de comparatifs en
effet et est important et puis il y a
également évidemment comme je le disais
les donner envie réelle donc qui
permettent de pouvoir
de pouvoir apprécier de manière fine
également l'évolution donc envie réelle
à la fois en efficacité mais également
évidemment en sécurité et sur un nombre
et sur un nombre de personnes vaccinées
extrêmement important cela a été
mentionné par madame la rapporteure avec
le jc piffard le jc piffard donc qui est
un groupement d'intérêt scientifique
public une force d' expertise publique
et j'insiste beaucoup sur la notion de
public donc évidemment
complètement dénuées de tout lien
d'intérêt comme est évidemment
j'ai manqué entre guillemets amédée voir
puisque je n'ai pas fait de déclaration
publique d'intérêts mais en tant que
directrice générale de la rsm je suis
évidemment des mets de tout lien
d'intérêt comme l'ensemble de mes
collaborateurs et donc ce jc puis phare
en effet qui est une qui réunit les
forces d expertise en épidémiologie de
l'asm et de la cnam permet en effet de
mobiliser des données extrêmement
précieuses sur l'ensemble des assurés
sociaux donc sur les 68 millions de
françaises et de français et donc le jc
piffard à publier et effet nous publions
en effet de manière extrêmement
régulière est totalement transparente
les études qui ont été réalisées nous
avons de mémoire cinq études qui ont été
réalisées sur l'efficacité des vaccins
en vie réelle 3 sur la sécurité je pense
notamment au myocarde it et on pourrait
évidemment y revenir qui permet en effet
de regarder ce qu'il se passe vraiment
envie réelle et donc notamment sur
l'efficacité qui a permis de conforter
les résultats en effet notamment des
essais cliniques sur les vaccins
notamment arn messager mais pas qu'eux a
permis de conforter sur plusieurs
dizaines de millions de personnes
vaccinées et donc vous voyez bien que on
a à la fois les essais randomisés en
effet et donc comparatif et puis tout
cette acquisition de données notamment
en vie réelle deuxième chose par rapport
à l'évaluation du bénéfice risque est
également le sujet des dmm
conditionnelle a été mobilisée pour les
vaccins que vis d'une procédure qui
existe aussi déjà depuis de nombreuses
années qui a été initiée lors de
l'arrivée des premiers antirétroviraux
dans le vih vous voyez c'est déjà il ya
un petit peu de temps qui s'appelle la
rolling review au niveau de l'agencé
européenne du médicament qui permet en
effet d'accélérer la mise à disposition
d des médicaments et là notamment des
vaccins sans évidemment rogner sur
l'évaluation en termes de qualité
d'efficacité de sécurité donc c'est des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
vraiment au tout début de l'arrivée des
antirétroviraux ou en effet le besoin
médical non couvert et
l'intériorité en effet de la nécessité
en effet d'avoir d'avoir ces médicaments
étaient évidemment très importante et
donc là on est dans ce procédé avec la
mise à disposition en continu de données
de la part des industriels et une éval à
une évaluation en continu des
rapporteurs pour en effet garantir un
accès facilité dans des conditions de
sécurité les plus adéquate possible
une madame la directrice générale une
question qui nous vient des internautes
peut synthétiser comme suit dans les
dents les exemples que vous avez
évoquées il y as sont des traitements
qui ont été en autorisations aux
missions marché conditionnelle
traitement contre le cancer traitement
contre le hiv ou autre est ce que c'est
la première fois que il y à un
traitement préventif et pas contre une
pathologie qui est mise en oeuvre en
sous forme d'un mêmes conditionnelle ou
est ce qu'il y a des il ya des
précédents le dire vaccination
s'adressant à priori à quelqu'un qui est
à quelqu'un qui est sain qui n'a pas été
et qui n'a pas été malade est ce que là
il s'est ainsi il ya des précédents ou
est ce que c'est c'est le premier de son
genre
alors sur les a et même qu'on dit sur la
rolling review je pense que d'autres
vaccins ont été ont été concernés et
notamment jeu même si ça c'est une
autorisation européenne mais à
destination de pays tiers je pense aux
vaccins contre ebola ou il y a eu en
effet cette mobilisation de running
review sur le sujet des mêmes
conditionnelle
je n'ai pas la mémoire là tout de suite
mais je vais vérifier je fais vérifier
ma façon de façon générale nous feront
circuler aussi quand nous
quand on fera le compte et on verra
d'abord si certaines des questions ici
ne trouvent pas leurs réponses ou qu'on
a besoin de complément nous font passer
bien évidemment cela par écrit ça vaut
aussi pour certaines des questions qui
nous sont posées par les internautes il
y en a tellement qu'il est clair que ne
pourront pas tous toutes les transmet
donc on évite et qu'un tout petit nombre
presque 300 voilà alors on pourrait si
j'ai jusqu'à jusqu'à minuit pour évoquer
toutes les questions mais on va faire
une toute petite sélection et pour
certaines d'entre elles nous nous
permettrons de vous les transmettre
aussi de façon à avoir vos réponses
écrites pour la suite du processus
ok pour vous madame la directrice
générale nous
[Musique]
oui question de la sénatrice catherine
procaccia
je vais là je vais l'un des piliers d'un
des piliers de l'opex tu
madame la directrice général vous avez
évoqué une évaluation en fonction des
anticorps il nous a toujours été dit que
les anticorps n'était pas forcément
significatif en tout cas que leur
j'imagine que leur
leur dosage doivent être interprétés
avec des pincettes crois aussi qu à
plusieurs catégories d'anticorps qu'il
faut qu'il faut prendre en compte ici
peut-être que
peut-être que le professeur alain
fischer voudra à prendre le relais à ce
moment là et ça peut être là la
transition vers vers votre audition
professeurs
elle est donc le professeur alain
fischer président du conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
mais mesdames messieurs les députés et
sénateurs merci de m'avoir invité longe
réponse directe à cette question avant
d'enchaîner alors je pense qu'il faut
bien distinguer l'évaluation des
anticorps à l'échelle individuelle à
l'échelle de la population le message
que vous avez retenu à juste titre c'est
que je l' ai beaucoup répéter je dois
dire j'assume le fait que pour un
individu donné sauf la situation
particulière des patients profondément
immunodéprimés qui est un sujet au sujet
de soucis encore aujourd'hui le titre
des anticorps ne prédit pas le niveau de
protection ce d'autant comme l'indiquait
le président il ya une seconde qui est
un anticorps et d'anticorps il ya des
anticorps neutralisants qui sont les
plus efficaces et qui sont comme leurs
noms l'indiquent susceptible de bloquer
la pénétration du virus au niveau de la
gorge du nez mais à condition d'être en
quantité suffisante et ciblant les bons
antigènes du bon variant et puis il ya
d'autres anticorps qui n'ont pas cette
action et quand on dose classiquement
dans les tests de routine des anticorps
au mélange coûts et donc à l'échelle de
l'individu je répète que cela n'a pas
d'intérêt maintenant dans les études
auxquelles faisait allusion christelle
ou d'ailleurs ont été regardées très
spécifiquement les anticorps
neutralisants est aujourd'hui contre 5,6
7,8 varié en différents là on sait on si
on étudie mille personnes 2000 personnes
dix mille personnes on a des données qui
sont statistiquement puissante qui
permet d'avoir une indication même si
elle n'est pas parfaite parce que rien
ne remplacera jamais la protection
clinique mais quand même c'est un
élément de en termes populationnelle qui
est pertinent
je me permets de d'enchaîner merci et je
vous en prie enchaîné ok donc je voulais
faire quelques remarques préliminaires
précédent suite contribuer un tout petit
peu de réponses aux questions je pense
et je pense que le témoignage à
l'instant de christine latimier sur ce
point parfaitement éloquent jamais dans
l'histoire de la médecine est
spécifiquement l'histoire la vaccination
il s'est exercé un niveau de
surveillance et d'évaluation aussi
puissant en france c'est évident avec le
réseau dont va je pense j'espère
entendre parler parce qu'il est vraiment
impressionnant en europe avec un travail
en commun au niveau de l'agencé
européenne du médicament à l'échelle
internationale au moins dans les pays
développés les états unis le canada
l'australie et il ya une masse
d'informations qui recueillit qui naquit
ne cesse d'être recueilli tous les jours
sur à la fois la sécurité et
l'efficacité des vaccins encore une fois
qui est inégalée dans l'histoire de la
médecine on parle de quelque chose qui
est unique mais positivement unique et
qui justifiait évidemment je me permets
de le rappeler par la gravité de cette
pandémie
on estime qu'à l'échelle mondiale
aujourd'hui on est à 17 18 millions
d'offres quand même je pense qu'il faut
rappeler ces chiffres en france essence
un prêt de 150 mille morts et huit cent
mille hospitalisations dont on parle pas
d'une petite grippe bénigne encore déjà
la grippe de temps en temps comme vous
le savez elles posent problème donc ceci
est justifié ça c'était mon premier
point le deuxième point je voudrais
témoigner n'étant pas directement engagé
sur cet aspect mais ayant au cours des
18 derniers mois interagit sans cesse à
la fois avec les autorités
gouvernementales des agences dont la
haine et celle de la transparence
absolument complète de la transmission
des informations en particulier sur les
questions de sécurité même si ça a coûté
temps en temps et prenons un exemple
tout à fait clair d'abord la
transparence s'est manifestée par le
fait que très tôt dans les premiers
jours des premiers essais cliniques on a
su qu'il y avait un risque faible de
l'ordre de 1 pour cent mille de choc
anaphylactique avec les vaccins et
rennes s'étaient su tout de suite
deuxième point concerne c'est le plus
tragique les accidents thromboemboliques
avec le vaccin astrazeneca ce cil alerte
a été déclenchée à l'échelle européenne
alors qu'il y avait encore un nombre de
cas extrêmement limité la france en
particulier a fait un travail je pense
exhaustive vu la gravité de ces
pathologies pour enregistrer lequel les
cas de mémoire je crois qu'il ya une
quarantaine de cas ceci a été rendu
public immédiatement
presque à flot continu ce qui est ce
qu'il fallait faire mais la conséquence
de cela malheureusement ou moins en
france c'est que le public a perdu
confiance dans le vaccin en question qui
le vaccin astrazeneca et le vaccin james
n dans une certaine mesure un moment
vous n'avez pas encore assez de doses de
vaccins et rennes kovacs et toute la
population est donc il ya eu un conte un
contre effets négatifs mais qu'il faut
assumer de d'une transparence qui ne
peut pas être plus complète que ce qui a
été fait on peut sur le dernier point de
d'effets indésirables indiscutable des
vaccins ce sont les mieux car dit que
les jeux plutôt chez les jeunes hommes
plutôt après la la seconde dose de
vaccin et rennes plutôt avec le vaccin
moderna parce qu'il est un peu plus dosé
à nouveau les informations ont circulé
immédiatement sans absolument sans
retenue au point un nouveau d'ailleurs
entraîné un excès probablement de
précaution de la part de la population
donc je voulais insister là dessus
troisième point plus générale
évidemment si on si on réfléchi au fait
que qu'on vaccine mettre un moment on a
vacciné 600 700 800 mille personnes par
jour aujourd'hui les chiffres évidemment
son plus bas mais si vous calculez camp
français à 15 cents personnes qui
décèdent tous les jours c'est à peu près
à peu près les chiffres si vous aimez
ton comprennent cent mille personnes
vaccinées un jour donné donc ça fait 1
660 dixième de la population française
ça veut dire que statistiquement
2.5 si je puis dire deux personnes
ennemis vont mourir chaque jour de
celles qui ont été vaccinés sur dix
jours sans frais 25 sur 30 jours sans
fil 75 donc 75 % vont mourir et c'est
prendre un peu plus parce qu'on vaccine
plutôt des gens un peu plus fragiles un
peu plus âgé non mais on va rester à ce
chiffre minimale il ya soixante-quinze
personnes qui nomme qui meurt dans le
mois qui suit la vaccination est ce que
ces personnes sont mortes à cause de la
vaccination ou simplement parce que
malheureusement elle devait mourir de
tel ou tel étiologie derrière ça il ya
ce concept qui est absolument critique
et qui est tout l'objet du travail que
fait la nsm en termes de
pharmacovigilance et et de
pharmacoépidémiologie c'est de
distinguer ce qui est du domaine de la
concomitance donc ce qu'on pourrait
appeler des événements secondaires qui
chronologiquement sont survenus après la
vaccination mais ce qui est distinct
d'une causalité ou on peut déterminer
comme ça a été le cas pour les accidents
thromboemboliques où les cas de
myocardite qui a une relation de cause à
effet il faut faire extrêmement
attention ne pas confondre les deux
parce que sinon effectivement on peut
très rapidement arriver à des chiffres
astronomiques qui n'ont juste aucun sens
que ce soit en terme de mortalité ou de
complications de tous ordres embolie
pulmonaire tous les choses moins grave
aussi bien évidemment donc je voulais
faire cette troisième remarqué ma
quatrième remarque générale avant
d'essayer de prendre deux trois points
de réponses aux questions posées c'est
juste je voudrais à mon tour posé une
question à tout le monde sait où on en
serait aujourd'hui si elles payent de la
kz1 où on serait aujourd'hui s'il n'y
avait pas eu de vaccins combien de morts
supplémentaires combien
d'hospitalisation supplémentaires
combien de mois de confinement
supplémentaires c'est des travaux de ce
type ont déjà été menées en france aux
etats-unis à l'été dernier une équipe de
recherche de saint-etienne avait estimé
que le 25 mille vies avaient été sauvées
en france en août 2000 un jeune et que
je vais pas donner des chiffres parce
que ce serait pas rigoureux j'ai pas une
étude très précise ce travail peut être
fait doit être fait il est pas si simple
parce qu'il ya pas mal de paramètres à
prendre en compte évidemment les mesures
d'isolement etc etc mais c'est évident
ce qu'il y ait beaucoup de personnes
heureusement dans ce pays qui sont
aujourd'hui en vie parce qu'elles ont
été vaccinées ce sera l'objet d'une
autre enquête je pense d'accord mais
tout à fait raison je pense qu'il faut
avoir ça en tête on nie tout à fait
d'accord
l'animation voilà votre remarque bien
sûr on en est conscient alors maintenant
bien sûr sûr sûr des points plus
spécifique par rapport aux questions qui
ont été évoquées
au delà des études randomisées qui
s'arrête par exemple au bout de six mois
ou un an on passe aux étudiants
observationnelles qui sont
méthodologiquement un peu moins
rigoureuse c'est exact sauf qu'on peut
il ya deux remarques à faire c'est exact
des études observationnelles qui ont été
faites qui continuent d'être fait à tous
les stades de la vaccination donc sur la
primovaccination sur les rappels en
fonction des variants enfin je ne vais
pas entrer dans les détails elle porte
sur des effectifs considérable de
centaines de milliers de personnes
notamment on a eu les données d'israël
qui sont qui ont été vaccinés vous
l'épaule et lascive les sites leurs
citoyens ont été vaccinés les premiers
on allait donner décosse puis deux camps
bretagne puis états unis et de france
l'adresse aux mille c'est la santé des
statistiques très très précises sur ces
lieux abstentions et puis je voudrais
ajouter qu'il existe une méthodologie
d'études qui est utilisée qui s'appelle
le test négatif design qui consiste à
prendre une population de grand nombre
par exemple qui arrivent à l'hôpital
avec des signes de pneumopathie on
pourrait éventuellement prendre un autre
signe clinique et parmi ces populations
on va calculer combien d'entre elles ont
co lead et combien d'entre elles ont été
vaccinées et c'est une méthode qui est
assez rigoureuse je peins et plus
méthode logist c'est pas ma formation
mais enfin bon j'ai suivi à peu près ça
c'est une méthodologie qui est puis
puisse plus rigoureuse que celle d'aider
des études observationnelles et en
l'occurrence ce type d'études confirme
largement les multiples études à chaque
fois on parle pas d'une ou deux études
on a des dizaines d'études de ce type
notamment menée en grande-bretagne pas
exclusivement qui confirme à la fois la
sécurité et l'efficacité autrement dit
l'analyse ce bénéfice risque des vaccins
et puis je veux pas être trop trop long
un mot peut-être sur la communication il
a été évoquée l'idée qu'il y avait une
dissociation entre la communication
entre les effets indésirables et
l'efficacité je pense que ça n'a pas été
le cas et quand ça a été le cas c'était
à rebours typiquement dans le jeu
reprend l'exemple des accidents
thromboemboliques à ce moment là on a
beaucoup parlé le comprend d'effets
indésirables et - l'efficacité alors que
pourtant même avec ces effets
indésirables là ils résident analyse
bénéfices/risques restaient favorables
et dans tous les autres cas en situation
où il n'y avait pas de d'événements
particuliers la discuter l'analyse
bénéfice risque a été de me semble-t-il
à travers les différentes antennes
possible de communication
globalement abordé est donc strictement
dans selon la balance bénéfice-risque en
confirmant à chaque fois lequel était
largement positive je m'arrête là pour
pas être trop long il reste d'autres si
beaucoup professeurs nous ont d'autres
occasions bien sûr de revenir là dessus
la sénatrice laurence moulin bon on
souhaite poser une question merci
monsieur le président chers collègues et
mesdames et messieurs merci pour les
explications très intéressante que vous
venez de me donner on attend bien sûr
les suivantes alors moi j'ai une
question concernant le dispositif de
pharmacovigilance un qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui ma question porte sur les
dispositifs de pharmacovigilance
concernant les jeunes enfants qui ont
été vaccinés avec des doses pour adultes
avant l'arrivée des vaccins pédiatriques
et qui ont été livré mi décembre 2021
selon les données de le sens de la santé
de santé publique france et un article
du monde sur le sujet du 18 novembre
2021 on recense 22 1490 enfants français
de moins de 12 ans concernés par au
moins une dose et 17 1199 complètement
vaccinés à cette date on recense parmi
eux des enfants de moins de 5 ans 4512
avec une dose
2436 avec 2,12 sans disposer d'études
cliniques et ni d'autorisation légale ma
question est donc la suivante un
dispositif de pharmacovigilance
at il été mis en place pour suivre les
enfants va signer par un régime
d'exception et notamment pour les
enfants de moins de cinq ans dans le cas
contraire pourquoi la nsm ne
rapporteraient t'elle pas les données
concernant ces deux ses 22 1490 enfants
merci
si je collecte pour la question
peut-être que c'est l'occasion de passer
la parole à madame la présidente du
réseau des centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance docteur annie pier
jonville berra si cela vous convient
vous êtes accompagnés de professeurs
jouer micallef référent corps minati des
professeurs sophie gautier référent
moderna docteur valérie gras champel
référent va accélérer a pas facile à
prononcer
voilà vague février et docteur marine
asa offer référence cotten
peut-être donc pour répondre à la fois à
la question de notre collègue sénatrice
et aussi propos liminaires sur les
questions qui vous inquiète qui ont été
posées par les parlementaires
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les parlementaires mesdames
messieurs on est déjà vous remercier de
nous avoir invités à cette audition à
laquelle nous sommes particulièrement
heureux de participer je voulais juste
rappeler à tout le propos liminaire
l'organisation des centres de
pharmacovigilance qui sont des
structures hospitalières indépendante
hébergés dans les chu c'est important
composé de pharmacologue médecins les
pharmaciens qui sont formés à l'analyse
et la gestion de tous les effets
indésirables des médicaments dont font
partie des vaccins on a donc en charge
le recueil l'analyse et l'expertisé
médicale des effets où des suspicions
d'effets indésirables je voulais
témoigner du travail important qui a été
fait puisque nous avons assuré la
surveillance des vaccins avec
professionnalisme habituel et surtout la
rigueur nécessaire
malgré une activité qui a été quintuplé
au cours de cette année avec une
surcharge de travail particulièrement
importante je voulais aussi rappelé je
pense que c'est important c'est un
message important c'est que la
principale finalité de notre activité ce
n'est pas d'enregistrer en tout venant
tout ce qui se passe c'est de détecter
les potentiels signaux c'est à dire des
effets indésirables nouveau grave ou non
qui pourrait amener à modifier le
bénéfice risque d'un produit compris les
vaccins ou à modifier la campagne de
vaccination ce n'est pas un
enregistrement
exhaustif l'autre chose importante c'est
que le niveau d'organisation des centres
régionaux de pharmacovigilance français
qui est assez particulier permet un
niveau de sensibilité pour la détection
de signaux faibles qui est
particulièrement intéressant je vais
vous le prouver par quelques chiffres
avec une précocité que ne permettent pas
les bases de données d'enregistrement
des faits d' événement puisque nous
c'est le coeur de métier l'intelligence
qui est partie fille ciel l'intelligence
humaine qui permet de détecter des cas
et de lancer un signal d un ou deux cas
quelles que soient l'imputabilité
j'insiste aussi sur cette partie pour le
suivi de pharmacovigilance mais que ce
soit le vaccin mais que ce soit pour les
autres médicaments l'imputabilité ne
rentrent en ligne de compte pour
détecter un effet nouveau ou lancer un
signal
imputabilité si vous pouvez préciser en
leur a fixé une méthode que on utilise
en pharmacovigilance kabok qui a été
mise au point pour quand un patient est
un effet indésirable et qui prend quatre
ou cinq médicaments pour cibler le
médicament en cause dans l'effet
indésirable cette méthode et comparative
elle permet de comparer les nôtres entre
chacun des médicaments est dire si c'est
un effet un dirham le plus probablement
causé celui ci après c'est également un
guide pour nous puisque ça nous permet
pour chaque cas d'analyser le délai de
survenue de prendre en compte les autres
diagnostic étiologique puisque pour
toute pathologie le médicament en dehors
de quelques cas exceptionnels n'est pas
la seule cause à la pathologiste donc
avec la note on sait un aide mémoire
pour éliminer les autres pathologies et
éventuellement prendre en compte la
bibliographie mais cette note
d'imputabilité n'est pas utilisé ni pour
faire les enquêtes ni pour remonter les
signaux faut juste avoir en tête que un
signal à l'europe et plus facile à
défendre si les cas on une imputabilité
très élevé puisque du coup il en faudra
de façon moins importante une - une plus
petite quantité pour remonter un signal
donc pour pour prouver la l'organisation
qui a été mise en place est ce qu'on
souhaitait mettre en place les centres
c'est prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires à une détection de signal la
plus précoce et la plus rapide possible
sur les 155 mm 1000 signalements reçus
en 2021 avec les vaccins et les 50000
question puisqu'on a aussi comme mission
de répondre au procès santé qui nous
interroge sur le lien entre une
pathologie un vaccin et on répondait
aussi avec plaisir aux patients les
centres de pharmacovigilance ont fait
remonter plus de 1150 trois cas marc ans
c'est un centre de pharmacovigilance qui
remonte à la fois l' agence du
médicament et aux rapporteurs des
vaccins une pathologie qui pourrait être
en lien avec le vaccin et qui est
nouvelle donc et pas listés dans le rcp
dans les effets indésirables parmi ses
plus de 1150 trois quart marquant les
rapporteurs des vaccins et le comité de
suivi de la nes m a identifié 80 de
pathologie au cours de l'année qui ont
fait l'objet soit d'un
signal européen soit d'une procédure de
surveillance particulière est dense et
plus de 80 pathologie lagence a
transmises 50 signe au potentiel à
l'europe dont 19 des nouveaux cd signaux
que seule la france avait émis dès qu'on
était les premiers à émettre juste en
aparté certains signaux ont été refusées
par l'europe comme les hypertensions
artérielles qu'on continue à suivre
quand même aller toutes les exactions de
la pression artérielle on continue à les
suivre et puis on était content de voir
cette semaine une publication qui a dit
que probablement les vaccins les v élevé
la pression artérielle c'est un des
signaux les plus précoces qu'on a dû
avoir en janvier ou février de cette
année qui montre voilà le niveau de
détection qui est utilisé par les
centres de pharmacovigilance et qui
permet une grande réactivité
alors après je voulais embrayé un
brillant passé sur les troubles
menstruels et la définition entre avérés
mais par contre voilà répondre à la
question va peut-être plus là nous alors
on enregistre et
nous avons le temps elle répondra aussi
bien à votre question chers collègues
que questions posées par les collègues
rapporteur
alors pour les troubles menstruels et le
fait que ce soit un effet indéniable
avéré c'est à dire que faut avoir en
tête qu'il y à deux niveaux en terme de
pharmacovigilance le terme le niveau
individuel impatients nous rapporte une
pathologie on analyse le cas et pour un
patient donné on peut dire la pathologie
que vous avez développé et probablement
ou possiblement en lien avec le vaccin
ces niveaux individuel au niveau
populationnelle on peut dire clap pour
un patient donné lien il est avéré ce
que vous avez fait c'est possiblement
lien avec le vaccin au niveau
populationnelle le même effet on peut
faire une étude épidémiologique et que
cette pathologie ne sortent pas c'est à
dire que la soie elle est spontanément
très fréquentes soit il ya des
particularités des patients qui explique
l'étude de pharmacoépidémiologie va pas
conclure un sur-risque avec le vaccin
faut avoir en tête que pour un patient
donné on peut avoir un effet en lien
avec le vaccin est une étude peut ne pas
confirmer au terme populationnelle que
le vaccin augmente le risque de cette
pathologie
faut prendre en compte cette dimension
qui s'expliquent souvent par des
pathologies très particulière des
facteurs de risque des patients ou des
bisous certains biais le fait pour un
effet indésirable qui en lien avec une
en lien avec un vaccin qui fait soient
avérées ou pas faut que ça réponde à une
procédure réglementaire et là c'est l'
agence qui sont charge c'est-à-dire
qu'il agences une fois que les signaux
ont été transmis à l' agence du
médicament lagence les transmet à
l'europe l'europe ouvre ou non le signal
et l'europe une fois que l'ouverture le
signal est ouvert fait les études
nécessaires et confirme le signal ou pas
c'est à dire que l'europe peut ne pas
confirmer et ça nous arrivait assez
souvent sur des signaux remontée qui
n'ont pas été confirmées par l'europe
même si pour certains patients on est
persuadé qu' un lien entre le vaccin et
la pathologie excusez vous qu'on
comprenne bien la procédure c'est-à-dire
que l'agencé ne prend pas sur elle de
signaler des éléments d'effets
indésirables potentiels si l'europe n'a
pas acté en ce sens non mais je né sais
que je tel que vous le présentez on a
l'impression que ça remonte à l'europe
on attend l'avis de l'europe et ça
redescend ou pas est-ce que je peux
quand est-ce que je peux compléter la
question en vous demandant si ces effets
indésirables
lorsqu'ils sont considérés comme bénins
sont retenus pour vous parce que c'est
les troubles et monstration sa part à
cebenna et courront
après analyse des cas au comité de suivi
à des pathologies à suivre qui sont
décidés et celle agence qui prend en
charge ces signaux potentiel la
transmission à l'europe
on continue sur tout le monde donc pour
les troubles menstruels est donc en fait
vous avez compris que nous le réseau on
est surtout là pour identifier
finalement les signaux enfin ici nos les
potentiels signaux et ensuite c'est à
charge de l' agence finalement de faire
tout l'aspect réglementaire remonte et
échanges avec le m nous on est là pour
s'assurer que tout ce qui se passe avec
les vaccins et la vaccination en termes
d'effets indésirables nous soit remontée
alors vous avez les moyens il ya le
portail bref en ce qui concerne les
troubles menstruels les trouve
monstrueux la vaccination pour les
femmes en âge de procréer 1 qui peuvent
être conseillés concerné par les
troubles e mensuels elle débute à partir
d'avril 2021 et dès le mois de juin on
repère effectivement qu'il ya des
saignements et des saignements mensuel
qui nous surprennent et donc on indique
effectivement au comité de suivi en juin
2021 que ces troubles la
nous préoccupe je sais pas si ça nous
préoccupe en tout cas nous surprennent
et qu'on souhaite les suivre
particulièrement on en fait un deuxième
suivie en jeu en juillet au comité de
suivi suivant on en refait 1 en
septembre et là en septembre on a
travaillé donc les deux vaccins arn mais
également les vaccins à des no parce
qu'on est effectivement surpris du
nombre de déclarations sur ce sujet là
on comprend pas très bien comment ça
fonctionne parce que les tableaux sont
très larges ça va du saignement à
l'aménorrhée c'est-à-dire à l'absence de
règles à des douleurs utérine très très
violente et donc on décide d'en faire un
descriptif très précis donc on a pris en
septembre la totalité des observations
qu'on avait reçu pour pouvoir les
analyser très précisément un parent 4000
cas qui ont été regardés dans le blanc
des yeux un par un et on a donc
proposé un rapport en décembre décrivant
très précisément les caractéristiques d
des événements qui nous été rapporté
alors nous au niveau français depuis
deux mois de juin on considère que ces
cas là sont à suivre parce que à titre
individuel on est on en entend ce que
nous disent ces femmes qui disent
qu'elles sont réglés régulièrement et
qu'elles sont déréglés ou qu'elles ont
des saignements plus abondants mais on
n'a pas au titre collectif on n'a pas
les moyens nous de faire les estimations
collective donc l'estimation collective
elle revient à l'europe l'europe elle a
été saisie de cette question cet été
l'été 2021 et en décembre 2021 décide de
clore le sujet parce qu'il estime qu'il
est compliqué de trancher parce que
comme les troubles menstruels c'est
quelque chose d'assez fréquent en
population générale est que c'est
multifactoriel notamment avec les les
histoires de stress en fait le le le
l'europe des sites que finalement elle
n'a pas les moyen d'estimer si jamais il
ya un lien avec le vaccin est clos le
signal d'un professeur quand vous dites
l'europe il s'agit de qui que
l'institution également l'europe c'est
l'institution voilà je laisserais manama
ratinier compléter mes donc le rock
c'est le la commission de
pharmacovigilance européenne qui se
réunit tous les mois et qui discutent
tous les signaux au niveau européen qui
décide après avoir expertiser le signal
que le signal hill le clou alors quand
il le camp tillieux le ferme ça veut pas
dire qu'ils arrêtent de le suivre
ça veut juste dire qu'ils ont apporté
une première réponse qui est une réponse
de on n'a pas trouvé de signal ou en
tout cas on pense pas qu'il y ait de
lien donc si je si je comprends bien au
début c'est vous qui
avait identifié un signal simplement par
des témoignages recueillis j'ai demandé
alors c'est pas des terres des
déclarations ce sont des déclarations de
serma très vigilant des déclarations de
pharmacovigilance c'était pas quelque
chose qui était a priori attendu donc ça
vous n'a pas du tout et donc il était
tout à fait logique 2-0 liens
de s'en préoccuper de faire un lien et
puis ensuite donc quand vous faites le
signalement et que la question se pose
au niveau de l'institution de la
commission de pharmacovigilance
européenne qui elle pour
mission d'évaluer les choses de façon
collective au niveau européen
décide de clore l'instruction pour
absence de absence de preuves en tout
cas pour l'absence d'éléments qui leur
fait penser qu'il peut y avoir un lien
avec la vaccination est en fait à la
suite du travail qui a été fait alors
nous très précisément au niveau français
mais aussi d'études notamment aux états
unis très précises l'europe a décidé de
rouvrir le signal en 7 en février je
vais y arriver en février 2000 22 sur
deux points particuliers donc le point
des saignements abondants qui gêne la
vie quotidienne et le point d aménorrhée
donc d absence de règles pendant plus de
trois mois
donc ça c'est cette enquête est en cours
et on attend les résultats de l'enquêté
au niveau européen pour le mois de juin
de cette année donc le signal en fait
bien sûr a été réouvert devant le nombre
de cas et les nombreux pays on n'était
pas les seuls les norvégiens les suédois
les anglais ont insisté en disant il ya
quand même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
volume alors se sont souvent
effectivement des effets qui sont
considérés comme non graves parce qu ils
n'amènent pas à l'hospitalisation ça
dure un cycle donc c'est pas considéré
comme grave mais c'est considérer
suffisamment impactant la vie des gens
qui sont concernés pour que ça fasse
l'objet d'une préoccupation
merci beaucoup cette vision plusieurs
demandes de parole d'abord on va
continuer avec votre collègue s'il
voulait bien et ensuite madame la
directrice générale de l'année ses mains
oui merci merci monsieur le président je
jeu vient amplifier ce que vient de dire
ma collègue en tant que le référent pour
le vaccin de pfizer avec trois autres
crpv de bordeaux strasbourg et toulouse
ou en effet dès l'été 2021 nous avons
analysé 200 cas de troubles menstruels
200 cas il y avait une vingtaine ou
trentaine de mémoires pour le vaccin
moderna nous avons ensuite et donc ça
c'est en accès libre puisque tous nos
rapports sont sur le site de l' agence
du médicament donc à une analyse déjà de
230 cas avec le bac scifinder sur ces
troubles menstruels nous avons poursuivi
les investigations
et nous avons produit en décembre 2021
là aussi dans notre rapport de décembre
mis en ligne
l'analyse de
3870 cas de troubles menstruels dix
pages ça aurait pu être plus concis mais
c'est révélateur de toute l'analyse
chirurgicale à la française que vous
avez souligné dans votre bilan madame la
sénatrice et je vous en remercie
infiniment parce que c'est un travail
énorme et je dis pas ça pour qu'on ait
des bénéfices secondaires on n'attend
pas ça mais c'est juste parce que ça
vient pour préciser un point essentiel
qui est qu en effet quand on parle de
troubles menstruels cela couvre en
médecine différentes situations
et c'est vrai que ça a demandé un
travail d'investigation du fait du non
traitées
3870 observations en plus de tout le
reste dire quand on fait ça on n'arrête
pas le suivi de pharmacovigilance qu'on
a tous les jours qu'on analyse tous les
jours à tous les cas qui arrive donc on
a analysé ces cas très finement et ses
claques on a pu identifier différentes
situations cliniques avoir le suivi de
ses patientes parce qu'en
pharmacovigilance qui est important
c'est d'avoir une photographie à un
instant t et de voir comment les choses
évoluent et puis de recueillir près de
ses patientes leur histoire le cycle
d'interruption les retards de règles
certaines parler d'aménorrhée mais ça ne
répondait pas stricto sensu à la
définition médicale d'aménorrhée on va
pas rentrer dans des aspects techniques
mais tout simple tout simplement pour
dire qu'en effet il était indispensable
de faire cette analyse là et donc ça
c'est vrai demander du temps en plus du
volume parce que là la porte d'entrée
était les troubles menstruels ce qui
renvoie des patterns cliniques et
médicaux très large il y avait des
saignements il y avait des métros rage
id meinau métrorragies des retards de
règles d aménorrhée etc à des douleurs
également donc il a fallu documenté tout
ceci est nécessairement ça demande un
peu plus de temps que quand la porte
d'entrée et voici une déclaration fait
par un cardiologue d'une myocardite
voyez c'est à dire que la porte d'entrée
elle est déjà diagnostic tandis que là
elle est symptomatique et donc et ça
c'est très important parce que ça a
demandé du temps certaines déclarations
été faites par des patientes et
d'ailleurs majoritairement par des
patientes et c'est très important
qu'elle ait été fait et je peux vous
dire que dans les centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance
on a réceptionné leurs déclarations on
les a appelés au téléphone on a échangé
par mail avec elle pour avoir des
compléments est ce qu'il y avait eu un
examen gynécologique
est ce qu'il y avait eu des explorations
et qu'il y avait eu un taux de beta hcg
pour savoir s'il y avait pas une
grossesse je m'excuse de rentrer dans
ces détails là mais ça vous montre
vraiment je pense un point essentiel qui
est le travail que l'on fait en
pharmacovigilance et que pour aller plus
loin en termes d'information et puis de
liens comme vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le président nous avons besoin
de ces précisions médical et
pharmacologiques
et ensuite juste pour la question des
enfants pardon je m'excuse envers la
sénatrice députés en pharmacovigilance
nous réceptionnons et nos analyses ont
toutes les déclarations qui nous
viennent quel que soit l'âge nous
n'avons aucun a priori ni de population
ne faisons aucun tri quelqu'un qui nous
appellent pour le vaccin ou pour un
autre médicament on le fait la même
analyse on met pas de côté parce qu'il
ya moins de trois ans moins de deux ans
et nous dès lors qu'un patient ou un
parent nous signalent pour son enfant un
effet indésirable avec un vaccin celui
là où un autre coin médicaments ont le
réceptionne on analyse et on le
documente
pour finir actuellement il n'y a pas de
signal concernant les enfants
merci alors qu'il ya eu un suivi
spécifique très bien donc la situation
exceptionnelle de ses enfants qui ont
été vaccinées en dose adulte avant
l'arrivée des doses pédiatriques n'ai
pas suivi particulièrement n'y a pas une
farce pharmaco vigilance particulière si
c'est le cas
ce qui a été en effet
ce qui a été en effet indiqué notamment
par les représentants des serres pvc que
le dispositif est globale et sur
l'ensemble des dimensions donc tout
toute vaccination et toute déclaration
d'effets indésirables est suivie avec la
même acuité avec la même intensité avec
la même rigueur et avec le même
professionnalisme
donc tout est et donc que ce soit en
effet chez des enfants des jeunes
enfants que ce soit sur des personnes
âgées et en fonction de l'évolution de
la campagne de vaccination
nous nous sommes évidemment aussi adapté
au départ comme vous le savez la
campagne a été a été en effet chez les
personnes âgées les personnes âgées
notamment notamment en institution et
donc il ya eu aussi toute une
communication une information une
appropriation aussi auprès des
professionnels de santé pour faciliter
la déclaration puisque là on savait on
avait en effet la notion que la
déclaration serait probablement plus par
les professionnels de santé lorsque l'on
était en institution et au fur et à
mesure que la campagne de vaccination a
évolué notamment ensuite vers plutôt le
grand public évidemment il ya eu aussi
cette mobilisation donc tout est suivi
de manière extrêmement précise si je
peux en profiter rapidement parce
qu'ensuite devons passer à la table
ronde table ronde suivante
l'articulation niveau national et
européen sur la surveillance qui est un
point majeur et et je souhaitais revenir
notamment sur l'exemple des troubles
menstruels
l'importance évidemment de la latitude
totale que nous avons au niveau national
sur la surveillance et sur les mesures à
mobiliser il y a évidemment fort de tout
le travail qu'ils réalisent fr laisser
rêver et ensuite en collaboration avec
la rsm comme cela a été dit il y à une
remontée des signaux au niveau européen
et donc une évaluation qui est réalisé
par le comité donc le pharmacovigilance
risk assesment and committee donc le
comité européen en effet pour les
troubles menstruels où le sujet est
toujours en cours en effet d'évaluation
mais sans décision à ce stade pour
autant au niveau national comme cela a
été indiqué dès le mois de juin dès
l'été il y a eu des signaux il a eu une
transparence une communication et on y
reviendra dessus et fort de l'ensemble
de l'évaluation qui a été mobilisé des
échanges avec les professionnels de
santé lagence donc à communiquer en
décembre 2021 une conduite à tenir dont
qui a été réalisé avec les
professionnels de santé face à ces
troubles menstruels juste pour préciser
qu' il y à l'évaluation en effet qui se
poursuit au niveau européen mais pour
autant et bien heureusement en tant qu'
autorité de police sanitaire bien
heureusement au niveau national nous
avons toute la latitude pour mettre en
place les mesures nécessaires permettant
de garantir la sécurité ça des passions
qui sont exposés aux produits de santé
et notamment les troubles menstruels en
sont l'exemple et je souhaite juste
terminée mais nous avons qu en effet
réunir il y à il ya quelques jours la
semaine dernière nous avons réalisé donc
une visioconférence avec les
associations de en tout cas les
patientes en effet notamment formé en
collectif sur le sujet des troubles
menstruels les professionnels de santé
les médecins généralistes les
gynécologues les sages femmes les
centres régionaux de pharmacovigilance
pour partager en effet la situation à la
fois en termes d'information voit qu'il
ya déficit même si on y reviendra après
nous avons une communication
transparente et et au fil de l'eau pour
autant l'accès à l'information doit être
renforcée pour qu'elles puissent en
effet également s'y renforcer la
déclaration en termes de
pharmacovigilance se sait pas forcément
même si on communique beaucoup en effet
toutes et tous sur la déclaration c'est
pas forcément simple et de voir quelles
quelles mesures complémentaires peuvent
être prises et donc ça ça a été réalisée
en effet il y à il y a quelques jours
merci beaucoup madame hallyday général
alors un une ou deux phrases du
professeur alain fischer réponse parce
qu'il ya une question importante à
laquelle nous n'avons absolument pas
répondu je pense qu'il est important
d'en dire un mot c fallait-il ou faut-il
vacciner les personnes en bonne santé
la réponse est oui à deux titres c'est
malheureusement même une personne en
bonne santé n'est pas à l'abri de faire
une forme grave de la maladie et on peux
vous en citer des centaines même des
milliers d'exemples et de gens qui sont
morts et de gens qui ont été en
réanimation première réponse deuxième
élément de réponse même si c'est pas
parfait cette vaccination n'ont selon
elle protège à titre individuel mais
elle diminue le risque de transmission
du virus environs d'un facteur 2 on peut
dire que c'est pas beaucoup je parle de
vague de l'eau micro ans la situation
actuelle mais deux c'est loin d'être
négligeable si on raisonne en grande
masse donc non ce membre en prend en
vaccinant les personnes en bonne santé
elle se protège et elles procèdent elles
protègent les personnes malades dans
leur environnement par exemple des
malades profondément immunodéprimés ou
des personnes âgées voilà
merci professeur pour cette précision
nous passons maintenant avec l'accord
des rapporteurs avec un petit peu de
retard dont je m'excuse à la deuxième
table ronde sera l'occasion d'entendre
quelques voix tic sur l'analyse et la
prise en compte des effets indésirables
dans la campagne de vaccination contre
le coc vie de 19
le panel que
d'intervenants qui a été sélectionné par
les rapporteurs après les échanges et
les
entretiens ne prétend pas à être
exhaustif bien sûr ne prétend pas à être
à donner une légitimité plus ou moins
grandes à tel ou tel mais les
rapporteurs ont estimé tout pris en
compte que les trois personnes que nous
avons invités seraient les plus à même
de fournir un ensemble cohérent
représentatif des critiques qui ont pu
s'élever et que leur parole sera
l'occasion de lancer un débat
contradictoire je vais commencer par le
professeur françois la professeur de
santé publique à l'université de
bordeaux en visioconférence je crois
professeur à la et
bonjour vous m'entendez nous vous
entendons
bonjour monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les parlementaires mesdames
messieurs chers collègues donc merci de
m'offrir l'opportunité de m'exprimer de
porter un regard critique puisque c'est
l'intitulé de cette table ronde nous
parlons tous de quelque part à cet
important de préciser
pour ma part je viens je m'exprime en
tant que chercheurs et praticiens de
santé publique et prévention et acteurs
de la démocratie sanitaire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que pour mon analyse
je me base sur des principes et des
méthodes et ses principes qui sont ceux
de la démocratie sanitaire interroge
temps le processus de décision c'est le
côté démocratie que la nature de ces
décisions c'est le côté sanitaire
ceci étant précisé quelle est mon
analyse de la prise en compte des effets
indésirables
dans la campagne vaccinale puisque c'est
le sujet de la table ronde et pour cela
j'aborderai plus particulièrement la
stratégie vaccinale la communication et
le rapport bénéfice risque ce qui me
permettra de répondre à certaines de vos
questions en tout cas celles qui
relèvent de montchamp expertise
tout de suite et pour préciser sur
l'aspect pharmacovigilance et
pharmaco-épidémiologie ce n'est pas de
critiques majeures à formuler et au
contraire je trouve que le travail a été
fait pour le recueil de l'information
s'était précisée tout à l'heure pour son
analyse pour la mise à disposition des
données aussi ce qui est une grande
nouveauté
intel à une telle échelle et ceci en
france comme à l'international
donc une critique ça peut être une
critique négative mais une critique
positive là elle sera plutôt positive et
je tiens plutôt à
féliciter les équipes mobilisées dans
ses travaux et je sais d'expérience que
comme c'est nous donc pour moi ce qui ce
qui pose problème et là ça sera
peut-être qu'avec le côté négatif de la
critique
ce ne sont pas tellement les données
mais la façon dont elles ont été
utilisées ou non d'utiliser en termes de
politiques publiques et les
communications qui a pu être fait qu'on
pu être faite autour de autour de ces
données et pour le dire de façon très
claire pour moi la communication sur les
effets indésirables n'a pas été loyal et
là je reprends un terme de l'éthique en
santé c'est à dire qu'elles ne
permettaient pas un consentement libre
et éclairé comme l'exigent le code de la
santé publique et cette communication
était inadaptée mais en réalité ne
pouvait être qu inadaptée car elle était
au service d'une stratégie inadaptée
alors pourquoi je le qualifie cette
stratégie d' inadaptés je vais je vais
le préciser avant d'aborder plus
spécifiquement la communication et
notamment sur les effets indésirables
pourquoi elle était inadaptée car nous
avons explicitement mise en oeuvre en
france une stratégie de masse ça a été
rappelée visant une immunité collective
que l'on sait pourtant inaccessible par
la vaccination du mois par les
vaccinations seul seul c'est en effet
bien établie ça a été rappelée à
l'instant les vaccins si ralentissent
j'allais dire la diffusion de
l'infection ne permettent pas de dollar
était par contre permettent surtout et
c'est leur principale qualité de réduire
la probabilité des formes graves donc
avec ses caractéristiques vaccinale la
mesure de son
public qui pouvait évidente
ce serait de mettre tout en oeuvre pour
vacciner les personnes les plus à risque
de formes graves de par leur âge où je
parlerai à de santé ou la combinaison
des deux pourtant on a clairement fait
l' inverse en france et ça s'observe
dans le dans les chiffres jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on a choisi
de vacciner tout azimut la population
générale au détriment de ceux qui en
avaient le plus besoin et c'est au
détriment de ceux qu'on ait plus besoin
parce qu'on se dit si on vaccine tout le
monde on vaccine aussi les plus fragiles
n'ont malheureusement c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne en santé publique car
une mesure universelle est par nature
génératrice d'inégalités
car qui va s'emparer des modalités de
vaccination surtout telles qu'elles ont
été mis en oeuvre ce sont les plus
jeunes et les plus favorisés et on
observe très clairement dans les
statistiques françaises les personnes
les plus âgées les plus malades les plus
vulnérables socialement les personnes
atteintes d'un handicap ou d'une autre
vulnérabilité sont encore aujourd'hui
les moins vacciner alors qu'elles en ont
le plus besoin on s'est targué c'est
encore rappelé tout à l'heure d'avoir
une des meilleures couvertures
vaccinales d'europe en population
générale mais par contre on se targue un
peu moins d'avoir toujours la pire en
europe de l'ouest chez les plus de 80
ans qui nécessitent le plus d'être
vaccinés c'est un vrai paradoxe et c'est
un vrai nom sens du point de vue
sanitaire et je rajouterai aussi c'est
un gâchis du point de vue médico
économique parce que est-ce que c'est
très efficient de d'utiliser de
mobiliser des centaines de milliers
d'euros et des dizaines de milliers de
ressources humaines en santé de
professionnels de santé pour vacciner
alors que par ailleurs et
malheureusement à l'actualité tout le
monde tous les jours notre système de
santé souffre d'un manque de moyens
financiers et humains le cruel et c'est
ça aussi une vision de santé publique
c'est pas uniquement le moyen qu'on
utilise de manière absolue c'est aussi
de manière relative est ce qu'on l'a
utilisé au meilleur endroit que possible
alors toujours avec cette vision de
santé publique un ces deux là d'où je
pars et c'est de là d'où je parle
je voulais souligner que sa stratégie de
limiter collective assumer nous a fait
oublier des principes élémentaires qui
font notre contrat social et des
principes éthiques élémentaire et ça je
tiens à le dire avec force parce que
c'est extrêmement choquant du point de
vue de la santé publique et ça a été
tirman frappant pour les enfants et les
adolescents qui étaient vaccinés non pas
pour leur propre bénéfice mais d'abord
pour protéger les adultes je vous invite
à relire et je pourrais vous transmettre
les verbatim les documents les
interviews etc à relire les prises de
position de début 2021 sur la
vaccination des enfants et les
adolescents
c'était d'abord pour atteindre limitée
collective faute d'adultes en nombre
suffisant il faut vacciner les enfants
où il va falloir vacciner les enfants en
juin 2021 le ccn le comité consultatif
national d'éthique a rappelé comment
cette instrumentalisation des enfants
portés des principes fondamentaux de
l'éthique en santé le discours a donc
changé et comme on ne pouvait pas
justifier un bénéfice clinique majeur
individuel des enfants on a inventé un
bénéfice psychoéducatif on pourra en
reparler si vous le souhaitez et en
parallèle on maintenait toujours en
filigrane sans l'assumer mais en un
filigrane cette communication sur
l'immunité collective en gros les
enfants étaient des vecteurs de qu'ovide
qu'il est qu'il fallait vacciner pour
cela
ça peut vous sembler anecdotique mais
j'ai été frappé par les propos du
premier ministre de l'époque au moment
où il annoncé la vaccination des enfants
et l'extension de la vaccination des
enfants
qu'elle dit le premier ministre s'était
de mémoire le 6 décembre 2000
2021 il a dit que s'il avait été
contaminée rappelez vous il avait été
contaminée par le col vide c'était sa
fille de 11 ans qui l'avait contaminée
et il avait expliqué qu'il fallait ainsi
justice vacciner enfants car ils sont
des transmetteurs ainsi il ne s'agit pas
de protéger les enfants mais de se
protéger en tant qu'adulte des enfants
qui représentent un danger potosi
potentiel donc c'est pour moi une
rupture fondamentale avec des principes
fondamentaux éthique en santé
là pour préciser un le fait qu'une
vaccination un bénéfice individuel et un
bénéfice collectif oui et c'est le
principe même de la vaccination mais on
ne peut pas
mettre en avant le bénéfice collectif si
on n'a pas un bénéfice individuel et ça
c'est extrêmement important notamment
chez les personnes vulnérables comme les
enfants donc j'en viens maintenant
rapidement à la communication et je
pourrai préciser mes propos si vous le
souhaitez donc quand même connu comme
j'ai dit comme la stratégie était
inadapté laponie la communication ne
pouvait être inadapté en effet on a
choisi une vaccination de masse donc il
fallait vacciner en masse des personnes
qui n'en avaient pas besoin impérieux et
donc il fallait manipuler c'est à dire
en jouant sur ce qui fait qu'on choisit
de se faire vacciner nos travaux de
recherche puisque l'on travaille
notamment sur l'hésitation vaccinale est
ça
le travaille là-dessus l'an montre qu
est ce qui fait qu on se vaccine on se
vaccine si on pense qu'on est vulnérable
face à la maladie on vaccine si on pense
que le vaccin est efficace face à la
maladie et on pense et on se vaccine si
on pense que le vaccin est dénué
d'effets indésirables c'est un peu les
trois conditions trois éléments qui
permettent de construire une décision
individuelle et donc si on voulait
pousser des personnes jeunes en bonne
santé est vacciné il fallait forcer le
trait sur ces trois points c'est à dire
renforcer le sentiment de vulnérabilité
par rapport aux qu'ovide deuxièmement
exagérer les bénéfices liés au vaccin et
troisièmement mettre sous le tapis les
effets indésirables et je vais préciser
illustrer ces affirmations parce que ça
me semble vraiment important
premièrement renforcer le sentiment de
vulnérabilité
c'est la fameuse stratégie de la peur
qui n'a pas été spécifique du vaccin qui
a été visé dès le début de la crise qu
vie d'un rap et vous tous les soirs le
nombre de morts égrené à la télévision
c'est une stratégie de communication qui
est assumé à qui a été construite qui
s'appelle la stratégie de la peur et qui
a utilisé des voix extrêmement diverses
c'est par exemple les reportages télé au
moment de la lande lancement de la
campagne de vaccination des jeunes
adultes les reportages td sur le jeune
adulte en bonne santé sportive tout bien
sans mobilité et qui se retrouvaient
hospitalisée en réanimation au moment de
la campagne vaccinale des enfants en
janvier on a vu sur les réseaux sociaux
et ailleurs beaucoup d'informations sur
un nombre important de décès d'enfants
c'est de la manipulation des esprits
très clairement et très clairement
assumé d'ailleurs parce qu'ils ont
construit et qui passaient aussi parfois
par la manipulation des chiffres à je
vous invite comme référence à à
regarder le compte rendu ou à lire le
compte rendu de l'audition au sénat
d'alice desbiolles en janvier dernier de
mémoire qui a donné des exemples très
concrets de données dans la façon de les
présenter peuvent inciter à faire croire
telle ou telle caractéristique de
l'épidémie et c'est très important sur
cette stratégie de communication par la
peur est là pareil même des effets
indésirables importants
elle a contribué notamment à l'explosion
des problèmes de santé mentale
et ça c'est important de le dire en
france encore aujourd'hui un rapport de
santé publique france qui suit ça de
façon extrêmement précise de la semaine
dernière c'est près d'un tiers des
français qui aujourd'hui on est anxieux
ou dépressifs c'est énorme les
comparaisons internationales montrent
que la france c'est la pire évolution
d'europe en termes de santé mentale et
quand on parle d'effets indésirables de
la vaccination moi d'un point de vue
santé publique je fais un petit peu un
pas de côté c'est à dire qu'elle les
effets indésirables du vaccin en tant
que produits de santé dont on a beaucoup
parlé aujourd'hui mais aussi les effets
indésirables de la vaccination en tant
que stratégie est donc aussi la
communication afférentes à la
vaccination et cette stratégie de la
peur en termes de santé publique elle
n'est pas recommandé elles mêmes à
proscrite par toutes les sociétés
savantes international est depuis
longtemps parce qu'on sait qu'elle a des
effets indésirables dont notamment en
termes d'altération de la santé mentale
donc premièrement renforcer le sentiment
de vulnérabilité faire peur deuxièmement
survendre les bénéfices du vaccin jeu
pour aller vite parce que le temps est
compté je donnerais juste un slogan le
slogan gouvernemental tous vaccinés tous
protégés c'est qu'on sait que c'est faux
on sait que c'est complètement faux
s'est fait que news au sens premier du
terme et donc effectivement il fallait
smic et que le vaccin c'est est l'alpha
et l'oméga qui allait nous sortir de la
crise troisièmement mettre sous le tapis
les risques et ça c'est important les
risques qu'ils ont été identifiés ça a
été bien rappeler tout à l'heure des
tréteaux pour certains que ce soit en
france ou à l'étranger je pense par
exemple pour les myocardite à israël qui
a été un des premiers à vacciner les
ados et donc sur ce plan moi je n'ai
clairement choqué aussi toujours avec
mon regard de santé publique et
démocratie sanitaire du traitement
infligé aux victimes supposées des
vaccins parce que ces personnes qui
souffrent dans leur corps qui souffrent
dans leur vie parfois professionnelles
familiales sociales sont des victimes à
prendre en considération dans tous les
cas et ceci indépendamment du caractère
imputable causal de leur souffrance à la
vaccination parce que ça a dérapé tout à
l'heure c'est extrêmement complexe à
mettre en évidence à l'échelle
individuelles comme collectives mais
globalement dans la communication
publique ces victimes ont été ont été
méprisés c'est dans le choix du
vocabulaire employé par exemple on a
rarement entendu le terme myocardite
sans qu'on dise bénigne derrière que
plusieurs % selon les séries 4 à 20% des
jeunes en bonne santé qui font une
cocarde et de post vaccinales se
retrouve en réanimation cb n'a cédé
myocardite bénigne que ces jeunes
pendant 6 mois ne peuvent pas faire
d'activités physiques peuvent avoir être
en arrêt de travail et tout c'est bénin
famille aux quarts du pays les êtres en
physiologie multi-facteurs etc etc dans
le discours public médiatique en
permanence il y avait une minimisation
de des effets ressentis par les
personnes et ce mépris aller jusqu'à la
censure sur les réseaux sociaux
sur de nombreux réseaux sociaux les
témoignages des victimes là je parle je
parle pas de chèques news propagées par
des antilles max je prends des victimes
qui de leur lit d'hôpital racontent
leurs histoires étaient censurés sur les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'il ne fallait
pas faire peur et dans le cas d'une
campagne vaccinale quel mépris quel
mépris empêcher une victime de
s'exprimer
donc tout ça pour dire que nous avons en
parallèle un bénéfice sur vendue
notamment sûr une immunité collective et
des risques mis sous le tapis pas dans
la leur mesure je répète mais dans la
façon de le communiquer de façon
explicite ou implicite est donc ce
rapport bénéfice risque du vaccin qui
est régulièrement à s'affirmer comme
acquis finalement quel est il et ces
essais je vais terminer sur ce rapport
bénéfice risque parce que c'est une
question extrêmement importante et qui
est au coeur à vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre préambule et votre synthèse d des
premières auditions que vous avez
effectués non j'ai pas l'aborder du
point de vue chiffré je laisse cela aux
spécialistes je vais toujours essayer
dans la posture santé publique quelle
est la démarche éthique classique en
santé publique qui aurait dû d'ailleurs
ainsi celle de la campagne vaccinale et
ses différentes phases parce qu'on parle
de campagne et vous savez que de très
nombreuses phases et d'évolution leye
aussi aux évolutions de l'épidémie
l'évolution d'arriver sur le marché des
vaccins les
arrivées de donner envie réelle etc etc
mais bon si je parle de la campagne
vaccinale ont globalement d'abord la
première règle si on doit objectiver le
rapport bénéfice/risque préalablement à
la mise en oeuvre de la mesure du choix
de l'indication du choix de vacciner
untel ou untel et de telle façon on doit
l'objectiver ces préalables et
deuxièmement on compte on se doit une
transparence de ce rapport pour que
chacun en fonction de ses
caractéristiques puisse consentir de
manière libre et éclairé je le rappelle
c'est le code de santé publique le code
de la santé publique en france or à ma
connaissance je peux me tromper mais je
les ai lus je pense tous et plusieurs
fois aucun des avis aussi bien dans la
haute autorité de santé c'est d'ailleurs
de là naissent m donc présenté de telles
données à l'appui leurs préconisations
c'est à dire quel est le rapport
bénéfice risque du vaccin en fonction de
son âge en fonction de son sexe de son
état de santé parce que c'est souvent
l'information qui est oublié dans
beaucoup d'études et d'ailleurs dans les
statistiques que nous sont présentés
chaque semaine des scénarios d'évolution
de l'épidémie et ceci contextualiser à
la france et j'assiste parce que ça a
été dit tout à l'heure c'est extrêmement
difficile d'extrapoler ces données d'un
contexte à l'autre d'un moment à l'autre
puisque le rapport bénéfice risque
dépend bien sûr de la dynamique de
l'épidémie du risque d'infection de la
nature du variant et s'était risqué mais
on avait rien là dessus et ses amis se
contentait d'affirmer le rapport un
argument d'autorité il y un rapport
bénéfice risque favorable comme la
plupart d'ailleurs des études de
pharmacoépidémiologie qui est objective
et tel ou tel risque mais ce risque ne
remet pas en question le rapport
bénéfice risque mais sans donner de
chiffres sans donner de preuves sans
donner d'éléments et au pire
reconnaissez qu'il n'en savait rien à
titre d'exemple je voulais la première
phase de la vie de l'année scène janvier
2022 c'était plutôt la haute autorité de
santé inquiète en charge mais comme
aujourd'hui nous l'avions l'année sème
donc je je ne suis permis de citer cette
agence donc la vie de la nation du 18
janvier 2002 sur la dose de rappel chez
les adolescents je voulais la première
phrase je cite in extenso la msm et le m
a donc l' agence européenne ne dispose
pas encore des données d'immunogénicité
d'efficacité et de sécurité portant sur
une dose de rappel chez les personnes
âgées de 12 à 17 ans qui permettent
d'établir un rapport bénéfice risque
clairement on ne savait pas le 18
janvier 2022 suisse suite à cet avis les
services du premier ministre annoncent
est quasiment dans les heures ou les
jours suivants que les adolescents de 12
à 17 ans peuvent désormais recevoir une
dose de rappel du vaccin contre le comme
ils disent nous on n'a pas de rapport
bénéfice risque on extrapole sur les
adultes etc malgré tout ce que l'on sait
des différences selon l'âge et comment
on peut aujourd'hui mettre en place ce
rappel avec de tels noms l'argument
surtout que chez des adolescents double
vacciner le risque en janvier 2022 de
formes graves étaient annuler parce
qu'il n'est jamais nul malheureusement
le risque mais extrêmement minime donc
ça ne justifiait pas en tout cas de
mettre en place une politique publique
aussi force tout ce que ça veut dire en
termes de risques potentiels en termes
d'efficience avec des arguments si
faible
donc tout cela professeur confesseur
respecter oui professeur ouais vous êtes
il faut se diriger la conclusion vous
êtes déjà à peu près à trois fois le
temps que nous avions prévu au départ
pour votre intervention je suis suis
désolé donc je vais conclure je passe
directement la conclusion donc pour moi
et comme pour nous tous un c'était
inespéré d'avoir aussi rapidement des
vaccins aussi efficace qui représente un
développeur de sortie de la crise
malheureusement c'est souvent présenté
comme le
nous permettant de sortir de la crise
une stratégie en cohérence avec les
caractéristiques des vaccins et des
besoins de la population auraient pu
contribuer à produire de meilleurs
résultats en termes de proville tout à
l'heure on a cité s'il n'y avait pas eu
d'accès voilà milliard de morts mais moi
ce que je dis c'est que si on avait
mieux si les vaccins et mieux vacciner
ceux qui en avaient besoin c'est aussi
beaucoup de morts évitées tous les jours
encore aujourd'hui c'est plusieurs
dizaines de décès par jour 2 n'ont
réussi ni de personne extrêmement
vulnérables socialement par l'âge par l'
isolement etc
on aurait pu - dc fort probablement on
aurait limité cette casse monstrueuse en
termes de santé mentale notamment chez
les plus jeunes il y en aurait aussi
éviter cette perte de confiance parce
que ça a été analysé par les études
notamment avec des mesures telles que le
paso aux parallèlement à l'augmentation
globale la confiance diminue avec tout
ce que ça peut gêner généré 1 comme
atteinte à la cohésion sociale et aussi
en termes de santé publique tous les
autres vaccins non obligatoires ont
chuté les dépistages des cancers en
chute et quand on perd de la confiance
en santé publique malheureusement ça
fait durable et systémique c'est un vrai
gâchis donc merci professeur
professeur il faut vraiment conclure
non mais tout ça pour dire que souvent
la démocratie sanitaire a été mis entre
parenthèses cette crise parce qu'on
considérait professeurs nous avons deux
autres intervenants juste après les
obstacles à la santé je pense qu'au
contraire ce ne sont pas les autres facs
la santé mais des conditions à la santé
je pense qu'il faut revenir sur des
bases professeurs nous sommes obligés de
passer à la suite je suis désolé mais
nous avons bien entendu vous allez merci
pour cette intervention il y aura bien
sûr tout loisir de réponse de la part
des autres experts présents à commencer
par écouter les deux autres
contradicteurs c'est comme ça qu'on
pourra le présenter et je commencerai
par donner la parole donc au docteur
amine oumlil c'est comme ça qu'on
prononce ou lille vous êtes pharmacien
hospitalier vous êtes directeur du
centre territorial d'information
indépendante et davy pharmaceutiques du
centre hospitalier de cholet à vous la
parole
je vous remercie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs chers collègues
je suis honoré de cette invitation pour
participer à ce débat contradictoire
inutile c'est ce débat qui a manqué
depuis le début de la crise on ne serait
pas là aujourd'hui si ce débat avait
lieu depuis plusieurs mois et on n'a pas
cessé de le demander
alors à titre liminaire je déclare
n'avoir aucun lien et aucun conflit
d'intérêts les deux informations
nouvelles donc je rappelle que j'ai dans
le cadre de mon audition durant laquelle
j'ai pu m'exprimer librement avec
mesdames et sénatrices et monsieur le
député j'ai fourni un gt j'ai transmis
un rapport circonstancié tout 92 pages
qui relate l'intégralité ce sens que des
données qui proviennent des documents
officiels de la haute autorité de santé
de l'agencé européenne du médicament de
l'année scène et de l'igas de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales
de nouvelles informations qui sont
publiés sur le site de l'asm le 26 avril
coville 19 communication pour le bon
usage des vaccins et des médicaments
indiqués dans la copie 19 avec une
première partie bon usage des vaccins et
des médicaments indiqués dans la colline
19 mise en place d'une communication
n'en promotionnelle à destination des
professionnels de santé il a on apprend
on lit l'évolutivité permanente et
rapide de la stratégie vaccinale aux
thérapeutiques ainsi que de données de
sécurité et de bon usage est
incompatible avec l'obligation de
diffuser auprès des professionnels de
santé une information exacte si à jour
et pour cause et le même jour et sans
doute suite à ce que j'ai transmis
ou à porter
le même jour le site de l'asm a mis en
évidence
a mis en évidence les trois composition
du vaccin comme erna tic qui sont
actuellement disponibles il me semble
que la composition initiale qui avait
fait l'objet de l'essai clinique
randomisée en double aveugle de deux
files r il me semble qu'il n'est plus en
circulation et j'ai découvert ces
compositions par hasard et il y avait un
article qui était consacrée à sa sur le
site du 7e il ya deux formulations pour
l'adulte et
maintenant j'en dis dans des réactions
de négation du côté de experts nous
aurons loisirs bien sûr donner la parole
dans certains cas rendant un
contradicteur absolument les a écoutés
attentivement longuement et que nous
faisons absolument j'étais loin d'être
d'accord avec parce qu'on a assisté à un
véritable festival d'affirmations
général pour nourrir une appréciation
d'ordre général moi je souhaite rentrer
sur des faits précis qui sont extraits
du rapport qui a été transmis aux
parlementaires et après je répondrai à
toutes les questions
voilà dans sera un échange en tant que
pharmacien j'ai découvert suite à une
alerte d'une consoeur pharmacienne mois
d'avril 2002 terre que je je je je vais
focaliser mon raisonnement sur le vaccin
faïza commergnat ti parce que c'est les
plus prescrits c'est le premier autorisé
c'est donc avec lequel on n'a plus le
plus de recul mais le mélo raisonnement
est transposable aux autres vaccins bien
entendu
voilà avec quoi ce donc ce set une à une
et même européen centralisée
conditionnelle dérogatoire d'urgence
donc il est clair que en étaient en
attente de
d'informations complémentaires
sur aussi bien le rapport bénéfice
risque mais ce qui est inédit en temps
pour moi en tant que pharmacien sur la
composition de même du vaccin je vous
lis un extrait de ce qui figure dans un
document publié par l'agencé européenne
du médicament et auxquelles on peut
accéder par le site de l'année c'est
donc l'agencé européenne du médicament
attendez je vous parle du mois d'avril
du militaire attend et c'est toujours le
cas il me semble donc des preuves
complémentaires concernant la
caractérisation de la substance active
et du produit fini
le renforcement de la stratégie de
contrôle afin d'assurer une qualité
constante du produit des données de
validation supplémentaire en vue de
confirmer la reproductibilité du procédé
de fabrication du produit fini le
procédé de synthèse et la stratégie de
contrôle de deux excipients qui serait
nouveau la lc 0,315 la lc 0 159 convient
de confirmer leur profil de pureté et
d'assurer un contrôle de qualité et une
reproductibilité entre les lots tout au
long du cycle de vie du produit fini en
tant que pharmacien je ne sais pas
comment ils ont pu libérer un lot étant
donné que le procès des fabrications
sympathie complètement caractérisée
je vous rappelle vous l'avez rappelé
qu'un vaccin c'est un médicament avec
deux facettes qui rappelle étrangement
séparables car un pâle carter qui
rappelle étrangement une pièce de
monnaie le bénéfice et le risque que
l'appréciation du risque se fait au
regard du bénéfice escompté la catégorie
d'âge démontré par des preuves de haute
qualité que le vaccin s'adresse à des
personnes en bonne santé et donc
nécessairement si le bénéfice n'est pas
démontrée le rapport bénéfices risques
est nécessairement des favoris
donc je vous remercie pour le titre donc
déclaration analysé communication et
comme l'a dit et comme l'a dit madame la
sénatrice l'information
l'information de la population et le
noeud est le coeur du conflit qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui parce que
l'information
jaillit sur les règles de prescription
jaillit sur l'information du public et
jahier ensuite sur le sur le
consentement libre et éclairé
alors des documents officiels on peut
affirmer sans difficulté aucune qu'en
décembre 2020 le jour où la campagne de
vaccination a été lancée que la preuve
n'a pas été apportée d'une quelconque
efficacité sur les formes graves sur la
transmission virale et on a oublié de
dire aux gens aussi que l'essai clinique
étaient toujours en cours et qu'on était
face à un produit expérimental il s'agit
bien d'un pari biologique
ça me cause pas de problème mais est ce
que la population a été informée
le coc vie de 19 je ne conteste pas la
gravité de la maladie il a pu tuer ça
c'est certain pour autant
il a tué
pour autant il ne figure pas sur les
deux listes réglementaire des maladies à
déclaration obligatoire je vous renvoie
aux deux liste des 31 qui sont consacrés
par le des 31 13-6 et le des 31 13-7
associé à l'article législatif elle 31
13-1 du conte santé publique le leem les
entreprises du médicament en juillet
2021 dans un document intitulé coville
19 et vaccins nous disent que cette
maladie est plus contagieuse que le sras
c'est le maire ce mais qu'elle a un
moindre taux de mortalité je dis bien
juillet 2021
malgré l'insuffisance ou l'absence je
dis bien l'absence et madame la
sénatrice viens de le dire à propos des
enfants
malgré l'insuffisance ou l'absence des
données on a injecté des populations
chez lesquels qu'on n'avait pas assez de
données et cela émane des documents
officiels encore une fois les plus de 75
ans les immunodéprimés et je répondrai
aux responsables de la taxe force
vaccination tout à l'heure
les femmes enceintes les femmes qui
allaitent et bien sûr les enfants
alors je rappelle que la
pharmacovigilance
je parle aussi monsieur le président en
ma qualité du juriste es-tu là d'une
chance aux droits et damnation de breda
santé à rennes et de la chasse pays donc
je suis aussi également juriste en droit
en droit de la santé et je comprends et
je suis responsable si la
pharmacovigilance depuis 20 ans au
centre hospitalier de cholet
donc la pharmacovigilance au titre au
sens la pharmacovigilance au sens du
code de la santé publique ne consiste
pas uniquement à compter les effets
indésirables comme ils l'ont dit mme
école de santé arc en vigilance mais
aussi à prévenir ses effets indésirables
notamment graves notamment les décès et
le
problème c'est le lien de causalité dont
on sera appelé à parler
de même prévenir les effets indésirables
et éviter de surcharger les sentes
pharmacovigilance passe par le respect
des règles de prescription c'est à dire
un médecin m'a prescrit selon les
données acquises de la science et un
pharmacien de par l'indépendance
professionnelle qui l'a ainsi que le
médecin est dans l'obligation de faire
barrage à des prescriptions qui ne sont
pas conformes aux données acquises de la
science
alors
le 21 avril
2021 on reçoit un mail de la dgs urgents
qui nous demandent de prescrire trois
doses on peut aller jusqu'à trois doses
chez les minimes déprimé et chez les
personnes qui ont des traitements
immunosuppresseurs
lorsqu'on regarde l'autorisation de
mission au marché conditionnelle
cette population est considérée dans la
rubrique mise en garde spéciale comme
étant
enfin on n'a pas de données chez cette
population et cela figure dans une
rubrique mise en garde spéciale de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
cela s'appelle du mésusage au titre du
code de santé publique c'est à dire ce
sont des comportements
intentionnel je me sens bien dans les
infraction intentionnelle
inappropriés qui s'écarte du cadre
défini par l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché
l'urgence ne justifie pas tout
vous avez opposé ce principe à des
traitements comme l'hydro xi chloroquine
pourtant ce sont des vieux traitement et
je ne conteste pas cela
je conteste le fait qu'on la con les
deux poids deux mesures pour dévier
molécules en l'opposent et en exige
légitimement des profs de qualité pour
des vaccins sans même demander
l'autorisation à la population concernée
s'ils sont d'accord pour s'injecter et
faire parti d'un pari biologique alors
l'information est un droit c'est en gros
l'information est un droit pour toute
personne le paternalisme médical est
révolue depuis au moins la loi kouchner
quand j'entends le professeur fisher me
dire on a injecté telle population
j'ai envie de vous dire est ce que vous
leur avez demandé leur avis
le consentement donc l'information le
code santé publique dit et pas que le
conte sortie publique les bonnes
pratiques de pharmacovigilance qui ont
été établies par le 2 février 2018 par
la direction générale de l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
qui sont intégrés ou quoi santé publique
donc ils sont imposables aussi
l'information doit être claire loyale et
appropriée
c'est une audition qui est très suivi il
serait
dommage que des problèmes techniques
viennent perturber les échanges
contradictoires
comme vous l'avez compris mes chers
collègues nous sommes partis pour
dépasser très largement le cadrage
temporel initialement prévu
c'est
ceux qui ont des contraintes temporelles
dans la suite seront prioritaires pour
prendre la parole bien évidemment
c'est la première fois que je vois de
tels soucis techniques
n'allez pas croire à un sabotage même si
certains feront bien évidemment la
suggestion
et une qui
cinq minutes de pause
pour égayer un
très bien
j'essaie de calculer un peu
en dhr merci de couper la soufflerie
voilà très bien
est ce que quelqu'un peut confirmer que
alors voyons en relançant le flux est ce
quelqu'un peut confirmer que la vidéo et
la remet
très bien
de manière éphémère qu'entendez vous par
cette intéressante adjectif vias
ça ne marche pas
n'ont pas le sou
ok
et bien allons-y
reprenons je vous rappelle
que
nous sommes très ordonné que la
technique le technology viennent nous
faire défaut et nous a donné une demi
heure de retard supplémentaire
professeur fisher à une contrainte à
17h30 essayons de tout faire pour les
rapporteurs aussi ont des contraintes et
commencer à se dire que l était bien
courageuse de se lancer au départ dans
cette dans cette mission mais toujours
vaillante
reprenons et professeurs et je vous
proposais docteur mme l'île de reprendre
votre intervention donc juste avant que
sa coupe vous est il en train de parler
de la question de la question de la
composition
je vous remercie donc je disais que les
autorités adoptent notamment l'agencé
européenne du médicament attendait des
preuves complémentaire
avec ce vaccin king ancien et non
seulement le bénéfice et le risque mais
également ce qui est inédit pour
information comme moi concernant la
composition de ces vaccins est donc un
calendrier précis attendait des preuves
concernant la caractérisation de la
substance active et du produit fini le
renforcement de la stratégique de
contrôle afin d'assurer une qualité
constante du produit des données de
validation supplémentaire en vue de
confirmer la reproductibilité du procédé
de fabrication du produit fini le
procédé de synthèse et la stratégie de
contrôle de deux exceptions qui serait
ne vous donc le lc
0,315 et le fc 0 159 en vue de confirmer
leur profil de pureté et d'assurer un
contrôle de qualité et une
reproductibilité entre les lots tout au
long du cycle de vie du produit fini
donc
en posant la question
sur ses propres attendus alors que les
dates d'échéance ont été dépassés
on l'a posé la question à l'asm on a eu
de réponses différentes donc madame la
directrice a répondu un avocat qu'elle
ne savait pas qu'elle transmettait la
demande
à l'agencé européenne du médicament par
ailleurs une autre entité de l'asm la
cellule accueil usagers a répandu à un
médecin qui s'interrogeait sur ses
propres complémentaires on lui a répondu
que tout allait bien que les preuves
étaient transmises donc mais bon on
tiendra compte de la réponse de la
directrice de l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui ne savaient
pas qui a transmis à l'agencé européenne
du médicament nos questions et
conformément au règlement de 2004 et
notamment l'article 20 points 4
anne est un membre peut de sa propre
initiative
suspendre l'utilisation d'un produit de
santé sur son territoire pour protéger
la santé de la population cas de besoin
et donc comment l'asm ne peut pas être
informé de suivi de ses propres
complémentaires qui était attendu et par
ailleurs dans ces documents vous
trouverez que ce qui confirme que le
secteur continue que l' agence
européenne attentes de rapports pour le
pour le vaccin said there décembre 2023
et juillet 2024
donc je rappelle que brièvement que
l'appréciation du risque se fait aux
gardes de bénéfices escomptés que le
vaccin s'adresse à des personnes en
bonne santé santé définition donnée par
le ms et que en l'absence d'un bénéfice
démontré par des profs de haute qualité
ce qui est d'ailleurs et y est exigé
pour des molécules anciennes et bien le
rapport est nécessairement défavorable
d'autant plus que l'ensemble dans un
cadre expérimental
donc le raisonnement vous l'avez compris
ça va se focaliser sur le vaccin parce
que c'est les plus prescrits le premier
autorisé pour lequel nous avons le plus
de recul mais le raisonnement peut être
transposée aux autres vaccins
donc concernant le vaccin fayer et
ressort des documents officiels
notamment de la haute autorité de santé
que la construction de l'essai clinique
lui même ne permettait pas d'apporter la
preuve d'une efficacité sur les formes
graves ou sur la transmission virale il
s'agit bien d'un pari biologique que la
population aussi n'a pas été informée de
façon claire sur le fait que les s'agit
bien d'un essai clinique
lakovic 19 est une maladie qui tue qui a
tué
pour autant elle ne figure toujours pas
sur les deux listes réglementaire des
maladies à déclaration obligatoire pour
figurer sur cette liste il faut être une
maladie dangereuse contagieuse et
disposer d'un test de diagnostic fiable
donc je vous renvoie aux articles d 31
13-6 tu es tirs et 7 combiné avec
l'article l 31 13-1 du corps de santé
publique le lem les entreprises du
médicament le 27 juin le 17 juillet 2021
ont publié un document intitulé kovy 19
et vaccins
selon le lem locaux vides 19 la copie 19
est plus contagieuse que le sras c'est
le maire ce mec est là à moindre taux de
mortalité
est peut-être affirmé donc selon donc
mois de décembre 2020 que malgré
l'insuffisance ou l'absence des données
des populations et y injecter je citerai
en particulier les plus de 75 ans par
lesquels on avait commencé les
immunodéprimés les femmes enceintes les
femmes qui allaitent et les enfants
monsieur le responsable de la taxe forcé
vaccination
donc la dgs urgent on a reçu un mail le
11 avril 2021 qui nous incite et
professions de santé allaient jusqu'à 3
12 pour les immunodéprimés or
l'autorisation d'émission marché
conditionnelle dans la rubrique mise en
garde spéciale indiqué qu'on n'avait pas
assez de données et pour un pharmacien
cela s'appelle du mésusage et engage la
responsabilité pénale du pharmacien
notamment du médecin la
pharmacovigilance ne consiste pas selon
le conseiller publica à kant et les
effets indésirables graves notamment les
décès mais aussi et surtout à les
prévenir
donc ça ne conduit à s'interroger en
amande de l'apparition des effets
indésirables et notamment sur les
conditions de prescription et de
dispensation pharmaceutique d'autant
plus que la méthode d'un petit ville
d'imputabilité à utiliser en
pharmacovigilance à deux limites qui
sont connus admise par tout le monde et
qui ne sont pas la faute de responsable
pharmacovigilance c'est une méthode qui
murray qui a comme première limite une
signification importante le réseau
français des 31 centres locaux vigilante
8e le mois de novembre 2021 que à neuf
est indésirable sur le 10 ans montait
seulement
lé deuxième limite c'est que la méthode
ne permet pas d'affirmer la certitude de
lien de causalité et ça les gens ont du
mal à comprendre et vous reprendrez
toutes mes conférences ont fait l'effort
de leur expliquer que si la
pharmacovigilance ne peut pas affirmer
la certitude de lien de causalité c'est
pas parce qu'elle vous cacher des choses
mais que c'est lié à la haine à la
limite de la de la méthode utilisée pour
autant le rapport de l'igas de 2011 a
formulé de sévères critiques
2011 ligas 2001 un rapport que gérant
mieux par l'eau enfin rapporteur il a
formé de sévères critiques à l'égard de
la pharmacovigilance française ils
affirment qu' elle ne veut pas évolué et
qu'elle n'a pas fait évoluer ses
méthodes et que ses outils son décalage
avec les objectifs affichés de la
pharmacovigilance et ne reviendront je
prendrai deux cas sur les décès et sur
le cas d'un enfant qui a perdu la vue et
qui montre que la méthode d'imputabilité
qui a été fixé par la sueur rapport le
rapport numéro deux
du 28 janvier 2021 et qui a été publiée
sur le sud 2-2 line et sème
une méthode d'imputabilité a été fixée
quel impact qui ne semble pas avoir été
respectée cette méthode dit quoi que en
l'absence donc on peut écarter la
responsabilité du vaccin dès lors je
cite qu'une autre cause vers gül
certaines permet d'expliquer les faits
un désir a notamment le décès or nous
avons dans le rapport numéro 18 qui
s'est arrêté les données de mémoire au
26 août 2021 nous avons dans le rapport
numéro deux vies de publier sur le site
de l'asm
900 sadc
et dans ce rapport on lit que uniquement
les personnes nées vivante
et moins de 50 ans en fait l'objet d'une
analyse approfondie
première question pourquoi
deuxième question sur donc ce qui
représente 35 décès sur l'absence est
et sur les 35 décès qui ont fait l'objet
d'une analyse approfondie il ya 16 qui
sont étiquetés dans ce rapport de cause
inconnue cause inconnue veut dire que on
n'a pas ce qui a été définie par la
méthode initialement on n'a pas de cause
autres certaines qui permettent
d'expliquer le gars c'est
donc la conclusion aura dû est la
suivante sans affirmer le la certitude
de vienne causalité il aurait dû publier
quand on ne peut pas écarter le rôle du
dax un deuxième exemple un enfant qui a
perdu la vue et donc j'étais obligé à la
demande de ses conseils juridiques j'ai
fait deux expertises juridiques à la
demande d'un avocat pénaliste et de
notre avocate pour l'enfant qui a perdu
la vue
j'ai rendu la conclusion sur la méthode
définie par la haine et sam c'est à dire
là toute la batterie de tests qui a été
fait pour cet enfant
négatif
j'ai rendu la conclusion présomption
simple de causalité qui n'est pas
irréfragable parce qu' aucune autre
cause certains ne permet de l'affirmer
enfin ne permet d'expliquer pourquoi cet
enfant au bout de quatre jours après la
première injection il devenu aveugle
l'hôpital dans la région parisienne de
l'ap-hp qui avait pris cet enfant en
charge la pharmacovigilance officielle a
rendu dans un courrier entre possession
la même conclusion que moi on ne peut
pas exclure le rôle du vaccin j'ai pas
vu cette phrase dans un rapport de la
jeunesse m à la date du 26 août 2021
parce qu'à partir de ce moment là quand
j'ai vu comment on écarter comme ça
facilement des cas précis j'ai arrêté de
lire les documents publiés sur le site
de l'asm alors que j'ai fait que de les
diffuser depuis le début parce que je
trouvais que la msa ma ferme mon travail
important tous les quinze jours on avait
un rapport c'est transparent
effectivement meka partie cette date là
où je voyais quels que soient les cas
dès le premier décès le premier décès
c'était en janvier 2000 20 heures on
avait cette phrase c'est une personne
nepad on avait cette phrase
aucun effet indésirable et médias n'est
intervenu phrase suivante le décès est
intervenu deux heures après alors si
deux heures après c'est pas un effet
immédiat je ne sais pas ce que c'est
donc en tout cas je ne comprends pas
donc on a assisté aussi une véritable
des recommandations faites par des
autorités officielles
je citerai l'asm est un cas précis la
haine s est mis la haute autorité de
santé qui nous oblige et qui n'ont
recommandé de passer outre
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
amm exemple dès le mois de janvier 2021
la l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
de fin du laboratoire pfizer nous
demandait de respecter un délai de 21
jours entre la première et la deuxième
injection
et là il essaime recommande qu'on peut
et se passer le délai jusqu'à 42 jours
elle a été suivie quelques jours plus
tard par la haute autorité de santé et
ce fait a même conduit
l'académie de médecine elle même de
rappeler les risques d'un tel
allongement délai entre les deux
injections et a rappelé que 2 le
laboratoire lui-même a dit j'avais
l'impression que le laboratoire était
plus prudent que le gendarme du
médicament le laboratoire a dit qu'il ne
pouvait pas garantir les résultats
affichés avec un tel espace mandela les
risques rappelé par l'académie de
médecine c'est l'apparition d'anti corps
facilitant professeur fisher a parlé d
anticorps neutralisants mais il a oublié
de parler des antilles qu'en facilitant
et le risque de voir apparaître des
variants des résistants une sorte de
résistance à la vaccination
l'information est un droit on n'a pas
entendu un mot sur le consentement lors
de la première table ronde pains
seulement sur le consentement
il fallait que le professeur à la le
rappel c'était le premier dans sa qui a
parlé le consentement est une liberté
fondamentale
le conte santé publique dit il ya un
lien le consentement et le lien qui
assure et un lien non
le code santé publique commence par une
première partie qui s'appelle protection
générale de la santé
ce président donc le canton public
commence par une première partie qui
s'appelle protection générale de la
santé et à part un chapitre préliminaire
droit des personnes parmi ses droits le
respect de la dignité de la personne
humaine ce principe de dignité de la
personne humaine repose sur le respect
de l'autonomie de la volonté
qui avec le respect du secret médical
constitue les deux pièces maîtresses de
la relation de confiance qui unit la
personne à son médecin lors de colloques
singuliers que vous connaissez donc
lorsqu'en porte lorsqu'on ne diffuse pas
une information je cite contenter public
et les bonnes pratiques de
pharmacovigilance qui sont intégrés le
conte santé publique claire loyale et
appropriée
on prend le risque de vie si le
consentement qui doit être normalement
libre et éclairé et surprotégé puisqu'on
est encore dans le cadre d'un essai
clinique est bien quand on fait pas ça
on porte atteinte on prend le risque de
porter atteinte à la dignité de la
personne humaine je peux vous montrer à
quel niveau se situe au niveau de
l'information comme adil madame la
sénatrice c'est le noeud du problème
c'est pas les accents le problème
problème c'est pas le vaccin problème
c'est l'obligation d'un texte de faire
intégrer des gens dans un essai clinique
de force par une obligation par la loi
une loi entre guillemets qui n'a
toujours pas été validé par le conseil
constitutionnel l'article 12 pour les
professionnels de santé pour les
pompiers et toutes les tous les
personnels qui sont sommés cette
obligation
les parlementaires qui ont pardon
rappelez-nous juste je devrais savoir
mais l'article 12 c'est celui-là il
doute celui qui consacre l'obligation
vaccinale pour les professionnels de
santé pour les pompiers et tous les
toutes les autres professions et
l'article 14 celui qui consacre les
sanctions c'est à dire le fait de
désactiver socialement ces
professionnels de façon extrajudiciaire
en mépris de tous les droits de la
défense sans entretien préalable et qui
nous a propulsés je sais pas un siècle
en arrière en termes de droit du travail
le conseil constitutionnel lorsqu'il a
été saisi par les parlementaires lors du
contrôle de constitutionnalité a priori
pour les professions de santé la
question de la constitutionnalité des
articles 12 et n'a pas été soulevée le
conseil constitutionnel avait la
possibilité de relever cela d'office et
ne l'a pas fait et toutes les questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité qui
ont été soulevées dans le cadre des
litiges ont été rejetées bloqué par le
conseil d'état matin et
voilà alors juste juste pour vous dire
voilà
si on est on est plus sur une analyse
voit la politique alors respectable mais
plus sur les questions politiques donc
je reviens sur que sur les dossiers ont
reçu ce jour technique
je reviens sur le sujet le défaut
d'information aussi le défaut
d'information aussi peut faire encourir
ac et le mésusage peut faire encourir à
ces produits la qualification juridique
de produits défectueux ce qui serait
dommage donc je rappelle que le principe
c'est l'inde où l'habilité du corps
humain et que l'acception c'est
l'intervention médicale et je viens
maintenant vous lire quelques à quoi on
a eu le droit
en termes de communication
je cite ce qui a été publié le 9 juillet
2021 sur le compte 8 hier du ministre
des solidarités de la santé jeu des boks
et luigi sur son compte twitter
vaccination kovy 19 si vous avez des
courbatures après le vaccin pas
d'inquiétude sais que vous avez trop
pédaler et envoie une photo de jeunes en
train de pédaler avec un pédalo à la
surface de l'eau je me cissé la mer où
l'eau ou une rivière
une affiche
diffusée sur le site de l'agencé
régionale de santé lui le vaccin peut
avoir des effets indésirables
voilà et je peux vous voulez vous lister
comme ça plein de slogans d'affiche de
bidouillages publicitaire qui montre que
tout a été fait pour minimiser les
effets indésirables et pour embellir le
bénéfice est notamment auprès des jeunes
alors pour les essences
pharmacovigilance je connais enfin j'ai
pas fini monsieur le président j'ai même
pas eu le temps de allez y mais on a
resserré à 35 je pense qu'un 05 vous
êtes déjà 20 minutes de temps de parole
total me semble-t-il je sais pas mais
qui ont parlé mais c'est important ce
que j'ai à dire je vais aller vite
aller à l'essentiel s'il vous plaît oui
on a eu des des journaux des femmes
shaker qui nous ont dit qu'on ne pouvait
déclarer que les effets indésirables
graves inattendue la loi le comte santé
publique dit qu'on peut te déclarer
j'ai assisté à des obstacles c'est à
dire à la demande de prophètes de santé
on a mis en oeuvre dans la région pays
de loire une aide à la déclaration pour
les professionnels de santé et pour les
citoyens juste pour jouer
l'intermédiaire entre le centre
pharmacovigilance et entre ses citoyens
qu'ils étaient perdus attaque frontale
par voie de presse du directeur de
l'hôpital lui-même
219 médecins et pharmaciens par voie de
presse qui dit qu'ils ont affirmé qu'il
n'y a pas de son multi fication
pharmacovigilance je donne un exemple je
vous ai parlé du lien de causalité qui
le long du problème
concernant la jeunesse m on a parlé des
liens de causalité
ils vous disent ils font des analyses
observé attendu en même temps ils nous
disent qu'il ya des une notification
donc comment on peut parler d' observer
sur le numérateur observé lorsque on
l'utilisé mais d'autres observé attendu
le numérateur et forcément sous-estimé
donc donc c'est une question
g1k choletais un seul cas qui a conduit
à la modification de la elle-même en
introduisant en effet indésirable plein
vent cathy intercity a soufflé cas il
n'y donc un médicament de cardiologie
avec une consultation de la base de
données pharmacovigilance qui est
montrée 24 car de 1983 à 2007 24 cas
dans un ce décès suspect avait conduit à
un ouvrage ou de la mention dans la
rubrique les faire venir e
concernant essayer d'aller vraiment il
nous faut diriger vers la conclusion
sinon n'auront pas le temps justement de
réaliser le contradictoire et nous avons
entre des intervenants bleus dernière
dernière chose peut-être sur le bénéfice
risque je vous invite monsieur le
président à lire ce que je me suis
ministre des solidarités de la santé en
personne
a dit lors d'une conférence de presse le
18 février 2021 qu'aucune 18 février
aucune preuve sur les formes graves
aucun pays européens n'avaient apporté
les preuves sur une forme grave alors
qu'on avait commencé à vacciner deux
mois auparavant et regardez le rapport
qu'il a versé au conseil d'état pour
justifier le maintien
des personnes doublement vacciner
il n'avait pas le droit de porter des
ehpad elle était confinée au même titre
que les personnes non vaccinées quatre
arguments quand vous lisez cette hargne
ces quatre arguments du ministre dans un
mémoire en date du 28 mars 2021 versés
auprès du conseil d'état vous vous
demandez à quoi sert ce vaccin
et je vous passe pour les contradictions
sur le rapport en question j'ai les
citer toutes les contradictions des
autorités entre elles sur les formes
graves et sur la transmission virale
donc il ya aucune affirmation de matar
ce sens que des extraits des autorités
officielles mairie je vais arrêter là
merci docteur moïse sur monsieur le
professeur fisher je les renvoie à la
nôtre d'alert que le cos avait des
fusées et qui a montré des clusters dans
les ehpad et savait pertinemment il
parlait au conditionnel et savait
pertinemment il je peux vous la lyre
l'efficacité donné mais pas celles qui
étaient diffusées dans les médias donc
c'est 35% au conditionnel et savait très
bien mais en même temps est-ce qu'il
quartier je vais arrêter là ce qui est
caractéristique dans cette affaire il
est mathématicien monsieur le président
la logique vous savez ce que vous
mathématicien épidémiologue oui mais la
logique vous connaissez on ne peut pas
relever toutes ses insuffisances on ne
peut pas se prévaloir de ses
contradictions c'est à dire relevé que
le vaccin il ya des clusters il ya des
insuffisances et c est donc la
conclusion on prend la conclusion
inverse c'est à dire que quand aux
comptines vacciner iront peut surtout et
surtout on peut obliger les gens on ne
peut pas obliger les gens à se vacciner
merci d'autres termes elle pour cela
merci docteur élire mesure je pense que
l'obligation vaccinale il faudrait
l'arrêter au plus vite merci dr mais
c'est très violent merci pour cette
présentation avec de nombreux arguments
et nombreuses citations
de rapports et autres et évidemment à
cette audition il ya des compléments qui
peuvent être des questions écrit des
dossiers écrits autres et tout a été
effectivement transmis au rapporteur qui
s'occuperont aussi de l'instruction
alors continuons je passe tout de suite
la parole au docteur or saulnier
virologues indépendante pour un exposé
qui sera le plus con si possible je vous
donne pas de je fais confiance à votre
bonne volonté pour aller droit au but
c'est toujours aux femmes qu'on demande
ça
j'ai c'est du vécu je vous remercie
monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames messieurs les députés
j'ai quelques diapositives a présenté je
vais je
je sais que j'ai un
nom jeu ça va être ça va être rapide
vous allez loin donc du coup je vais
balayé assez rapidement pour respecter
mon temps de parole qui est de 5 minutes
du coup je vais commencer par parler
alors est ce que ça fonctionne quand je
passe les diapos oui
donc tout simplement s'il ya
d'introduction pour vous dire que je
parle en mon nom propre
et je vais commencer par vous parler de
l'impact socio-économique de la
tolérance des vaccins qu'ovide en
mentionnant dans un premier temps
l'absentéisme post vaccinale qui s'étend
de 1 jour à plus de trois jours du fait
de l'incapacité à travailler et qui
concerne 20% de la population en général
et jusqu'à 37% sur du personnel de
de santé face du personnel hospitalier
et on observe que l'arrêt réacteurs
génie site est plus élevée sur les
sujets les moins à risque de kovy de
graves
concernant la
halle et le recueil des événements
indésirables en france et il est basé
sur du déclaratif donc c'est un
dispositif passif c'est la même chose en
europe et aux us 1 aux usa cependant on
a un recueil qui est également actif sur
un suivi de quasiment 8 millions
d'individus en france 25% des événements
indésirables sans grave qu'on peut
mettre en regard de 6% pour un vaccin
grippal et lorsqu on compile les données
qui sont dans les rapports spécifiques
publié par la nsm au 28 avril 2022 et
j'ai porté tout le détail dans les
diapositives en annexe si vous le
souhaitez on observe un effet
indésirable grave toutes les 1434
vaccination qu'ovide un décès tous les
28 1300 vaccination qu'ovide qu'on
pourrait mettre en parallèle avec la la
grippe c'est à dire un sur six cent
soixante mille et une hospitalisation
toutes les quêtes
1430 vaccination qu'ovide et pour la
grippe c'est un sur cent vingt mille on
peut mettre ces hospitalisations en
regard de l'europe une hospitalisation
tous les deux 1651 et aux états unis
avec ce fameux système de recueil actifs
qui s'appelle v safe une hospitalisation
toutes les 2600 764 pour la dose 2 qui
s'ajoute à un sur trois mille cinq cent
soixante treize pour la première dose
certains auteurs pour mieux qualifier
les évènements post vaccinaux ont
comparé les vaccins qu'ovide et grippe
et ils ont travaillé un nombre
équivalent de vacciner vous sont portés
ici les chiffres du vaccin pfizer avec
les les événements les plus les plus
marquants donc c'est l'histoire du
risque relatif ses seins donc
on aboutit à risque relatif c'est à dire
que
pour revenir un risque par individu
puisque le nombre de population n'est
pas le même c'est ça donc du coup sûr
remporter les cinq catégories
principales pareil vous avez le détails
en annexe et pour montrer ici que le
risque relatif
qui vous en ôter à côté des différentes
typologies pour audrey vigilance eva air
sont importants entre le vaccin et à rnm
et les vaccins antigrippaux et qu'on va
de risque relatif de fois gratuite à
foix 926 en fonction des catégories
si on s'intéresse
au mieux aux péricardite dont on a déjà
pas mal parlé aujourd'hui
on voit que cet événement indésirable
grave a été signalé par la haie-vigné
dès la mi-août 2021 avec une incidence
de mios péricardite 20 40 fois
supérieure à celle attendue en
population générale principalement pour
les jeunes nous sommes chez les 18 24
ans on a une une péricardite sur 3500
vacciner coville sur la base canadienne
qui est vraiment très intéressante
puisqu'elle est stratifié par âge et par
dose et qu'elle couvre toute la durée de
la vaccination c'est à dire les 17 mois
de la vaccination chez
pour le verse aux états unis on a une
étude qui montre que les 12 15 ans en co
morbidités c'est une myopie ricard dit
sur 6000 vacciner ce qui est largement
supérieur au taux d'hospitalisation pour
qu vide qui est de 1 sur 16000 on a
observé également d signale proches sur
les vaccins files heures et modern a
alors qu'aujourd'hui seul ce dernier est
suspendu pour les moins de 30 ans est
également observé que des lésions
cardiaques
persistante était observée chez les
adolescents qui étaient suivies
plusieurs mois après cet événement grave
concernant la mortalité toutes causes on
a des signaux à suivre et à investiguer
on a eu une étude observationnelle qui
montrent une association entre les
appels pour les arrêts cardiaques des
syndromes coronariens aigus chez les 16
39 ans et le déploiement de la
vaccination covin en israël et non pas
l'infection donc ça c'est une étude qui
est observationnelles et critiqua avec
qui mériterait d'être investis et non
avant excusez moi en revanche ce que
vous avez dit il je vous coupe pour
qu'on ait vraiment des non pas
l'infection c'est à dire que s'ils n'ont
pas en ayant par ailleurs avec
l'infection accords montrent une
association hockey avec le déploiement
de la vaccine d'accord très bien merci
voilà en revanche c'est ce que je vous
disais il ya une autre étude
intéressante qui est une étude danoise
qui elle s'appuie sur les essais à haut
niveau de preuve donc les essais averses
étaient randomisés contrôlés
et qui montrent que les vaccins à rnm
n'ont pas été associés à une réduction
de risque global de la mortalité toutes
causes et ce du fait selon les auteurs
des décès de cause cardiovasculaire
est donc là je ont conclu
à court terme du coup on voit que les
vaccins qu'ovide ont des effets
immédiats impactant avec un absentéisme
qui est important on a vu également la
pertinence du recueil actif des des
effets indésirables mais également il
serait intéressant de vous montrer
l'intérêt de ce recueil actifs sur le
suivi des effets indésirables et cc à la
diapositive 11 à moyen terme on voit que
les vaccins qu'ovide représentent une
proportion inédite d'effets indésirables
graves et là on peut
[Musique]
ils sont enfin du fait notamment des ces
attestée par le nombre
d'hospitalisations observée en france
inquiète de plus de douze mille
personnes ce qui représente une
multiplication faut à 25 par rapport à
la grippe par exemple
on observe un rapport de risque élevé
par rapport aux vaccins grippaux il y à
des signaux à suivre on a donné
l'exemple de la cardio si toxicité de la
rnm vaccinale et de sa formulation qu'on
aurait pu évoquer la neurotoxicité ou
d'autres choses concernant le long terme
donc les effets à long terme ne sont
actuellement pas documentés dans les
essais cliniques à disposition et on
s'interroge notamment sur l'impact de la
stimulation répétées du système
immunitaire par les différents rappels
vaccinaux il ya il y aurait beaucoup de
choses à dire donc je vous remercie de
votre attention je vous demande juste
les annexes
la bibliographie
excusez moi qui ai deux quais documenté
ici la synthèse
de toutes les données de l'année c'est
ici
ça c'est la comparaison valeur ses draps
vigilance vous avez toutes les dates a
qui sont compilés et enfin l'intérêt
aussi du système vsf pour le suivi et
pour jaillir le niveau d'information que
ça peut donner notamment les
téléconsultations les passages aux
hôpitaux c'est quand même un sur 340 les
passages aux urgences est bon ça n'est
qu'une coupure de ce qui est dans
l'article c'est extrêmement documenté et
sa montre voilà le niveau d'information
qui peut être apportée je vous remercie
de votre attention je voudrais juste
rajouter puisque j'ai pas pensé à
mentionner mes liens d'intérêt donc je
n'ai pas de liens d'intérêt avec ce
travail et je remercie aussi les
contributeurs qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette analyse je vous remercie merci
docteur sonné félicitations pour votre
concision pour le coup très
impressionnante
[Musique]
oui c'est peut-être industriel oc
c'est c'est mérité je crois
ce n'est de la pauvreté
oui merci beaucoup donc on va laisser
les changes contradictoires se faire moi
je voulais quand même
pointé un des sujets qui est quand même
la question du rapport bénéfice risque
individuel à racault a rapporté au
rapport bénéfices risques collectifs et
est-ce que c'est pas sur ce sujet tout
particulièrement qui est un peu le noeud
du du du système de tout ce qui se passe
est-ce que c'est pas sur ce sujet
particulièrement qu'on aurait dû ou
qu'on devrait faire plus oeuvre de
pédagogie parce que je sais c'est très
compliqué mais le bad le rapport
bénéfice risque individuel et pas
forcément quelque chose d'intuitif
vis-à-vis du rapport bénéfice risque que
collectif
et en ce qui concerne les enfants en
tout cas clairement
ces deux sujets ont été mis en balance
donc je vois là je vous soumets cette
question et ce sujet parce que quand on
parle de banamba rapport bénéfice risque
que finalement on parle de tout un tas
de choses et on parle pas toujours de la
même chose et que l'ambiguïté
viens viens de cette question et puis
pour revenir sur ce que vous avez
présenté
madame qui est très bien présenté on
entre le risque relatif de deux vaccins
il lutte était indispensable pour ce
fameux rapport bénéfice risque de
montrer le risque relatif entre la
grippe et lakovic 19 et danser dhimmis
des mentions de variants puisqu'en
réalité le bénéfice et le risque se
calcule par rapport au risque de la
maladie elle-même donc est-ce que c'est
ce que ces travaux là où ont été fait ou
est ce que vous pensez que ces
éléments sont sont accessibles alors ils
sont enfin on doit sans doute pouvoir
documenter cette question
ce qui est
qui est certain c'est que avant de
parler de bénéfices risques il faut
voilà l'idée c'était de vous comparer
les risques et de d'espérer améliorer le
risque qui est actuellement observés qui
est assez important voilà
on est entre les vaccins c'est à dire
qu'on est vraiment sur un vaccin qui est
très bien connu avec un tropisme qui est
comparable
et un vaccin qui est nouveau qui peut
éprouver avec un procédé moins bien
maîtrisée
oui tout à fait
disons que je me suis focalisé sur le
risque du coup je peux pas vous répondre
sur la partie bénéfices mais c'est des
choses qu'on peu documenté évidemment
merci bien merci continuons le
contradictoire et dont de suite la
parole au professeur alain fischer
merci
quelques minutes je veux juste remarqué
sur les trois interventions si on suit
les trois interventions que nous avons
entendu en gros les responsables des
autorités sanitaires de tous les pays
européens des etats-unis du canada de
l'australie sont des gens qui me
permettait de continuer est ce que je
fais ce que je peux glisser si vous
payez laissant la parole était
professeur fisher qui l'ont dit les
flammes interrompre sinon je peux aussi
parler d'autre chose
absolument
bien donc les dans les différents pays
où riches qui ont la chance de disposer
de vaccins où il n'y a pas eu comme dans
d'autres pays des manifestations pour
obtenir des vaccins qui n'avaient pas eh
bien ces différents pays où peu ou prou
mener la même politique avec des nuances
et on peut en discuter elles sont très
intéressantes ces nuances mais
globalement ils ont mené la même
politique c'est à dire utiliser les
vaccins disponibles tout d'abord pour
les personnes prioritaires tant que
c'était qu'il n'y avait pas de quoi
vacciner toute la population et ensuite
de proposer la généralisation de la
vaccination y compris aux adolescents y
compris aux enfants tous les pays toute
l'europe occidentale toute l'amérique du
nord l'australie le japon enfin on
pourrait continuer comme ça donc moi je
veux bien que tout le monde se trompe ou
que tout le monde est criminel l'extrême
limite si on pousse le raisonnement je
pense que ça amène à réfléchir et ça
suggère qui est quand même derrière tous
ces pays des experts qui connaissent un
tout petit peu la vaccination qui
connaissent la santé publique qui
connaissent l'épidémiologie et qui ont
apporté des bases concordantes pour
proposer cette politique qui étaient
mise en oeuvre dans tous ces pays avec
succès en terme de protection contre
l'infection ça c'est une vraiment le
général qui a trait à mon avis aux trois
présentations j'aurais peut-être revenir
plus particulièrement sur celle de
monsieur alaïa et quelques points que
j'ai noté il n'y a pas le temps tout où
je ne peux que m'inscrire en faux sur un
certain nombre de ces affirmations
la première s'est il dit la
communication à l'égard des effets
indésirables étaient non loyales je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire en
l'occurrence je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
il ya une communication au contraire
extrêmement rapide complète et peut-être
d'une certaine façon je vais dit
contre-productive surtout les effets
secondaires
indiscutable et ceux ci dont encore une
fois malheureusement et jeu mais je ne
regrette pas qu'ils ont été ainsi mais a
rendu un vaccin inopérant en france
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé dans
d'autres pays mais je vois pas en quoi
elle a été non loyales puisqu'elle a été
on ne peut pas être plus transparents et
rapide ce qui a été fait ou puisque les
poulets
la pole l'expression publique a été fait
dans les heures ou jours qui suivent
elle les allées les observations pardon
si moi j'ai un chat dans la gorge c'est
pas très grave arrive à tout le monde
la deuxième est de dire que la campagne
la campagne de vaccination a cherché à
privilégier systématiquement la
vaccination générale aux dépens des
personnes fragiles je suis désolé de
dire que c'est absolument faux du 27
décembre 2020 premier jour de
vaccination jusqu'à la fin mai un 2021
c'est à dire ça fait cinq mois ci je
compte bien avec merci beaucoup
vaccination a été réservé selon les
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé les autre etc peu importe
aux personnes fragiles en commençant par
les plus fragiles et plus âgées les
personnes n'est pas des pieds en
décroissant progressivement et il ya
même d'emblée dès janvier il a été mis
en place la vaccination des personnes
les plus vulnérables immunodéprimés et
c'est donc c'est juste faux de dire
qu'on a privilégié la vaccination la
population en général ce n'est que moi
de fin mai alors qu'une fraction
importante du pardon des personnes à
risque avait déjà été vaccinées qui a
été entrepris une action gdaxi nation
général fondée sur des observations
liées aux essais cliniques et aussi des
études en vie réelle d'autres pays
montrant qu' il y avait un risque s'il
était infiniment plus faible pour la
population générale a contracté la
maladie et deuxièmement parce que je
n'étais jadi mais je me permets de le
répéter c'était encore plus fort en 2021
qu'aujourd'hui parce que les virus de
l'époque les témoins transmissibles il y
avait un effet de protection collective
même si on n'a pas atteint bien sûr une
immunité collective mais en vaccinant
des jeunes de 30 ans ou de 40 ans ou de
20 ans peu importe où des ados on a
aussi protégé leurs grands parents ou
leurs je ne sais pas là une quelqu'un
qui a une transplantation rénale dans
leur environnement
donc je m'inscris en faux contre ce
point et ensuite
je fais remarquer que pour les
populations à risque les résultats sont
parfois insuffisants c'est clair on
n'est pas élu était mieux que plus de 80
il y a que 10 puis à 10% personnes de
plus de 80 ans qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés c'est un échec relatif quand
même faire remarquer que 90 % l'ont été
mais c'est vrai que c'est un échec
néanmoins un relatif néanmoins la grande
majorité des personnes fragiles ont été
vaccinées plus de 90% de les données de
la cnam le montre atteints de maladies
chroniques savez beaucoup de monde en
france 1 17 million de personnes ont été
complètement vaccinés
il ya une lacune pour les malades
dialysés où il ya une difficulté
indiscutable mais enfin la l'immense
majorité des personnes à risque ont été
vaccinées et se continue heureusement
d'être vacciné et cela inclut ça a été
la toute première priorité et chacun se
rappelle la vaccination des personnes en
ehpad qui n'était pas quelque chose à
mettre en route de façon simple donc
troisième point où je suis je suis un
peu étonné des propos concernant les
enfants et les adolescents ou en gros on
a dit on a inventé
une justification à ces deux lacs six
nations parce qu'on voulait à tout prix
mettre en avant l'unité collective qui
était un argument mais certainement pas
l'argument numéro 1 il ya deux arguments
connus qui ont été mis en avant un qui
été évoquée mais à rebours qui est la
protection contre les conséquences de
l'absence de scolarité et les risques
donc d'isolement des enfants grâce à la
vaccination je suis assez étonné
d'entendre que c'est la vaccination qui
entraînait les problèmes de santé
mentale des enfants d'abord parce que
pour les moins de 11 ans ils sont
toujours pas vaccinées donc la prime de
santé mentale c'est sûrement pas la
vaccination qu'ils engendraient et
d'autre part on sait que pendant la
première phase de confinement donc bien
avant la vaccination le taux
d'augmentation de suicide deux
tentatives de suicide des adolescents
tous les médias de tous les hôpitaux de
france m'ont dit à augmenter
considérablement ce n'est pas la
vaccination qui a entraîné les troubles
mentaux des enfants des adolescents
celle isolement les conditions de vie de
ces enfants notamment de ceux les plus
défavorisés donc la vaccination pouvait
s'y passe était parfait mais était
mesure raisonnable a proposé et puis
surtout monsieur allah vous oublier
complètement le fait que même si c'est
un risque faible il ya des enfants qui
font défendre ap il ya mille enfants en
france qui ont été hospitalisés pour ce
qu'on appelle le syndrome pims d'une
pathologie inflammatoire propres enfants
heureusement il n'y a qu'un seul qui est
décédé mais c'est déjà un trop et ses
1000 cas impliquent des enfants une
période où la vaccination existe on peut
regretter qu'il n'ait pas été vaccinés
ce qui aurait évité les hospitalisations
des séjours en réanimation voire
peut-être des séquelles donc il y a
évidemment il est beaucoup plus faible
que pour les adultes et à fortiori les
personnes âgées mais il y à un bénéfice
individuel direct pour les enfants qui
justifiait cette vaccination
malheureusement la société française de
pédiatrie n'a pas suivi de façon
adéquat de cela je le regrette mais on
constate que dans les pays voisins la
vaccination des enfants s'est déroulé
continue de se dérouler et cela se passe
se passe bien
quatrième point la stratégie de la peur
pour la communication fondée sur
l'exagération des risques d'un côté la
minimisation des effets secondaires
honnêtement je peux pas laisser passer
ça vire on a des données des centaines
de publications scientifiques sérieuses
sur les essais cliniques les études
observationnelles les études négatives
qu'ils contrôlent que j'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure qui tout dans de nombreux
pays dans différentes classes d'âge pour
en stratifié comme vous le souhaitez par
âge pas risque de morbidité etc qui
démontre l'efficacité la vaccination
évidemment elle est plus forte chez des
personnes particulièrement à risque mais
elle existe dans toutes les classes
d'âge je n'y reviens pas et il n'y a pas
eu non plus à linverse de minimisation
des effets secondaires donc je suis un
peu étonné qu'un collègue
d'universitaires je suis également
universitaire je suis également de la
recherche je connais un peu
l'immunologie et part je suis pédiatre
pour ce qui est des camps d la situation
des enfants évoque ce genre de choses il
a été évoqué le fait que 4 à 20% des
patients qui ont développé des
myocardite poste vaccination était en
réanimation je n'ai jamais vu ces
chiffres je pense que c'est très
inférieur effectivement elles sont dans
l'immense de l'immense majorité des cas
bénins donc voilà je vais m'arrêter là
je suis pas sûr que j'ai envie de
continuer parce que c'est le même et ça
continue après la même façon avec 2 le
jeu juste là où j'ai été mis en cause
personnellement quand même je pense que
dans ce cas là je réagis monsieur
oubli l'on m'avait remis en cause de
reprise donc je réponds oui le code
je réponds si vous permettez vous
indiquant qu'on a on a vacciné les
populations sans leur demander leur avis
je pense je crois que c'était à propos
des immunodéprimés je peux parler
c'est juste totalement fausse et
personnes aucune personne a été vaccinée
et de force déjà ça serait assez
difficile on leur a demandé mais je vous
suggère d'entrer en contact avec les
associations de malades atteints
d'insuffisance rénale transplantation
rénale de maladies auto immunes et ou de
cancer de lymphome c'est pas tout à fait
le discours qu'ils tiennent ils disent
qu'ils disent le discours inverse on n'a
pas été assez sollicités encore même si
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été vaccinées
mais ils disent parfois on a eu du mal à
obtenir une réponse des médecins en
faveur la vaccination donc c'est juste
exactement le contraire de ce que vous
avez prétendu et le dernier point je
m'arrêterai là je veux pas évoquer tous
les autres points qui sont inexactes
mais ce serait trop long vous dites vous
êtes allusion à une autre où on parle
des cas de kloster en ehpad c'est pas
parce qu'il ya des quatre clusters que
la vaccination inefficaces
personne n'a jamais prétendu que la
vaccination est efficace à 100% mais à
nouveau la littérature est riche de
dizaines de papiers qui montre que la
vaccination et c'était une bonne
nouvelle d'ailleurs on craignait qu'il
n'en soit pas ainsi avant le début de la
campagne vaccinale mais que la
vaccination est efficace et protège les
personnes très âgées contre les formes
graves de la maladie et enfin tout
dernier point
peut pas être trop long mais madame
saunier je pense que quand dans le il ya
événement est un événement c'est pas un
effet et je pense qu'il faut faire
extrêmement attention c'est toute la
discussion je pense que peut-être vous y
reviendrez total chantal
n'importe quoi christelle c'est pas
grave entrée en 13 juil intervenir entre
événement effet il ya une grande
différence c'est qu'ils ont fait si on
suit vos chiffres on arrive à des
chiffres absolument astronomique de
spitz alisation et de décès liés à la
vaccination qui ne tiennent pas la route
ni en france ni dans le monde je suis
désolé je m'arrête là où merci beaucoup
professeurs
la l'a bien compris que vous devez
partir dans quelques minutes la
sénatrice florence lassarade
oui merci moi je vous remercie quand
même à tous pour la qualité de vos
contributions et je pense que dans une
période où la la l'épidémie a ralenti où
on n'est peut-être pas là on est
peut-être à la veille d'un autre d'un
autre épisode mais notre rôle était
aussi de
comment dire d'essayer d'apporter un peu
de recul et je pense que ce qui est
important dans tout ce que vous avez dit
les uns et les autres c'est la
temporalité c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
juger
avec l'oeil d'aujourd'hui on est sorti
d'une période vraiment critique des
faits qui se sont passés il ya deux ans
à 18 mois il ya quand même aussi une
notion de tombes de temporalité qui doit
intervenir pour ce qui est de l'enfant
on n'est pas tous même pédiatre et je
suis pédiatre forcément d'accord avec
tout ce que vous avez proposé mais moi
j'entends des arguments de quelqu'un qui
est confrontés tous les jours à des
pathologies très grave à des malades
qu'il faut malgré tout protéger les
pulls et puis comment dire les plus
fragiles d'entre nous sont pénalisés par
actuellement l'arrêt du port du masque
ainsi on est on est content de plus
porter le masque mais la vaccination
c'est un désert un des éléments de
protection on a progressé dans le
diagnostic par exemple du pime ce nom
vous parliez qui qui permet à tout média
de maintenant de d'être à la alerté mes
médecins généralistes sur les sur les
symptômes qui fait qu' il n'y a plus eu
de décès par pim ce dont je pense que
tous les tous les aspects de la question
ont progressé mais nous notre notre
sujet c'était vraiment les effets
secondaires y compris les effets
relativement mineures non qui ne
conduisent pas forcément un dessin une
hospitalisation mais nous avions quand
même à coeur de 2
mettre en évidence tout ça et je pense
qu'il ne s'agissait de condamner
personne mais par contre un échange
telle qu'on vient de l'avoir je pense
que ça peut aider à faire progresser les
choses je vous en remercie
attendait d'abord en le faire dans
l'ordre d'abord les alors sauf que qui
pour vérifier qui a une obligation de
départ donc 17h30 en habit noté alain
fischer les autres pouvaient rester un
peu plus longtemps
un petit peu plus longtemps mais pas
beaucoup
alors nous pouvons organiser une mais
vraiment un élément en très rapide donc
je vais redonner la parole au docteur
mli le docteur saulnier pour une très
rapide je parle ici de deux trois
phrases pour répondre et puis une
conclusion aussi de façon à dire arriver
vers une vers une clôture de débats en
ce qui concerne pas le contradictoire
impliquant le professeur fisher a déjà
même excusez moi si c'est possible si je
répondrais bien professeur a là aussi
pareil de trois phases a déjà un
professeur fisher lorsque je critique ce
que vous dites c'est pas une attaque
personnelle c'est un débat d'idées donc
que j'aurai sur les idées
justement pas le problème
attendez attendez depuis j'ai du coup ça
je suis en effet je suis je passe contre
attendez attendez attendez tandis que
vous dites je termine la lysine lorsque
vous dites que
tout le monde a vacciné donc le produit
est bon je veux enfin je vous rappelle
que les critères d'évaluation des
médicaments ne dépendent pas
d'une célébrité médical ne dépendent pas
de la pluralité des utilisateurs je vous
renvoie à la sphère vioxx qui est émis
je pourrais vous rappelez affaires vioxx
la sphère thalidomide la sphère
distilbène et les exemples ne manquent
pas
pour les plus de 75 ans je vous invite à
lire ce qu'avait publié la haute
autorité de santé et le 23 décembre 2020
d'un 2020 elle nous dit clairement qu'il
n'y avait pas assez de données pour
trancher
c'est la haute autorité de santé c'est
pas moi qui le dis vous dise qu'il
n'avait pas d'obligation je suis désolé
mais je ne sais pas dans quelle vie moi
personnellement je vois que des gens
obligés quasiment la plupart en tout cas
un passé lac sinal puisse sanitaire puis
vaccinale pour aller manger un sandwich
pour aller faire du football l'enfant
dans l'enfant en question dont je vous
ai parlé qui avait perdu la vue et c'est
vacciner pour continuer à jouer au
football
l'obligation pour les problèmes de santé
ça j'en parle pas
le cluster je suis désolé mais le seul
critère juridique qui permet d'imposer à
une population une obligation c'est si
le vaccin permet d'empêcher la
transmission virale si c'est uniquement
une protection personnelle contre les
formes graves notamment à supposer que
cette protection soit démontrée
juridiquement c'est impossible je vous
rends là non mais voilà pouvait conclure
s'il vous plaît alors pour les enfants
les enfants je suis désolé vous reprenez
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
en décembre 2021 moi je les consulte et
il est c'est écrit comme sa population
pédiatrique
l'agencé européenne du médicament à
différer l'obligation de présenter les
résultats des études et dans la liste
suivante on autorise quand même donc
cela qu'on m'explique comment on peut au
4e autorisé un produit alors que les
résultats des études ne sont pas entre
les mains de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments
il est entendu merci monsieur l'île
madame souligné
oui je vous remercie
moi j'avais je veux juste revenir sur le
fait que ce soit certes une
contradiction mais c'est surtout une
contribution donc l'idée c'est quand
même que la discussion soit positive
je suis intervenu sur principalement les
risques et pas effectivement le bénéfice
mais voilà c'est le risque que j'ai
souhaité mettre en valeur aujourd'hui il
est évident que la vaccination est un
outil indéniable de santé publique donc
c'est pas du tout ça qui est à remettre
en cause ici j'ai suffisament
suffisamment travaillé dans l'industrie
de la vaccination pour pour tenir cette
position facilement
donc quand finalement quand on aura des
risques qui sont acceptables on sera
quand même beaucoup plus beaucoup plus à
l'aise pour parler de bénéfices risques
par rapport à la maladie et ça ça doit
est étudié par tranche d'âge par dose et
et faire quelque chose qui soit ajustée
à l'individu en fait parce que pour
certaines tranches d'âge et certaines
populations
on a des risques qui sont supérieurs aux
bénéfices
merci même souligné professeur à la et
je tiens quand même à préciser que les
événements enfin voilà les léser les
tableaux qu'on a effectués sont imputés
puisqu'ils sont présentés comme des
effets indésirables par l'asm donc on
n'a fait que reporter les chiffres de
l'ine sem et si tel n'était pas le cas
de toute façon on a parlé de décès et
d'hospitalisations
ces chiffres sont en cohérence sur les
différentes bases de données et je pense
que quand on en est à l'hospitalisation
et à des déclarations d'événements dans
le cadre d'un hôpital c'est que la
gravité est bien présente donc voilà je
voulais juste revenir sur la
caractérisation
de l'événement c'est important
alors attendez mais on a bien noté votre
mac monsieur oumlil professeur à la
mi-mai mais merci de me redonner la
parole donc j'essaierai d'être plus bref
que tout à l'heure j'ai bien compris le
message donc sur sur deux trois points
quand même soulevé par par monsieur
fisher d'une part sur la stratégie de
vaccination collective versus personnes
à reese hoffa les faits sont têtus
nous avons le paradoxe en france 2 une
meilleure couverture vaccinale chez les
adultes jeunes que chez les plus de 80
ans d'avoir la pire en europe de l'ouest
tous les pays européens d'europe de
l'ouest contre 95 et 100 % de personnes
de plus 80 fax de plus de 80 ans
vaccinée nous on en a oscillé entre
entre 85 et aujourd'hui 90% donc on est
on est un échec relatif donc on peut se
dire verre à moitié plein on a 90 %
sectionnée mais on a toujours beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes fragiles y compris
socialement aussi un sdf et autres
personnes vulnérables socialement qui ne
sont pas vaccinés et qui sont à fort
risque d'être infecté et qui sont un
fort risque de formes graves et ce qui a
contribué à plusieurs dizaines de décès
par jour encore aujourd'hui on met 2022
donc les frais sont têtus la stratégie
globale n'a pas permis de protéger de
façon optimale les personnes les plus
fragiles mais si lié au levier aussi et
à la façon de les mettre en oeuvre
deuxième point sur pourquoi vacciner les
enfants et l'immunité collective
c'était quand même un argument est le
premier argument mis en avant et je me
permets de leur cité monsieur fisher en
mai 2021 j'ouvre les guillemets faute
d'adultes en nombre suffisant il va
falloir se vacciner les enfants fermez
les guillemets donc c'est une citation
tronquée je suis un départ dans un bar
étant juste quelques signes chambéry les
liens je vous enverrai le lien et chacun
jugera et enfin troisième troisième
élément sur sur l'évolution de la santé
mentale des français donc effectivement
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est pas le vaccin bien sur lui-même
c'est la stratégie globale incluant la
communication qui a contribué à cette
évolution de la santé mentale qui était
la communication globale sur la crise
c'est qu'il a fallu communiquer sur le
vaccin mais avant on a communiqué pour
faire accepter confinement couvre-feu et
autres mesures de restriction et quand
on voit l'évolution de la santé mentale
des français lié à la communication et
aussi aux mesures comme vous l'avez
souligné de fermeture des écoles de
confinement et c'est malheureusement
la stratégie de la peur est un des
principaux déterminants et quand on
interroge en un travail en cours
d'ailleurs avec des jeunes suicidant
c'est un des arguments principaux c'est
un des motifs super extrêmement fort
d'anxiété des jeunes et pouvant
entraîner des comportements on parle
beaucoup des suicides mais aussi
d'anorexie mentale etc chez les très
jeunes chez les 9 ans 10 en 11 ans 12
ans et le choix de la communication par
la peur faire peur sur les rythmes
fesseur si vous pouvez conclure des
enfants a des conséquences voilà c'est
s'aider vous je vous remercie
merci merci merci merci professeur à la
je fais sur fisher l'an juge je réagis
au moins sûr vous m'avez cité de façon
tronquée ce qui est pas complètement
honnête j'ai toujours mis en avant les
trois arguments en commençant par
l'argument de bénéfices individuels sur
les pim c'est aussi sur les formes
aiguës des enfants fragiles donc je
demande de rectifier et l'instant et je
verrais très là parce que ça près la
dyslexie la discussion comme toujours
dans ces cas-là deviens circulaire entre
discussions qui sont une analyse
critique des faits versus des opinions
je suis désolé de le dire mais on est là
dedans c'est le en ce qui concerne les
prêts mentaux des enfants ils sont
apparus au moment du confinement qui
s'est passé un an avant la vaccination
donc parler la vaccination là dedans je
suis désolé je vais être un peu forcée
sur la malhonnêteté intellectuelle
non je ne dis pas que c'est qu'il
n'existait pas avant c'est ce que je
viens de dire c'est l'ensemble de la
communication depuis le début de la
crise et regarder les chiffres de la
semaine dernière nous avons
nous devons nous devons suivre lors cet
échange avec avec le professeur fisher
c'est très important sur les deux autres
personnes voyagent s'il vous plaît ne
peut pas partir sans que je vous donne
la définition légale parce qu'il s'est
interrogé sur le mont royal professeur
docteur ils nous feront je ferais je
m'engage moi même à faire l'aller-retour
par écrit sur les questions sur votre
question concernant la non loyauté
chiant sur le monde loyal ce que ça veut
dire endroit ça veut dire qu'il ne faut
pas minimiser ni maximaliser les risques
et pareil pour le bénéfice docteur
docteur je m'engage je m'engage à
m'occuper de faire l'aller retour au
niveau de la au niveau de la
transmission et je vous remercie pour
merci pour la question et la précision
est important professeur fisher nous
vous remercions pour votre disponibilité
au delà de l'heure qui était prévu et je
vais nous continuons un petit moment je
vais passer là est ce que les
rapportrice souhaite intervenir
sénatrice nous saluons la sénatrice
florence lassarade qui a accompli sur
cette mission une quantité
extraordinaire de travail ainsi que sur
la précédente et qui se doutait sans
doute pas de à quel point l'engagement
et des êtres extraordinaires merci chers
collègues et interventions de la potée
nancy ok sinon on continue on continue
dans le dans le contradictoire quelques
moments et peut-être que le
docteur christelle ratinier car bonneuil
où le docteur annie pier jonville berra
souhaite intervenir à leur tour
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
laisserais aussi évidemment la parole au
docteur jean ville berra juste quelques
éléments notamment sur le sujet de la
minimisation en effet des effets
indésirables et d'une communication qui
en tout cas été indiqué je crois
notamment par par françois là comme
l'eau je ne reviens pas sur le sujet non
loyal mais non pleinement transparente
je voudrais juste revenir sur le
dispositif qui a été mis en place dès le
tout début de la mise en place en effet
de la campagne de vaccination qui a
d'abord concerné comme cela a été
indiqué par le professeur fisher les
personnes fragiles dès le départ dès la
première vaccination qui de mémoire a eu
lieu le 27 décembre 2020 le premier cas
des vaccinations il y a eu donc un
dispositif renforcé à la fois de
pharmacovigilance mais également de
pharmaco épidémiologie et en effet mes
collègues dessert tv pourront revenir
dessus notamment aussi sur le sujet des
ressources humaines puisque je crois que
c'était une question qui a été qui a été
posé qui a permis en effet évidemment
d'analyser l'ensemble des cas mais qu'il
y ait une communication en temps réel
donc avec une communication en effet
donc de manière quasiment toutes les
semaines au tout début ensuite en effet
tous les quinze jours et donc nous avons
toujours un rythme donc de communication
régulière et récurrentes sur l'ensemble
des effets indésirables qui sont
signalés analysé traité en effet parler
crpv et ensuite discutées au sein de
comité de suivi qui se tiennent en effet
de manière régulière on est à peu près à
plus d'une quarantaine de communication
et avec un dispositif en effet de
communication qui permet d'avoir de
donner accès à la faux professionnels de
santé au grand public il y a toujours
des efforts évidemment de connaissances
notamment du site de l'année scène même
si nous sommes en effet nous essayons
évidemment d'être le plus actif possible
y compris en termes de relais sur les
réseaux sociaux mais avec une
granularité de l'information permettant
d'avoir un accès selon les souhaits des
personnes qui consultent en effet ces
informations et nos documents à la fois
avec des points d'information
synthétique des fiches de synthèse en
effet qui permettent d'avoir des
éléments plus détaillée mais pour autant
dans 1 dans on va dire un format assez
ramassé et puis ensuite comme cela a
déjà été indiqué par mes collègues des
crpv les rapports complets sur l'eau
semble des effets indésirables par ex et
donc c'est dans ce cadre là et cette
communication et ce dispositif en effet
inédit donc de survie de surveillance
mais surtout de communication
extrêmement importante également aussi
nous avons mobilisé c'est important avec
les professionnels de santé avec les
usages et les associations de patients
des webinaires de manière extrêmement
large retransmis aussi sur notre chaîne
youtube qui permet de faire connaître
évidemment ces éléments d'information et
de pouvoir aller
également aussi plus en détails et on
voit bien et je le vois en effet dans
les échanges que l'on aille avec
notamment la deuxième table ronde on a
un sujet cela et je crois que madame la
rapportant vous l'avait indiqué la
communication et le noeud évidemment du
sujet c'est évidemment très important il
y a eu des efforts considérables qui ont
été mobilisés mais nous sommes encore
sur le chemin je partage complètement
une notion de pédagogie de communication
d'informations sur ce que l'on voit ce
que l'on connaît sur ce qu'il y a
évidemment encore à apprendre et et
cette transparence juste pour revenir
sur quelques éléments et après je passe
la parole à madame au 2 janvier de berra
sur le sujet notamment je crois que
c'est le docteur oumlil chi chi le
mentionnait sur les je suis désolé je
vous tourne le dos s'est pas
complètement simple sur le sujet en
effet des différentes
possibles composition notamment du
vaccin on fire je tiens à préciser que
la composition depuis là mêmes est
identique ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui nous
avons plusieurs conditionnement du
vaccin pfizer au tout départ il ya eu
des vaccins donc avec
donc à diluer donc ensuite nous avons
une préparation prêtes à l'emploi et
nous avons en effet une forme également
pour l'enfant et donc de ce qui existe
en effet et ce qu'est mis en ligne et
vous avez indiqué la dette depuis le 26
avril 2022 qui correspond à la mise en
ligne des éléments sur le site de
l'agencé européenne du médicament
puisque je rappelle que ce sont des ae
mêmes qui sont des mêmes centralisée
avec une mobilisation importante des
agences sanitaires mais sais tu n'as
même centralisée de la commission
européenne donc nous attendons y compris
réglementairement la mise à disposition
de ces rcp et notices au niveau de la
commission européenne pour que cela
puisse être relayée au niveau national
et donc on a bien trois présentations
une présentation pour dilution une
présentation prêtes à l'emploi et une
présentation pour l'enfant avec des
durées de conservation qui sont
différentes et celle là ce sont là en
effet des différences eu égard pour
limiter le risque en effet des erreurs
médicamenteuses qui pourrait y avoir
pour les professionnels de santé entre
ces différents flacon il ya des bouchons
violer des bouchons grille donc et viol
a écrit en effet il ya eu toute une
communication qui a été réalisé en effet
par par line et celles en lien
évidemment avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés avec des visuels pour bien
rappeler les différents les différents
en effet flacons et là évidemment pour
éviter au maximum c'est ses erreurs donc
ça c'est un point évidemment important
sur le deuxième point aussi où line et
sem a été mentionné directement par le
docteur oumlil sur le sujet en effet de
du procédé de fabrication et des
questions j'ai je vous ai répondu en
effet j'ai répondu oh pardon c'était un
avocat qui met qui nous avaient saisi
j'ai répondu en effet alors je n'ai pas
répondu que je ne savais pas parce qu'on
est fait en général j'essaye d'avoir les
informations en tant que directrice
générale de une agence de sécurité
sanitaire en effet il est mieux d'avoir
la connaissance et d'avoir les
informations j'ai indiqué que je
transmettais l'ensemble de ses demandes
auprès de l'agencé européenne du
médicament puisque c'est elle en effet
qui détient l'ensemble des données à
nouveau je rappelle que c'est la
commission européenne qui à qui donc
autorisé qui à l'ensemble de ces
éléments et donc et je crois en effet me
rappeler également que la directrice
générale de l'agencé européenne du
médicament a répondu à la demande de de
l'avocat et permettant de mettre en
évidence l'ensemble des éléments qui ont
été précisés j'arrête là parce que sinon
le docteur jean ville berra ne pourra
pas avoir le temps de répondre aux
questions notamment sur le sujet de la
pharmacovigilance
merci
dr ribeiro merci quelques éléments de
réponse à monsieur lille et à madame
sonic mes collègues compléteront
éventuellement l'assaut notification si
vous faites la pharmacovigilance vous
savez très bien que c'est pas un
obstacle à détection de signaux on a
remonté plus de 100 signaux donc je
pense que là sous notification faut
vraiment pas la mentionner ce d'autant
que dans la base mondiale de
pharmacovigilance la france est dans le
top dix des dix plus grands
contributeurs et dans la qualité des
dossiers dans le top 3
donc là sous notification c'est vraiment
plus quelque chose qui est d'actualité
l'imputabilité on l'avait expliqué tout
à l'heure elle n'a jamais été prise en
compte pour l'utilisation des cas pour
les rapports et pour remonter les
signaux et donc dire que c'est une
méthode qui font oublier je pense que là
on a vraiment fait la preuve que la
méthode d'imputabilité c'est pas elle
qui avait fait obstruction à la remontée
des signaux les cas vous avez aussi met
en cause les calculs observé attendu
donc on prend en compte la sous
notification dans les calculs observé
attendu il arrive de multiplier par
vingt ou trente le nombre de cas
observés pour pouvoir le comparer au
nombre attendu mes collègues qui fonda
pharmaco-épidémiologie peuvent pourront
largement vous l'expliquer
les décès faut aussi prendre en compte
alors que dès le premier décès que je
connais très bien pour l'avoir expertise
et la france de l'argent samedi le jour
même une réunion de crise c'était en
fait impropre probable troubles du
rythme chez un patient qui avait de
nombreux noirs et l'éthique suite à ce
décès on a mis en place une procédure
que tous les centres ont utilisé pour
que tous les décès soient documentés de
la même façon l'idée étant de les
catégoriser puisque le vaccin fait pas
mourir par l'opération du saint-esprit
s'il entraîne un décès c'est par un
mécanisme médical physiopathologiques
qui sera un double trouble du rythme qui
serait une réaction allergique ou qui
seraient l'aggravation d'une pathologie
donc dès le début on a pris le parti de
catégoriser cdc pour s'il y avait un
signal pouvoir le remonter le plus
rapidement possible et tous les cas de
mort vite qu'on pouvait attribuer un
trouble du rythme au décours dans les 24
heures qui suit la vaccination ont été
comparés au nombre de troubles de décès
par mort subite qu'on a réussi à
récupérer puisqu'il ya un réseau qui
n'ôte qui prend en charge ces décès qui
les comptabilise afin de s'assurer que
justement le nombre de mort subite par
troublée du rythme dans les heures qui
suivent la vaccination n'était pas
supérieur au nombre attendu dans la
population générale qui joue rappel pour
certaines tranches d'âge peut aller
jusqu'à 100% me le dire quand on est
très âgé on a en gros une chance pour
mille de morue de se faire une mort
subite donc les décès ont été regardées
de très près et c'est vrai qu'il reste
et les décès attribuables aux
complications des effets indésirables
qui ont été rapportés pour la
vaccination sur fisher vous l'a rappelé
les thrombopénie thrombose anton c'est
que malheureusement on a eu des décès à
déplorer au décours de cet effet
indésirable pour répondre à madame
saunier je pense que
la pharma que j'en sais un métier on
sait tous tous les jours tous les cas
qu'on prend en compte et il nous arrive
et on en a eu encore cette semaine nous
en service dès myocardique déclaré huit
mois après le vaccin
huit mois après le vaccin on est sur
pratiquement à 100% que surtout que le
dernier c'était dans un contexte virale
que c'est pas mieux car dit en lien avec
le vaccin
mais comme on ne veut pas prêter le
flanc à la critique on a pris le parti
de garder tout ça ce qui fait que dans
les bases de pharmacovigilance vous avez
moins un nombre d'événements qu'on ne
peut pas rattachée à la vaccination
énorme donc vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
ces chiffres pour les comparer à
d'autres pathologies au faudrait avant
regarder de près cas par cas et là à
prendre en compte l'imputabilité parce
que ces cas on les rentrer quand ils
sont huit mois après le vaccin avec une
note d'imputabilité évidemment très
faible pour pouvoir les comparer une
pathologie spontanée la deuxième
critique je ferais si sur la gravité
alors là aussi pour pas battre le flanc
aux clips pour se mettre à l'abri des
critiques et surtout protéger les
patients on a d'emblée décidé de
considérer comme grave alors la
définition de la pharmaco jans la
gravité en format que j'en sais qui
conduit à l'hospitalisation la
prolongent entraînent des séquelles ou
le décès d'un commun accord entre les
centres on a décidé de codecom
médicalement significatifs qu'il est
transformé en grave les fièvres
supérieures à 40 pas ce qu'ont estimé
qu'avoir 41 après le vaccin c'était
peut-être inattendue les arrêts de
travail prolongé comme on a eu après
astrazeneca c'est à dire que la gravité
faut comprendre que dans la situation
d'un vaccin qui est préventif on a
élargi les critères de gravité notre
objectif c'était là encore protéger les
patients détecté un maximum de signaux
donc vous avez une sur-représentation
des taux gras des faits graves qui est
pas la gravité réelle de ces effets
sépaq les 25% c'est pas des patients
hospitalisés loin de là et alors le pire
giresse et la comparaison avec la grille
parce que si vous êtes d'urologues savez
comme moi que le vaccin contre la grippe
c'est un thé mieux tolérés on vaccine
surtout les gens âgés qui font pas
d'effets indésirables puisqu'ils ont pu
le système lié a di mino sénescence donc
il répond très peu au vaccin donc on
quand on compare à un vaccin ont comparé
deux vaccins qui ont la même cible en
terme de population la grippe c'est pas
du tout la même cible il ya très peu
d'effets indésirables c'est un vaccin
très vieux pour lequel on communique
plus sur les effets indésirables il n'y
a pas eu la communication pour le co
lead donc on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
faire une comparaison pareil c'est juste
un vis-à-vis des patients je pense que
voir vos diapositives pour les patients
moi je fais un tout est faux faux tour
calculé je suis désolé mais je laisse ça
parle à mes collègues parce que je pense
que dans les publications que j'ai pas
regardé de près il ya aussi quelques
soucis oui je je vais prendre la parole
de façon très concise parce que le temps
est précieux oui je souscris bien
entendu à tous qui a dit annie pier des
rajouts vie je pense que si vous mettez
ces diapositives entre les mains d'un
épidémiologiste pharmaco épidémiologiste
et vous en avez auditionné certains lors
des auditions privé le professeur
bernard bégaud le professeur en travaux
pariente le directeur du jc piffard le
docteur mahmoud zureik je pense que ils
resteront sur la même ligne que nous
c'est très étonnant pour pas dire
autrement de faire de telles
comparaisons la population est pas la
même il y a une très forte incitation à
la déclaration j'en passe et des
meilleurs donc je pense que il faut dire
les choses clairement il faut pas être
anxiogène je pense que ces diapositives
sont très anxiogène pour les patients et
je pense que le grand public a besoin de
tout sauf
d'une surexpression des risques surtout
quand ils sont faux quand ils sont juste
on est pour la transparence et les
centres régionaux de pharmacovigilance
ont tous fait parce que là on vous parle
que des cas mais on a eu une très grosse
activité en termes de réponse
téléphonique auprès des patients qui
nous ont rappelé on a eu plus de
cinquante mille appels des patients rien
que pour les vaccins c'est énorme donc
je pense que c'est un peu délétère que
de présenter ces chiffres qui une fois
de plus ne reflète pas du tout la la
réalité dans le même ordre d'esprit vous
vous citer une publication ou les
conclusions sont pas tout à fait ça vous
citer une publication qui est sur cinq
cas de patients qui ont deux jeunes de
jeunes adolescents qui ont fait une
myocardite en parlant d' effets à long
terme ces jeunes et j'ai lu l'abstract
rapidement je la connaissais déjà ont
été hospitalisés ont fait une car dit
sont restés au bout trois jours ou trois
jours tout est redevenu normal même les
cycles de troponine qui normalement sont
au plafond il n'avait plus de douleurs
thoraciques
il n'avait pas d'altération de la
fréquence cardiaque
et oui vous vous faites une irm
cardiaque à quelqu'un deux mois après il
a les stigmates de serre myocardite donc
on peut pas dire il y a à long terme ça
c'est là c'est là c'est la maladie on
sait qu en effet la meilleure car dit ça
met un certain temps à cicatriser et
c'est donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas
surinterpréter des publications
scientifiques d'ailleurs sap a été
publié dans une revue de cardiologie de
pharmacologie parce que sinon elle
aurait été très rapidement balayé les
murs car dit il a aussi il faut dire il
faut dire les choses de façon très
claire et là aussi c'est les centres
régionaux de pharmacovigilance qui est
madame la sénatrice l'a dit en
introduction la façon dont on a eu de
décrire les premières myocardite était
sans équivalent on a dit que c'était des
sujets jeunes on a dit que c'était
surtout à des deux c'était dans des
délais très courts et qu'il n'avait pas
d'altération de la fraction d'éjection
ventriculaire je n'avais pas
d'insuffisance cardiaque associé ni de
troubles du rythme cardiaque associés
alors ça peut paraître technique quand
on parle comme ça mais c'est la première
chose que nous demandent les
cardiologues et c'est la première chose
que nous demandent les parents quand ils
nous appellent ce qui nous fait en effet
donné le qualificatif de myocardite
bénigne alors c'est jamais bien bénin
parce qu'on croit que ce n'est rien oui
c'est quelque chose d'une qualité mais
par opposition aux myocardite graves ou
les patients restent hospitalisés 15
jours les délais d'hospitalisation ont
ensuite été confirmées
population entière grâce à l'étude et
piffard qui a bien montré que les durées
d'hospitalisation et est très courte et
d'ailleurs elles sont courtes non pas
pour la prise en charge de la myocardite
mais pour en faire le diagnostic
un patient au début quand ils arrivent
ils à simplement une douleur thoracique
il faut 48 à 72 heures pour faire le
diagnostic complet c'était la durée
d'hospitalisation
donc ce n'était pas du tout des formes
graves au sens médical du terme au sens
sévérité il n'y a pas eu les
pourcentages en réanimation annoncé donc
là je pense que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
que le souhait de cette audition c'était
une totale transparence et la vérité la
vérité sur les mots car dit c'est celle
que je qu'on vous annonce et celles qui
auraient été confirmés par de nombreuses
publications qu'elles soient françaises
ou internationales
et si je puis me permettre vu un
résident rapidement juste pour répondre
à la question de madame les rapporteurs
ont auparavant rapporté je ne sais pas
sur le l'histoire du bénéfice individuel
du bénéfice collectif va du risque
individuel et du risque collectif
on peut l'illustrer tout à fait avec le
cas de monsieur m lille l'enfant pour
lequel il a donné une expertise sur sa
cécité avec un bilan écologique négatif
effectivement à titre individuel on ne
pourra pas exclure que le vaccin ait eu
lieu et ait eu un lien enfin et pu
provoquer ou ait pu participer à cette
cécité sachant que c'est la réponse que
vous avez eue si j'ai bien compris du
centre de pharmacovigilance pour autant
ça ne veut pas dire que au niveau
collectif il y à un signal et ce signal
non la regarder au niveau de moderna on
a regardé les cas de cécité puisque on
avait eu un cas pareil qui à titre
individuel était marquant le patient
avait un bilan écologique négatif avait
présenté nécessité transitoire a
représenté une cécité transitoire à la
deuxième vaccination donc c'était un
argument fort pour s'interroger et quand
on a regardé les cas de cécité
transitoire conte avec modern a donc on
avait 78 k45 était du trouble visuel qui
apparaissait dans un contexte de réac
tôt c'est à dire dans les 24 48 heures
qui suivaient la vaccination associé
avec de la fièvre des migraines des
céphalées sur lesquels on n'était pas
très inquiet et puis le reste des cas
qui étaient donc des authentiques
altération de la vision alors perdre de
vue mais un transitoire pour lesquels
effectivement on ne peut pas écarter
avec le
bémol que pour tout c'est pour tous ces
cas là il y avait pour beaucoup des
facteurs de risque associés c'est à dire
des conditions qu'ils pouvaient aussi
favoriser la survenue de ces cités et
donc qui ne nous permettaient pas de
faire le lien avec le vaccin donc cédé
qu'à fins et des observations qu'on
continue de suivre pour lequel on ne
peut pas faire le lien en l'état de ce
conte dont on dispose on a très peu de
cas et à part le cas dont je vous ai
parlé avec la réintroduction positif
tous les autres c'est des cas où il ya
d'autres facteurs qui peuvent intervenir
et qui ne nous permettent pas avec
certitude de dire tiens il ya vraiment
quelque chose qui se passe avec le
vaccin est ce que sur ce sujet là qui
est quand même un sujet grave on peut
considérer voilà c'est fait vraiment
partie des sujets graves est ce qu'une
enquête de
pharmacoépidémiologie a été dit est
diligentée par le jc puis phares comme
elle a pu le faire par exemple par comme
le jce a pu le faire pour les myocardite
et pierrick hardy ça c'est pas nous qui
pouvons répondre puisque c'est à lagence
que c'était si mais c'est une question
parce qu'en fait c'est un procès ce
qu'on n'arrive pas non plus tout à fait
à saisir complètement
sur le sujet et merci beaucoup de me
donner la parole parce que je souhaitais
en effet intervenir sur la
complémentarité entre la
pharmacovigilance et la pharmaco
épidémiologie donc en effet les études
de
pharmacoépidémiologie pardon qui sont
menées c'est un programme et c'est un
programme qui évolutif au départ en
effet il ya évidemment à la fois la
partie efficacité de la partie sécurité
et notamment également sur des sujets
par exemple comme les maladies auto
immunes en effet on le sait avec les
vaccins il y avoir un sujet sur
l'apparition de maladies auto immunes et
donc dans le programme il ya le suivi
notamment des maladies auto immunes et
puis le programme du
jc piffard sur la surveillance s'adapte
en fonction des données qui remontent de
la pharmacovigilance très clairement
comme on a lu avec les mots verdict sur
ce sujet là en effet etc on voit en
effet en fonction si on a aussi un
certain nombre de sujets qui remonte
évidemment ça pourrait être suivi par le
jce l'ujc fifa et donc ça s'adapte au
fur et à mesure typiquement aussi sur
les thromboses atypique et donc ça
s'adapte au fur et à mesure en effet
notamment sur le suivi à long terme
parce que ça a été une des questions
nous avons évidemment le suivi à long
terme avec les les déclarations en effet
d'effets indésirables mais on le sait
plus on s'éloigne de la prise du
médicament ou de la vaccination plus la
déclaration est compliquée et donc là en
effet et et ce processus évolue en
fonction donc il ya un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont en cours en cours
d'examen par par epiphane et qui va
pouvoir intégrer au fur et à mesure des
données donc sur ce sur ce point là on
vous fera parvenir donc après après
l'audition la liste en effet des études
précises qui sont en cours et comment
cela peut être peut être adaptée mais on
voit bien en effet
7,7 cette articulation qui est
indispensable myocardite avec une
détection très tôt à nouveau un parent
par la pharmacovigilance française est
ensuite assez rapidement également ce
qui a été mis en place au niveau de la
pharmaco épidémiologie et confirmé
ensuite à distance parce que l'intérêt
en effet avec la pharmaco épidémie c'est
que nous sommes sur des grands noms nous
sommes sur l'intégralité des personnes
vaccinées et puis avec le recul en fait
et donc on avance en fonction du recul
notamment sur l'exposition l'exposition
à la vaccination donc oui il ya un
programme au long cours de suivi des
effets indésirables et de suivi de
manière générale en pharmaco
épidémiologiques remettra les points
spécifiques sur les études qui sont
design et à ce stade il voit là parce
que le sujet c'est qu'il ya des quelques
sujets ponctuels suffisamment grave pour
mériter une étude spécifique c'est
vraiment ça le sujet s'il ya le suivi
global et pia voilà tout à fait
nécessité je veux dire c'est quelques
cernes événement suffisamment rare et
grave pour nécessiter un suivi pharma
pour aller malgré la capacité de le
retrouver évidemment dans le système
national des données de santé et c'est
ça qui est un point évidemment important
typiquement sur sur d'autres sujets
signé il n'y a pas la capacité d'aller
voir dans les bases du fnds puisque l'on
voit beaucoup de beaucoup de choses mais
mais pas tous et donc ça c'est un point
ça c'est un point important et notamment
sur des cas en effet spécifique
j'entends évidemment la cécité mais sur
d'autres choses aussi il y a la
possibilité de mobiliser donc il y à ce
programme qui est adaptée et qui est
évolutif constamment en fonction des
remontées qu'il y a au niveau national
mais pas que puisque nous avons
contribué au niveau national à alimenter
évidemment beaucoup donné au niveau
européen ou mondial il peut y avoir
aussi d'autres choses ou et qui est
intéressant de suivre donc c'est
vraiment cette articulation qui est qui
est importante et
cette collaboration s'y intégrer et si
intriqués a pu vraiment être mise en
place avec avec au vide merci madame a
été générale alors une demande de gérard
le seul le rapporteur une demande de
monsieur lille une demande de madame
souligné
allons-y et puis je vous sélectionnerez
parmi elles allaient il y à des
centaines de questions littéralement qui
sont posées sur la bande plus de six ans
voilà certaines sont certaines sont plus
ou moins des questions genre je vous en
proposerait 2 tout particulièrement un
certain nombre seront transmises par
écrit aux intervenants dans les dés ne
pouvons pas faire bien davantage alors
dans l'ordre gérard le soleil
gérard est ce que tu nous entends ça
fait esprit tu la mettais l'époque
moderne
oui il a baissé la main non
alors en attendant de clarifier la
situation de notre collègue la parole au
docteur oumlil
donc je n'ai absolument d'accord je suis
absolument d'accord sur le fait que
l'évaluation d'un médicament se fait
tant à l'échelon collective qu'est
l'échelon individuel qu'on peut avoir un
médicament qui ne demandent pas intérêt
pour la population générale et qui peut
avoir un intérêt particulier c'est une
petite partie de la population l'exemple
type c'est le thalidomide qui après
avoir été supprimée pour les
malformations qui l'avait entraîné et
les prescrits et les revenus avec une
surveillance stricte et donc là on peut
être d'accord l'inversé est vrai aussi
c'est à dire est le problème c'est que
dans le cas de cette vaccination
générale c'est que les contre
indications
le médecin ne peut plus évalués en
fonction de l'état du patient est en
fonction ces critères de risque propre
qui peuvent déclencher des effets
indésirables imprévisibles notamment
donc on a une liste administrative
établit par l'exécutif générale et
absolue et le médecin moi j'étais plein
de cas de myocardite d'avc dont une
question posée ou sur notre vigilance
avec lequel je travaille
territorialement compétent on a eu un
caramel sont en accueillant ne savait
pas répond il n'avait pas la boule de
cristal non plus un avc après la
première injection
elle passions le médecin qui suivait ce
patient une pose la question est ce que
je peux faire la 12e et moi j'en sais
rien je pose la question on s'entraîne
encore vigilance ils ne savaient pas ils
ne pouvaient pas savoir et puis le sens
pharmacovigilance m'a répondu il faut
que le patient discute avec le médecin
mais discuter de quoi
ensuite
pour l'information
l'information je rappelle les critères
juridiques d'information c'est pas moi
qui les a définis je vous cite donc vous
je vous invite monsieur le président
allait consulter l'article r 41 27 35 et
l'article l mais 111-2 l'information les
critères les caractères de l'information
concernant les risques que dit l'article
l 1111 tirer d'eux il faut lors d'un
entretien individuel et non pas sur des
documents publiés sur des sites auxquels
le patient ne sait pas comment j'allais
faire pour les trouver ce qu
effectivement l'information peut être
disponible mais le problème c'est au
moment de la prescription et en revient
sur les modalités de prescription et de
dispensation pharmaceutique donc
l'information sur les risques voilà ce
que dit la loi il faut avant toute
prescription d'un médicament ou d'un
soin quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
avant une opération chirurgicale
n'importe quel soin à visée curative
diagnostic aux pros préventive il faut
communiquer les risques fréquents ou g
normalement prévisible la prévisibilité
pose question parce que là on est dans
un avec un vaccin qui a été mis sur le
marché
dit là où je devrais être santé avec
seulement 1,1 à un mois et demi de recul
alors qu'une directive de 2001
européenne
stipule que pour pouvoir parler d'un
usage médical bien établies d'un
composant d'un médicament il faut un
minimum 10 ans
il ya une directive
alors ensuite quand ce n'est pas fini le
juge la jurisprudence administrative et
judiciaire ajoute risque il faut
communiquer aux passions les risques
fréquents aux graves même exceptionnel
c'est à dire si vous avez un cas de
paralysie faciale un caddie mieux car
dit il faudrait le communiqué avant de
pouvoir vacciner la personne et surtout
l'afp cette information est pérenne dit
la loi
parent ça veut dire quoi c'est sans
durée c'est une durée limitée est limité
pardon illimitée ça veut dire que si la
personne a été vaccinée et que a
posteriori des effets indésirables
nouveau en été
repérés et reconnu par les autorités il
faudrait rappeler toutes ces personnes
et leur portée à leur connaissance ces
risques d'effets indésirables pour
anticiper justement la réalisation du
risque et ça est-ce que ça a été fait
aussi ça c'est la loi et si le jour dans
l'entretien individuel et non pas sur
bfm ou sur ses news alors je sors sur
l'imputabilité rom lille il faut
l'imputabilité nous allons nous la
dernière chance s'il vous plaît dernière
chose dernière sur l'imputabilité
il ya un membre de la
du comité scientifique pharmacovigilance
de la nacelle qui a démissionné parce
qu'il n'est pas d'accord parce que le
ski était sur la méthode d'imputabilité
qui laisse des cas de côté qui rejoint
la ville l'igas il a démissionné parce
que ce qui était définie dans le rapport
numéro deux du 28 janvier 2021 auquel je
paye la réponse d'ailleurs sur les
quatre décès restaient inconnues et
s'écrit dr muller il s'agit de répondre
oui vous de répondre aux commentaires
des notabilités je suis pas d'accord je
suis pas le seul et d'ailleurs la cge
la cour de justice de l'union européenne
en 2017 elle est venue confirmer ce que
le juge administratif et judiciaire la
cour de cassation avait retenu depuis
2007 2008 c'est à dire que par exemple
le juge administratif il se contente de
la temporalité de réa temporel qui
considère un bref délai c'est de
quelques mois et la cge a défini des
critères qui permettent si vous avez des
indices graves précis et concordants
c'est à dire qui rejoint un peu ce que
ce qui est utilisé par la
pharmacovigilance proximité temporelle
de tout terminer doit vraiment
déterminant proximité temporelle absence
d'antécédents personnels et familiaux
des cas publiés et répertoriés
normalement vous pouvez avoir une
présomption de causalité
merci dr souligné vous vouliez
intervenir de façon ultra concise
j'ai pas dit il très concise mais je
vais essayer de l'être je voulais
répondre à madame
notamment sur le je vous rejoins
complètement pour la grippe et c'est
vrai que l'idée c'était surtout de
trouver un comparatif
l'âge on a regardé un certain nombre de
vaccins pour lesquels on pouvait avoir
une comparaison c'est très difficile
d'avoir cette information là il y en a
pris le vaccin pour lequel on avait le
les effets indésirables les plus élevés
voilà disposition après si vous en avez
un autre à me proposer des données je
serai je serai ravi de pouvoir faire le
en fait c'est juste pour avoir par
rapport au nombre de doses administrées
on a construit votre démarche on
critique
bcc des données publiées parce que je
n'arrive pas en cause la
communion jeu
le rationnel à faire ça parfois nous est
pas couper tout à l'heure je sais ce que
ça serait beaucoup plus simple d'avoir
une discussion je voulais non mais je
vous la corde je vous en prie mais ça
serait beaucoup plus simple des changes
et que finalement pas se parler les uns
après les autres parce que c'est très
difficile après du bras vous pouvez tout
à fait prendre quelques instants après
l'audition pour compléter cet échange
donc c'est vrai voilà je concède la
comparaison à la grippe mais en fait je
vais revenir tout simplement aux données
on on a survolé j'avoue sur le vsf qui
sont vraiment intéressantes parce que là
on a des digues l'information qui est
sur les sept premiers jours qui après
suivi dans le londres dans le plus long
terme on a vraiment quelque chose qui
est juste post vaccinales avec des
systèmes d'interrogatoires de d'alerté
sms etc ça passe par une application et
du coup il ya énormément d'informations
qui sont récoltées notamment sur des
événements qui entraîne des
hospitalisations des consultations des
passages aux urgences etc donc on a
quelque chose qui est voilà que je
voulais mettre en évidence et et qui
pourrait apporter beaucoup
d'informations
je pense que c'est vraiment important de
mieux documenter le risque pour éviter
toute cette
l'éviter la perte de confiance en fait
moi c'est mon seul objectif et c'est pas
sens et pas un autre donc après ma
question ça serait quelque elle a été la
recommandation pour les vaccins et mais
rennes a chez les jeunes hommes en
france
merci docteur saunier je vais en mode
blitz comme on dit
retranscrire également la question
transmises transmises en direct par par
gérard le sol ainsi que deux questions
qui nous ont semblé particulièrement
intéressants parmi les questions posées
par le public je voulais soumet en mode
beats puis je vous permettrait une
dernière expression à vous madame la
directrice générale madame la présidente
là dessus et je dirais que juste
quelques phrases de conclusion question
de gérard le sol
je souhaitais demander s'il ne serait
pas possible de faciliter les
déclarations directes des patients à la
pharmacovigilance
j'ajoute une question ici qui concerne
aussi la pharmacovigilance qui est
transmise par l'auditoire pourquoi ne
pas refaire une recherche en pharmaco
vigilance active étant donné que les
remontées passives sont très fortement
sous-estimés et j'ajoute une autre
question comment se fait-il également
transmises par l'auditoire que les
médecins généralistes soit à peine au
courant des rapports de
pharmacovigilance du vaccin
dernière question de ma part sur
laquelle j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir
vraiment eu une réponse c'est la
question de la question des rapports
bénéfices risques ciblés dans quelle
mesure on peut imaginer un rapport
bénéfice risque pour telle catégorie
d'âge tel type de santé tel autre
évidemment pas rentrer dans un
détails microscopiques parce que en plus
et plus échantillon un petit moins on
perd le bénéfice dans l'intérêt de la
statistique mais c'est revenu plusieurs
fois dans l'audition cette question des
bénéfices pour catégories les uns les
autres je vous laisse dernière
expression je pense que madame x général
c'est vous qui êtes la plume qui avait
une obligation juste après dans quoi
vous donner la parole en premier
juste quelques éléments sur la
déclaration pharmacovigilance patients
elle est possible déjà depuis de
nombreuses années depuis quasiment voilà
deux mille ans dix ans c'est même plus
que même un petit peu plus que dix ans
est d'autant plus facilitée avec la mise
en place du portail unique de
déclaration des signalements qui a été
en 2017 et on le voit bien aujourd'hui
dans les déclarations que nous avons
mais le docteur gilbert a évidemment
complétera où on a en effet des
déclarations à la fois des
professionnels de santé mais aussi des
usagers donc on voit bien la
connaissance et nous avons aussi que
communiquer au travers de la mise en
place notamment d' affiches dans les
centres de vaccination pour informer et
inciter en effet à la déclaration des
effets indésirables donc c'est en effet
connu mais je laisse le docteur gilbert
a complété complétait bien évidemment
bon effectif oui depuis la loi de 2011
les passions la possibilité de déclarer
via le portail mais on en a eu beaucoup
par téléphone aussi donc même les gens
parce que la question s'est posée de
l'accès internet et delà du problème de
la déclaration en ligne les patients
avaient rapidement nos coordonnées ou
pas si par leur pharmacien et on prend
et également les déclarations c'est pas
une déclaration formellement papier par
téléphone on prenait une déclaration
n'est pas pu des patients ce qui nous
permettait aussi de leur répondre tout
de suite voir de les orienter vers leur
médecin donc il ya un service
territorial qui est aussi très important
pharmacovigilance les déclarations
passion c'était déjà c'est en gros 75%
des déclarations qu'on a reçues donc il
ya déjà une partie importante pour le
suivi actif
je pense que
faudrait pour dire on améliore en
mettant en place quelque chose de
proactif ça voudrait dire qu'on n'a pas
été bon quand on voit qu'on a remonté
déjà plus de son signaux voilà faudrait
jeu on a déjà fait la preuve de
l'efficacité
après les systèmes proactif bas
financièrement et là c'est le nerf de la
guerre c'est à dire que ça coûte très
cher de suivre des corps de patients
parce qu'on a beau vous montrer que ses
fréquents les effets indésirables graves
comme d'une grande rareté et s'il faut
suivre plusieurs centaines de milliers
de patients pour avoir la chance de
détecter on a détecté des signes au
potentiel comme les maladies de ville 30
acquise qu'il était un
cible détecté dans un suivi proactif
c'est ça justement l'objectif de la
pharmacovigilance et la puissance de
notre système c'est que même une
pathologie très rare sur deux cas après
cinq ou vingt millions de patients
vaccinés on peut remonter un signal et
on peut pas monter encore poursuivre 20
personnes 20 millions de personnes
vaccinées ou alors faut investir de
façon énorme donc l'argent étant le nerf
de la guerre les centres de pharmaco
jans ayant déjà du mal à fonctionner on
a eu des subventions supplémentaires
pour prendre en charge le suivi mais on
sait que après le vaccin on reviendra
pas l'état basal on aura des gros
problème du financement je pense
qu'avant d'aller financer dé suivi
proactif faut déjà consolidé ce qui
existe ça me paraît le plus important et
qui a fait la preuve de son efficacité
monsieur le président c'est celle pour
compléter votre question sur le rapport
bénéfice/risque cibler et sous le
contrôle de la nes m c'est ce qu'on fait
quand on commence la campagne par
certaines cibles de population en fait
on considère que ces populations ont un
bénéfice supérieur aux autres et donc
typiquement quand on commence la
campagne de vaccination par les
personnes en ehpad ou un lieu celle des
c'est bien parce que ce sont les plus
fragiles vis-à-vis domaine de la maladie
ensuite quand on l'a étendu assez
rapidement aux personnes âgées de plus
de 75 ans c'est parce qu'on considère
effectivement qu'elles ont un bénéfice à
la vaccination qui est supérieur à des
populations plus jeunes et donc on
commence à vacciner ces populations dans
un contexte à l'époque de rareté des
vaccins donc on considère bien que tout
le monde n'a pas le même bénéfice risque
vis-à-vis de la vaccination avec un
bénéfice qui varient en fonction de son
âge et donc en fonction de son
exposition à des risques liés à la
maladie mais vous avez des des
estimations quantitatives d'un pour
différentes catégories de ses bénéfices
risques c'est le travail qui est fait
par les autorités scientifiques et donc
nous on exploite ce travail là en
particulier la haute autorité de santé
qui avait rendu un avis fin du mois de
novembre 2001 qui précisait justement
quelle quelle population il fallait
vacciner prioritairement à vie qui a été
suivie également par les différents avis
du conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale qui nous l'ont permis
effectivement de commencer la
vaccination en priorisant ces
populations fragiles
je vais vous proposer je sais que vous
avez encore monsieur lui-même sol ni
encore des remarques mais je vais vous
proposer de continuer or audition quand
vous aurez des cv des discussions je
crois que nous avons ici des personnes
de
on a déjà fait 3 3 allers-retours 1 vous
savez dans le contradictoire c'est plus
que dans qu'on en fait et qu'on en fait
d'habitude je vous proposais de de co2
continue et or auditions dans le champ
mon travail ici mais ceci monsieur s'il
y a une dernière chose à ajouter non
j'avais juste un élément parce qu'il a
été dit que
il a été dit que on avait une
communication qui était fondée sur la
peur et donc je voulais rétablir les
faits par rapport à ça ça n'a jamais été
la stratégie du ministère d'utiliser la
peur pour la campagne de vaccination au
contraire et tous les spots de
vaccination qui ont été mobilisés dans
le cas de la campagne avait justement
comme thématique plutôt la libération le
vaccin comme outil de libération par
rapport aux contraintes du coc vide et
l'humour a aussi été mobilisés et
d'ailleurs le docteur oumlil l'a
mentionné on a utilisé l'humour à
certains moments dans la campagne de
vaccination donc ce n'est pas vraiment
synonyme de peur
madame saulnier dans votre insistance
vous avez droit à vraiment une
c'est le bénéfice du fait que vous aviez
été ultra consiste dans votre première
intervention et je vais continuer à être
ultra concise je voulais juste rajouter
que les le système de le dispositif
actif en fait et la proactivité à aller
chercher de l'information entre quand
même des signaux beaucoup plus élevé que
ce qu'on a pu voir avec les systèmes
passifs donc c'est vrai que ça c'est
pour compléter votre votre votre
remarque de tout à l'heure et ce qui me
semble important aussi pour compléter
ces que ça apporterait en fait la
dimension de représentativité c'est à
dire qu'on pourrait arriver comme par
exemple avec le réseau sentinelles avoir
quelque chose de représentatif sur sur
la population et sur la france et avoir
une remontée qui soit plus réaliste en
fait et non pas limité à quelques
personnes qui vont déclarer pour tel et
tel raison ou quel que soit niant qu'ils
vont déclarer
[Musique]